GOOD ACTORS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON VOCAL I THINK
IT --
STARTED FOR THE JOINT COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR SOME HUMAN SERVICES
AND SELECT COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE --
AND JUST SO YOU KNOW --
THERE THAT'S OF REALLY BUSY
AFTERNOON SO SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE IN MULTIPLE COMMITTEES AS
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO BE INTO
COMMITTEES LATER AS WELL SO WILL
BE COULD GOING IN AND OUT --
BY SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE SAYS REALLY IMPORTANT
I JUST --
FOR FOR ME --
BUT ALSO FOR YOU KNOW.
GIVING US OPPORTUNITY TO DIVE
DEEPER INTO SO I THINK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY --
AND IT IS AN INFORMAL HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES AND
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND THE FOCUS OF THE HEARING IS
TO OUR THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND POVERTY.
WE KNOW THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AFFECTS PEOPLE OF ALL AGES RACES
ETHNICITIES GENDER AND GENDER
IDENTITIES SEXUAL ORIENTATION IN
INCOME LEVELS.
YA I'VE SHARED WITH MANY OF YOU
THOUGHT THAT MY SISTER IS A
SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND I KNOW THAT --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS AN ISSUE
NOT JUST FOR THE VICTIMS BUT FOR
THE FAMILIES AND SO THAT'S WHY
I'VE TAKEN.
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT
AND REALLY TALK WITHOUT ALL OF
YOU FOR AND TO COME UP WITH
ACTUAL SOLUTIONS ARE SOME.
BABY STEPS I GUESS I WISH WE CAN
FIX IT ALL WITHOUT ONE BIG.
YOU KNOW --
WAVE OF THE MAGIC WAND BUT THAT
ONE ONE DOES NOT EXIST AND I'M
LOOKING TO YOU THE EXPERTS TO
HELP ME.
I WOULD SOME SMALL CHANGES
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BECOME.
A A SOLUTION FOR LEADER AND SO I
THINK AGAIN FOR FOR BEING HERE
--
IE.
I HAVE TO ALSO MENTION THAT ON
THURSDAY I WILL BE PRESENTING A
RESOLUTION AND RECALLING AT
BECAUSE RESOLUTION.
OP PEAKY UNFORTUNATELY WAS A
FIVE YEAR OLD.
A CHILD THAT WAS KILLED BY HIS
OWN FATHER DURING A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE --
DISPUTE THAT MOTHER I ON MY
ESTEVEZ --
IS FROM BOTTOM PARK WHICH IS IN
MICE MY NOT ONLY THE CITY I LIVE
IN BUT IN MY DISTRICT.
AND SHE WENT TO COURT SEVERAL
TIMES ASKING FOR SOLE CUSTODY OF
PEKING.
AND MANY TIMES EVEN TESTIMONY
THAT WAS GIVEN TO POLICE --
HE TOLD THE POLICE THAT HIS
FATHER WOULD KICK HIM THAT WOULD
HURT HIM.
AND ON I WENT TO CORD ASKING FOR
SOLE CUSTODY AND FOR NO
VISITATIONS AND UNFORTUNATELY.
I THE LAW FAILED --
HER AND FAILED BEAKY THE FATHER
TOOK BEAKY. TO DISNEY LAND AND
NEVER RETURNED AND HE WAS FOUND
NINE WEEKS LATER.
IDC'S WHERE THE FATHER HAD --
SUFFOCATED HIM AND BASICALLY
KILL THEM TO HURT.
THE MOTHER BECAUSE DURING THE
MASSIVE VIOLENCE.
ISSUES --
THE INTENT OF THE ABUSER IS
OBVIOUSLY TO HURT NOT JUST
PHYSICALLY PHYSICALLY BUT IN
THIS CASE EMOTIONALLY AND FOR
THE REST OF HER LIFE --
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE I WAS
[inaudible]
I WRITING.
OF THE SPEECH THIS MORNING FOR
FOR THURSDAY BECAUSE IT'S GOING
TO BE VERY EMOTIONAL AND I COULD
NOT STOP THINKING ABOUT.
BEAKY AND EYES THAT S. WHO IS
NOW A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR HER
SON AND FOR OTHER KIDS THAT ARE
IN THE SAME SITUATION.
AND SO.
I TELL YOU THE STORIES AGAIN SO
THAT YOU KNOW I WENT MY
COMMITMENT IS TO THIS COMMITTEE
IT'S NOT JUST A CEREMONIAL
COMMITTEE.
NOT IN MY BOOK.
I REALLY AM TAKING THIS.
NOT ONLY PERSONALLY BUT I'M
HOPING THAT OUT OF THIS WE CAN
PREVENT TRIED TO TRAGEDIES SUCH
AS BIGGIES --
TRAGIC DEATH --
MY A FAVORITE LINE FROM ANA IS
THAT SHE SAYS THAT SHE HAS THE
SHE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING
MOTHER TO BE KEY FOR FIVE YEARS
[inaudible] TWO MONTHS.
A AND TWO DAYS AND SO DI JUST
SITS WITH ME I HAVE MY OWN TEN
YEAR OLD AN ELEVEN YEAR OLD --
CHILDREN THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW I
WOULD BE WALKING AROUND IF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPENED TO
ME OR TO ONE OF MY KIDS SOUL.
I COMMEND ON THE FOR HER
STRENGTH.
AND HER NOW HER ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF HER SON BUT AGAIN I AM
TELLING YOU THIS SO THAT.
YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S NOT JUST
SOME.
COMMITTEE WERE GONNA BE ARE
SITTING AND TALKING ABOUT I HOPE
THAT IN THE TIME THAT I AM IN
THE ASSEMBLY WITH YOUR HELP WE
CAN MAKE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES. TO
HELP ALL OF THOSE FAMILIES SO
WITH THAT --
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY
RANTS I AM PASSIONATE ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL HAVE BEEN DOING AND I THINK
YOU AGAIN --
FOR HELPING ME AND IN THIS
ENDEAVOR BUT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PANELISTS --
WHO HAVE JOINED US TODAY TO
SHARE THEIR EXPERIENCES AND
EXPERTISE AND THANK YOU TO MY
FELLOW MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
JOINING US TODAY?
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM THE FIRST
PANEL -- BOB
ARE COMMITTEES I HEAR SO WHEN I
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS A COMMA
DOUBLES.
STOP SO THAT IF THEY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR ANY OTHER THING TO
SHARE THAT THE THEY ARE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
SO WITHOUT --
CAN OUR FIRST PANEL PLEASE JOIN
US WE HAVE NORBY FLINT POLICY
DIRECTOR FROM BLACK WOMEN OF OF
FOR WELLNESS.
I SHIVA'S MAYES FROM STAND UP
PLEASE SIR.
RACHEL SMITH A LOCAL ADVOCATE
FROM SACRAMENTO AND BATH HOUSE
IT FROM WE'VE THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US [inaudible]
DO.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND%
BEGIN MANY MISTER MACY FLAT AND
I AM THE POLICY DIRECTOR AT
BLACKPOOL FOR WHAT IT IS WHICH
IS A NONPROFIT COMMITTED TO THE
BEING OF BLACK WOMEN AND GIRLS.
BROCADED A LOS ANGELES.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN WE NEED TO BALLOTS FOR
HOSTING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TODAY AND THANK
YOU.
TO THE MEMBER I'LL.
SO I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
A WHERE WOULD STAR IN TALKING
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND AND I WAS
REMINDED.
OF A MEDIUM I WAS OUT WITH
WOMEN'S HEALTH RIGHTS AND
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS.
WHERE WE WERE HAVING A MEETING
AND WHERE?
THE U. WELL THE DUMPSTER FIRES%
THAT WE NEED TO PUT OUT.
AND I BOTH HAVE STATE HOW LUCKY
WE WERE TO BE IN CALIFORNIA --
AND HOW WE HAVE THESE GREAT LAWS
ON THE BOOKS.
BUT IN THOSE LAWS AND THOSE
MARKERS SOMETIMES THAT GETS LOS
AT THE HELP TO BEAR HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH INEQUITIES
PARTICULARLY OF WOMEN OF COLOR.
AND LOW INCOME WOMEN AND I WANT
TO SPEND THAT TIME MY TIME WITH
YOU ABA A FEW MINUTES TODAY
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT THAT INTERSECTION OF WHERE
LOW INCOME WOMEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR.
ARE ARE LOST IN THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE CONVERSATION.
SO I ACTUALLY REVERSED.
MY MY SPEECH TODAY AIR
COMPOSITION SOMEONE OF THAT WITH
THE MICROS GO TO START WITH THE
MEADOW BUT I A SPLIT UP INTO.
THREE AREAS WAS THE MICRO MESO
AND MACRO SO THE GOOD OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AIR TO ALL THE WAY TO
OUR KIND OF OF BECOME CULTURAL
SOCIETY.
OF MOON LEGAL ABOUT THE OF MICRO
LEVEL ARE THE MOST AND OVER THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL ARE THEN PUT IT
WORK OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT OF MY BEST
--
WHO IS IN A TV RELATIONSHIP?
AND IN THE MIDST OF THE BREAKUP
--
HER EX BOYFRIEND HAD CAME INTO A
PLACE TRUSTED PLAYS THROUGHOUT
ALL OF HER CLOTHES.
CHESTER TV DAMAGE* BAD
THROUGHOUT HER MATCH AS IT WAS
AS SHE ADDED SENSUALLY REBUILT
HER LIVE.
WE WERE BOTH IN COLLEGE NEITHER
OF US HAD A LOT OF EXTRA MONEY.
AND SEE ESSENTIALLY NOW NEEDED
TO REBUILD HER LIFE.
SHE ALSO COULD NOT AFFORD TO
MOVE OUT OF HER RENT CONTROLLED
APARTMENT.
AND HER CHILD WHO WAS GOING TO
SCHOOL IN THIS AREA AS SHE DID
WANT TO TAKE HIM OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT THAT AND ALL
THE THINGS IN HURDLES THAT SHE
NEEDED TO GO THROUGH IN TERMS OF
REBUILDING HER LIFE PEOPLE DON'T
THINK ABOUT HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS
TO MOVE.
HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS TO READ BY
YOUR ENTIRE WARDROBE HOW
EXPENSIVE IT IS FOR FOOD HOW
EXPENSIVE IT IS FOR ALL THE
LITTLE THINGS THAT --
WE TAKE FOR GRANTED WHERE.
AND CONVERSATIONS AROUND AND WE
TELL FOLKS WILL WHY DON'T YOU
JUST LEAVE --
LAW WE ALSO TALK ABOUT EMERGENCY
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE FOR EMERGENCY
HOUSING ESPECIALLY WHEN PEOPLE
ARE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE TO
PROVIDE THEIR LOOK OF INCOME
LEVELS ARE OTHER DOCUMENTS THAT
THEY MIGHT HAVE LEFT BEHIND.
ARE WHEN THEY HAVE TO LEAVE
HURRY.
THE FOLKS NEEDED IT ARE IN
THINKING ABOUT HOW FOLKS NEED
ACCESS TO CLOTHING MEDICAL CARE
AND FOOD WE ALSO NEED TO THINK
OF HOW WE'RE AND HAVE LESS ON AN
AUDIENCE [inaudible]
ARE --
HARVARD AND PROCESS IN TERMS OF
FOR SURVIVORS WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING RESTRAINING ORDERS.
AND THEN --
IN APPROVING THE HISTORY OF
ABUSE WHICH IS OFTEN SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO DO IN
ORDER TO GET SERVICE SAYS.
I NEW AND THEN ALSO SPEAKING
ABOUT OUR MANDATE REPORTERS YOU
TALK ABOUT YOUR DOCTORS AND
NURSES AND GIVING THEM MORE
OPTIONS TO THINK ABOUT WHEN THEY
HAVE TO MANDATE.
OF WHEN THEY SEE ABUSE CAN THEY
HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE NOT ACTUALLY
HAVING -- TO
I DO DIRECTLY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS FEARFUL ARE AWAKE
BECAUSE DIFFERENT ISSUES FOR THE
FOLKS THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
SO.
THAT IS THE MACRO BOOKING AT THE
THE MAD SO I WANTED TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE A BECAUSE STATE THAT IS
EXTREMELY HIGH --
PRICEY TO LIVE IN.
AND WE HAVE TONS OF POVERTY OF
THE HAVE TITANS OF HOMELESSNESS
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE
UNDEREMPLOYED AND WHAT THAT
MEANS WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT ARE
IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOW INCOME ARE
LESS LIKELY TO LEAVE AND LESLIE
AND MORE LIKELY TO COME BACK TO
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSE THERE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO WAY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO LIKE BE OUT
IN THE COLD ARE IF YOUR CHILDREN
ARE GOING TO BE OUT IN THE COLD
--
ARE YOU KNOW STAYED IN THIS
PLACE AND SO WILL YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
STRUCTURE ISSUES THAT THE MONTH
SO WE WANNA ALSO TEACHES THAT.
KEEP IN MIND OF THE ISSUES
AROUND.
YOU KNOW HOUSING AND IF YOU
CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE AN AREA THE
NIGHT NOT ONLY A PHOTO --
CAUSES ISSUES IN TERMS OF
HOMELESSNESS BUT THAT ALSO
EXACERBATES PROBLEMS AROUND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND LASTLY I WANT TO FOCUS ON
KIND OF THE MESO ISSUES ARMS YOU
NEED THE MACRO ISSUES.
AND THINKING ABOUT CULTURE WHICH
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DON'T ACTUALLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT OR DON'T ACTUALLY PUT A
LOT OF TIME AND I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY.
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAD SPENT SOME
TIME -- WELL
I WOULD SAY SINCE THE ME TO MOVE
MAY HAVE STARTED THAT WE'VE SEEN
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PATRIARCHY ASIDE GINNY AND OUR
SPACE SAYS.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT HOW
PATRIARCHY AND MISOGYNY
INTERSECTS WITH RACISM AND CLASS
OF THOUGH PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO INTIMATE PRTNER
VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
RAY WHAT IS IN ME WILL BE LOOK
AT FOLKS AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
SAME VALUE FOR THAT.
FREIGHT WHAT IS IT MEAN WHEN
SOMEBODY REPORTS --
SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPY AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT SEEN THEM AS A FULL
HUMAN BE.
AND SO WHEN WE HAVE CONVERSATION
--
RACISM THE CLASS OF THOUGH THEY
ARE TONS OF REPORTS AND I JUST
EXPERIENCED THIS IS ONE OF MY
FRIENDS WHO REPORT IT.
HER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATION.
AND IF SHE WASN'T TAKEN
SERIOUSLY ISSUE WAS LEAKING --
LINKED LOOKED AT AS DIET YOU
SOMEONE WHO IS NOT VALUED --
SOMEONE WHO IS THIS LAKE THOUGH
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THOSE
FOLKS STILL WITH.
AND WHAT HAPPENS WAS HER PLACE
GOT TRASHED YET THE SEND HER
DAUGHTER OFF AND SHE HAS TO
MOVE.
RATE IN THIS OF THE THINGS THAT
--
IS NOT TALKED ABOUT A LOT WHEN
WE SPEAK ABOUT HOW DO WE ADDRESS
RACISM AND CLASSISM AND
PATRIARCHY AND OUR SPACE SAYS WE
ALSO NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW IN
WHICH WE ARE REINFORCING THE
CONVERSATIONS --
WITH OUR YOUTH IN PARTICULAR WE
HAD -- THERE
IS A STUDY THAT CAME OUT.
I'M NOT TOO LONG AGO THAT WAS
LOOKING AT WOMEN --
IS MEET YOUNG FOLKS.
AND ACCESS.
TO PARTICULARLY BLACK GIRLS WHAT
DO YOU THINK SOCIETY THINKS
ABOUT CHAU.
AND THEY SAID THAT THEY THOUGHT
THE SOCIETIES THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT APPEAL WITH THEIR SEX
APPEAL.
RIGHT AND THESE ARE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND SO WE ARE TALLIED
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE ARE
SHOWING IN OUR CULTURE AT THAT
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT.
THING IS THEIR SEX APPEAL OF
WHETHER THEY'RE INTO THEIR AND
THE RELATIONSHIP.
RATE THAN THEIR VALUES OF WAY OF
THEIR RELIEF THAT THEY VALUE THE
RELATIONSHIP SOMETIMES MORE THAN
THEY VALUE THEMSELVES AND THAT
ACTUALLY ALSO REINFORCES THE
CARGO --
REINFORCE THE SPACE AND
REINFORCES THE ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COULD
HAVE BEEN BECAUSE WE ARE.
ESSENTIALLY SOCIETY SAID YOU'RE
NOT WORTHY OF BEING [inaudible]
SAFE AND SO I AM NOT SURE WINNER
CLOSE AS TO THE MEASURE FAIRLY
SEPARATES BUT TALKED ABOUT --
JUST A COUPLE OF SPOTS.
A LIST THAT HE LOOKING AT DV
CALLED THREE OF BECAUSE
INCREASED 11% BETWEEN TWENTY
ELEVEN CITY TWENTY ELEVEN AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER ONE OUT OF THREE WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE REPORTED HAVING
BEEN SUBJECT TO RAPE PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE ARE STOCKING.
AND WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO BE MURDERED BY A
SPOUSE THEN MAN.
WOMEN OF COLOR OFTEN IMPACTED BY
HIGHER RATES THAN WHITE WOMEN
LOW INCOME WOMEN OFTEN HAVE LEFT
THE RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH DVD
IPV AND I'M MORE OF THAT I'M
MORE AFFLUENT COUNTERPARTS.
BOTH BLACK WOMEN AND INDIGENOUS
WOMEN HAVE RATES FOR HOSPITAL
COUNTERS COSTS BY ASSAULT HIGHER
THAN THE CALIFORNIA AVERAGE WITH
BOTH BLACK WOMEN IN THE
DEPLOYMENT SKEWING THE DATA
BLACK WOMEN ARE ONE THOUSAND
POINT SIX PER.
ONE HUNDRED OF ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
NEED OF ONE MAN ARTERIES.
300-100-1000 WOMEN CALIFORNIA
AVERAGE OF TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE POINT NINE PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WOMEN.
AND ALL POLL BE W. W. CONDUCTED
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN OUR OLD
WAYS NATIONAL BLACK WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AGENDA.
OVER THE ONE IN THREE BLACK
MOTHERS THAT WE REPORT IT HAVE
APART IT BE IN RATES.
AND SO WE THINK ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
I USED UP MY CONVERSATION AND A
WHAT I WOULD HOPE IS THAT OF THE
COMMITTEE WITH THINK ABOUT TODAY
IS HOW WE ADDRESS THESE ARE THE
THREE DIFFERENT LEVELS.
OF BOTH ADDRESS THE THE
INDIVIDUAL CHAMA NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE FOR FOLKS.
THINKING ABOUT THE POLICY AND
THE INTERSECTIONAL ISSUES WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR FOLKS IN TERMS
OF LOW INCOME.
AND ALSO WOMEN OF COLOR AND ALSO
THE SOCIETAL WINDS THAT HOW DO
WE ALSO CREATE SOCIETIES AND
CULTURES AND CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE INCLUSIVE AND MATTER OF
VALUE IT AND GIVE DIGNITY. TO
WOMEN IN LOW INCOME WOMEN BEGAN.
THANK YOU I'M I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ADD --
pLISTENING TO TO THE DISCUSSION
--
WHAT BAFFLED ME I WAS PART OF --
TESTIFYING AGAINST MY SISTER'S
ABUSER AND THE QUESTION THAT I
HAVE AND HOPEFULLY AT SOME POINT
WE CAN GET AN ANSWER TO THAT IS
--
SHE WENT TO COURT FOR A
RESTRAINING ORDER.
AND WHICH IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THAN ACTUALLY CHARGING
HIM WITH ANY CRIME.
AND SO.
WHEN SHE WENT TO WE HAVE TO
SPEND A HEFTY AMOUNT OF MONEY
WITH ATTORNEYS WHICH?
BY ALL ACCOUNTS THAT SHE HAD TO
BORROW MONEY FROM MY PARENTS
EXOTIC FEDERAL.
AND I WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
RESTRAINING ORDER WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO AFFORD ANOTHER ATTORNEY
TO TRY AND CHARGE HIM.
WITH THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE AND
THAT'S WHERE I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE SYSTEM.
AND I NEED YOUR HELP IF THERE IS
ANYTHING LEGISLATIVELY THAT WE
CAN DO TO CORRECT THAT BECAUSE
AWAIT HER ATTORNEY SAID.
WAS.
HERE'S THE THE RESTRAINING
ORDER.
HOWEVER IF YOU WANT TO PRESS
CHARGES YOU HAVE TO GO TO COURT
AGAIN IMPROVE IT NOT ONLY PROVE
IT BUT NOW YOU HAVE TO SPEND
MONEY ON AN ATTORNEY. TO DO THIS
AND SO WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
IS.
HE'S STILL TRYING TO ABUSE HER.
AND THE WAY HE IS DOING IT IS
BECAUSE MY SISTER IS RUNNING FOR
US SENATE AND SO WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO DO HE PUT SOMEBODY TO
RUN AGAINST HER.
AND NOW HE HAS REQUESTED PUBLIC
RECORDS ON OUR THERE'S THREE
SISTERS HE'S REQUESTED PUBLIC
RECORDS ON MY SISTER SHE WORKS
FOR CITY.
AND SO IT'S HIS WAY OF STILL
POKING -- AT
NOT JUST HURT BY ACT OUR FAMILY
IS IN GENERAL AND SO
[inaudible]
I AM.
CONFUSED I GUESS AS TO WHAT.
WE CAN DO TO STOP HIM.
AND HE'S NOT STOPPING AND BUT
HE'S PUSHING THAT ENVELOPE HE'S
DOING YOU KNOW THE POKING A
LITTLE BIT SEE IF HE GETS YOU
NOT LIKE A KID YOU POKE. TO SEE
IF YOU GET BURNED IF YOU YOU
KNOW YOU TOUCHING THE HOT FLAME
AND THEN YOU POKE AGAIN AND IF
YOU CAN GET BURNED AGAIN THEN
YOU KEEP.
PUSHING AND AND SO WE HAVE A
CONFERENCE THIS WEEKEND.
AND SINCE WERE ELECTED OFFICIALS
MY SISTER IS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
--
WE HEAR THAT HE'S ATTENDING
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I AM NOT PART OF THE THE
RESTRAINING ORDER --
ONLY SHE AS AND SO.
YOU KNOW THAT WHOLE DYNAMIC AND
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE WE
HAVE RESOURCES I HAVE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES INTO INFORMATION AND
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS.
NOT A FOR ITS DIFFICULT ENOUGH
FOR IT FOR ACTS BUT FOR SOMEBODY
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT WE DO THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE
YOU KNOW THE ACCESS TO OUR
PARENTS THAT CAN PROVERBIAL HELP
WITH A LITTLE BIT --
I WANT US TO THINK ABOUT THAT IS
IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO LEGISLATIVELY AND IN ON
THROWING IT OUT THERE. TO CLOSE
ITS WHICH SEEMS TO ME LIKE A
LOOPHOLE.
OF DOT NOW AFTER SHE READ
OBTAINED A RESTRAINING ORDER NOW
SHE HAS TO GO BACK.
AND TRY TO CHARGE HIM AND SO HIS
NARRATIVE NOW AS WELL.
IF I WAS THAT GUILTY WHY HAVEN'T
I BEEN CHARGED.
AND SO HE'S CONVINCING OTHER
FOLKS GULLIBLE FOLKS THAT --
HE DIDN'T DO IT THAT IT WAS A
MISTAKE THAT THE JUDGE GAVE THE
RESTRAINING ORDER AND YOU'D BE
SURPRISED.
IN OUR POLITICAL WORLD.
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF NOT
JUST MALES A WHOLE BUNCH OF
FEMALES INCLUDING SOME MEMBERS
OF MY OWN --
CAUCUS THAT ACTUALLY BELIEVE HIM
THEY BELIEVE THAT HE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING AND SO.
HELP ME AGAIN WE CANNOT DO THIS
TODAY OBVIOUSLY BUT I EXPECTS
AND I WILL.
MAKE SURE THAT I'M HERE FOR
ANOTHER TEN YEARS AND SOUL IF
YOU ALL CAN HELP ME FIGURE OUT
HOW TO CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE.
BECAUSE IT'S UNFAIR IT'S UNJUST
AND LIKE I SAID NOT JUST TO TALK
TO OZ BY TWO WOMEN.
LOW INCOME WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR
THEY DON'T HAVE THE THE ACCESS
TO RESOURCES IT'S HAPPENING.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE THAT I ALSO
WANT TO ADDRESSES.
SO WE WENT ACCORDING UP THE
RESTRAINING ORDER AND THEN WENT.
AND THEN WHAT BECAUSE WE THINK
ALL THE SHE GOT THE RESTRAINING
ORDER TALL GOOD KNOWN.
SHE'S IT'S A THREE YEAR
RESTRAINING ORDER AND WE'RE IN
THE SECOND YEAR SO WHAT HAPPENS
ON THAT THIRD YEAR.
AND IF HE'S.
FIGURING OUT WAYS TO STILL
ABUSER BECAUSE IT'S STILL ABUSE
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT HE
THINKS IT'S JUST OPOKU ITS
POLITICAL NO IT'S ABUSE DEL HOW.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS AND I THINK WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT.
I AND I AM SURE THIS WILL BE A
TOPIC OF LONG CONVERSATION BUT
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER.
SO A FEMALE --
GET OUT OF THAT SITUATION.
AND THEN WHAT IT THEN THEY'RE
STRUGGLING FOR A VERY LONG TIME
I RECENTLY HEARD --
TERRY CREWS AYE THE ACTOR AND HE
PUT OUT A VIDEO AND IF HE'S
LISTENING HOPEFULLY WE'RE GONNA
IT HAS TAG HIM.
ON THIS BECAUSE I DID YOU HEAR
WHAT HE SAID WHAT HE SAID WAS
THAT HIS MOTHER.
WAS ALWAYS READY TO LEAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP AND SHE WAS LIKE
PACKING THEIR BAGS AND IT'S LIKE
OKAY KIDS LET'S GO AND THEN SHE
WOULD SAY.
BUT WE'VE GOT NOWHERE TO GO.
WE'VE GOT NO MONEY TO GO FIND A
PLACE AND THEN THEY WOULD STAY
IN THAT RELATIONSHIP AND SO IT'S
SOMETIMES IT IS THE PERCEPTION
THAT THESE WOMEN STAY.
WHY ARE YOU STAYING I EVEN GOT
--
I A I A FACEBOOK.
POSTED LIKE OH YEAH I FIVE HOURS
SO ANGRY AT MY SISTERS ABUSER
WHY DID YOU ALLOW HIM TO HELP ME
NOT KNOWING ANYTHING COULD
HAPPEN BETWEEN AND SO.
SO AGAIN LOOKING AT THE VICTIM
AS SHAMING THEM.
FOR STAYING FOR EXAMPLE WHEN IN
TERRY CRUISES CASE HE SAID THAT.
THE MOM WOULD SAY HEY LET'S GO
BUT THEN WE GOT NOWHERE TO GO NO
INCOME.
SO WHAT HAPPENS THEN SO IN OUR
LATER CONVERSATIONS I WOULD LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT.
SO WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE
RETRAIN RESTRAINING ORDER
EXPIRES WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THAT
THAT WOMAN DOES ACTUALLY LEAVE.
YOU KNOW WOULD DO WE HAVE ANY
DATA AS TO HOW WELL THEY ARE
DOING OR HOW WELL THEIR KIDS ARE
DOING AND HAVE THEY BEEN BE
ABUSED.
NOT BY THE SAME PERSON BUT BY
THE NEXT.
ONE BECAUSE NOW I'M SURE THEY'RE
IN A RELATIONSHIP WHERE THEY YOU
KNOW FALL INTO.
TWO THE SAME SITUATION BUT I
WILL STOP RIGHT THERE AND THAT'S
FOOD FOR THOUGHT I GUESS BECAUSE
WE TO HAVE MANY MANY ISSUES TO
DISCUSS BUT IN ARE IN FEW FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS.
I WOULD LIKE.
TO ASK IT IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
GONE THROUGH OR HAVE SEEN ANY
STATISTICS AFTER.
WE PROVIDE ALL OF THE SUPPORT
THAN WHAT HAPPENED SO THANK YOU
AND FOR INDULGING ME IN THE
CONVERSATION BUT NEXT WE HAVE --
ME'S FROM --
STAND.
I THINK YOU HELLO HOW'S
EVERYBODY GOING [inaudible]
LET.
OKAY CAN BE ABLE TO HEAR ME.
MONDAY WAS SEVENTH MAYES AND I'M
A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND I ALSO WORK AT STAND UP
PLASTER AS THE HOUSING MANAGER
--
I'VE BEEN OUT OF MY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATION FOR A WHILE
NOW AND THERE WAS A LOT OF
BARRIERS THAT I WAS FACED WITH
WITH BEYOND A SINGLE MOTHER OF
THREE HAVE NO TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALL THE WAY FROM INDIANA WITH NO
FAMILY.
SO I DID END UP IN AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP THAT --
WAS VERY HARD --
AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I
FACED WAS TRYING TO NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM.
IT WAS EXTREMELY HARD THAT WAS
HARD FOR ME TO GET HOUSING --%
THE HOUSING THAT I HAD IT WASN'T
SAFE -- AND
NOT ONLY THAT IT DIDN'T PROTECT
ME FROM THE ABUSER BECAUSE
LET'S.
TALK ABOUT A RESTRAINING ORDER
YOU KNOW THEY GAVE ME A FIVE
YEAR RESTRAINING ORDER AND IT
DIDN'T STOP HIM.
HE STILL CAME AND HARASSED ME BY
IN ORDER FOR HIM TO BE RE
ARRESTED.
HE WOULD HAVE TO BE CAUGHT OWN
THING BASICALLY SO --
THAT WITH THE CAT AND MOUSE GAME
ME OR MY CHILDREN --
AND SO BEGAN THAT I'D NOW WORK
WITH VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
SEXUAL THOUGHT AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING [inaudible]
THERE'S SO.
SO MANY LAYERS AND BARRIERS THAT
I SEE THAT JUST REALLY CONFIRMS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A REAL
PROBLEM.
AND THAT THAT ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS IS THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
MONEY FOR SAFETY.
OUR SAFE HOUSES DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY.
THIS PROBLEM IS INCREASING AND
CLIENTS ARE HAPPEN TO BE TURNED
AWAY BECAUSE THIS SHELTERS FULL
OR THAT SHELTERS FOOL AND THEN
THE MONEY THAT WE DO GET.
IT'S RESTRICTED.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED IS WE NEED UNRESTRICTED
FUNDS EVER WANT TO BE ABLE TO
SAVE LIVES NOT ONLY DO WE NEED
AND RESTRICT THE FANS BUT WE
NEED SERVICES.
THAT PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO TAP
INTO [inaudible]
MENTAL HEALTH.
A LOT OF ARE SURVIVORS END UP
HOMELESS.
AND IN THAT MENTAL MENTALLY
UNSTABLE BECAUSE OF THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO YOU HAVE YOU KNOW.
MENTAL HEALTH STIGMA THEN YOU
HAVE HOUSING IS WAY TOO HIGH AND
THEN YOU KNOW THAT THAT HUMAN
RESOURCE OR HUMAN SERVICES.
THEY DON'T EVEN GIVE.
SURVIVORS ENOUGH TIME TO GET ON
THEIR FEET BEFORE THE ALREADY
PULLED THE RUG FROM UP UNDER OWN
NOT PROVIDING CHILDCARE.
NOT PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION --
AND HOW DO YOU TELL SOMEONE THAT
ONLY MAKING FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DOLLARS A MONTH WITH THREE
KIDS THAT HAVE TO PAY TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN RENT THAT
THEY HAVE TO SURVIVE THEY NEED
TO SURVIVE ON THAT [inaudible]
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
SO WE NEED MORE FUNDING IN THAT
AREA WE NEED MORE FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH WE NEED --
ABUSERS WE NEED FUNDING FOR THEM
SO THAT THEY CAN.
GET THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
YOU KNOW DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A
LEARNED BEHAVIOR.
SO WHAT OF WHAT AT WHAT IS THE
ROOT OF THE ISSUE WHAT IS THE
ROOT OF THEIR ABUSE THAT CAUSES
THEM TO IT TO HARM PEOPLE.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF I THINK THAT
THAT WE JUST.
YOU NO WE WE EVEN DONE AWAY WITH
LANDLORD DISCRIMINATION.
AND HOUSING PROGRAM THAT I RENT.
I HAVE SUCH A HARD TIME GETTING
CLIENTS HAL'S BECAUSE LANDLORDS
WANT TO DISCRIMINATE WHAT WE
DON'T YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT
THAT PROBLEM IN OUR COMMUNITY OR
THEY REYES THAT --
DEPOSITS TWO ONE THREE TIMES TO
READ BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THERE IS A PROGRAM THAT'S GOING
TO PAY FOR IT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT WHEN THE PROGRAM
ENDS OUR PEOPLE ARE STILL
STRUGGLING AND THEN.
THEY END UP BACK IN THE SAME
CYCLE THAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED.
ANOTHER ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP ALL
BECAUSE WE JUST WANT TO SURVIVE.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE TO GET AHEAD WE WANT TO BE
ABLE. TO TO BREAK THAT TO BREAK
THE SILENCE FOR OUR FAMILIES
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T BREAK IT F.
SURVIVORS.
THIS JUST GOING TO GOING TO THE
NEXT GENERATION OUR OWN KIDS.
AND SO --
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH ALL I HAVE TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOU KNOW THE STORY WITH
YOUR SISTER AND I REALLY FEEL
LIKE WE CAN'T A RATHER CAKE THIS
ISSUE.
IF IF EVERYBODY WOULD JUST
[inaudible]
PROBLEM IS IT'S A SOCIETY
PROBLEM IS NOT YOU KNOW HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ANYTHING ELSE
EXCEPT.
FOR ITS SOCIETY AND WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND NEXT WE HAVE RACHEL SMITH.
PATTY HI RACHEL OTHER THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME CAN YOU GUYS HEAR
ME.
OR DO I NEED TO TALK INTO THIS
ATTACK.
SOME MY NAME IS RACHEL SMITH I
AM OF JERICHO APACHE THE ON OFF
THEM AND I'M MEXICAN --
NOT HISPANIC AND I AM HERE TODAY
ON THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME AND
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
AND I'M HOPEFUL BUT YOU KNOW FOR
CHANGE --
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIVE COMMUNITY THAT I
SUPPORT PARENTS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY --
AND YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THE STORY ABOUT YOUR
FAMILY -- IN
TWO THOUSAND WHEN THE SAFE FOR
SIX IN SUMMER DINO COUNTY MY
COUSIN WAS --
A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHE ALSO FILED A RESTRAINING
ORDER AND IT WAS A REALLY LONG
PROCESS FOR THAT RESTRAINING
ORDER.
AND ULTIMATELY SHE WAS KILLED BY
HER EX HUSBAND AND SO --
THAT IS PART OF THE REASON WHY
IT IS THAT I DO THE WORK THAT I
DO.
IN ADDITION TO MY OWN HISTORY --
OUR PEOPLE ARE --
SURVIVORS OF INTERGENERATIONAL
TRAUMA AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHERE IT ALL BEGINS FOR
US -- FOR A
LOT OF US WE ARE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS VERY NORMALIZED.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND IN OUR
HOMES AND WERE RAISED TO BELIEVE
THAT IT'S JUST FIGHTING YOU KNOW
AND THEN THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY GETS KILLED AND IT'S
REALLY NOT THAT SIMPLE.
AND SO --
FOR ME I DON'T BELIEVE
NECESSARILY THAT IT'S COMPLETELY
A POVERTY ISSUE I BELIEVE THAT
IT IS A A FACTOR OF OPPRESSION.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SUPPORT THAT ARE
OPPRESSED IN THIS IS A COMMON
DENOMINATOR IN ALL OF THEM.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FAMILIES THAT
ARE AT THE POVERTY LEVEL THAT
ARE VERY HEALTHY YOU KNOW
THEY'RE JUST ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY --
FOR A GOOD NATIVE COMMUNITY AS
FAR AS THE WOMEN AND THE
CHILDREN ARE CONCERNED A HUGE
BARRIER FOR US IS THAT WE DON'T
REPORT PORTS UNDER REPORTED DUE
TO AGAIN HISTORICAL TRAUMA --
FROM THE BOARDING SCHOOL ERAS
THE CHILDREN WERE REMOVED FROM
FAMILIES AND IN THAT PROCESS A
LOT OF OUR FAMILY MEMBERS WERE
SEXUALLY MOLESTED --
CAME OUT BEING YOU KNOW ABUSERS
THEMSELVES.
AND A LOT OF THE DRUG.
PROBLEMS AND ALCOHOLISM BEGAN TO
LIKE INVEST OUR OUR PEOPLE AND
SO OF THE DOTS A HUGE PART OF
THE BARRIER AS TO WHY IT'S ALSO
UNDER REPORTED I BELIEVE --
CASE IN POINT RIGHT NOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER THE
CHILDREN ARE BEING REMOVED AND
THOSE CHILDREN ARE BASICALLY AT
SOME POINT PROBABLY GOING TO BE
PEOPLE THAT WE SUPPORT YOU KNOW
AND IT ALL IT'S DOING IS CAUSING
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA AND
MORE TRAUMA --
WE SEE I SUPPORT WOMEN AND YOUNG
GIRLS THAT SCORE A TEN ON THE A
SCREENING.
AND I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT BUT THAT IS
BASICALLY A FACTOR THAT'S
PROVING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE MAJOR HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
PROBLEMS AT WHEN THEY GROW UP.
IN ADDITION TO THEIR CHILDREN
AND SO -- AS%
FAR AS HOUSING IS CONCERNED --
WE WORK WITH THE POPULATION THAT
THEIR ABUSERS WILL LITERALLY
BURN THEIR IDENTITY AND THEY
TAKE FROM THEM AND IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET ACTIONS IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE IS A VERY VERY IT'S
LIKE HARD TO GET IT BACK.
WHEN YOU'RE CRISIS YOU'RE NOT
THINKING?
I NEED MY ID SO I CAN GO GET A
HOTEL YOU'RE JUST THINKING HOW
MY GOING TO BE SAFE COMING IN TO
GET TO THIS NEXT UP --
THERE ARE A LOT OF BARRIERS AS
FAR AS THE LANDLORDS ARE
CONCERNED.
THEY THEY DO DISCRIMINATE BASED
ON THEM TRYING TO PROTECT THEIR
OWN PROPERTIES IN THEIR OWN YOU
KNOW -- I
GUESS RESOURCES AND THEY DON'T
WANT THE SAME CYCLE TO BE
REPEATED AND THEY CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
CALM.
AND YOU KNOW CAUSE A RUCKUS
BECAUSE IN SOME OF THE CASES
THAT'S AND THAT ENDS UP WHAT'S
HAPPENING --
WE'RE SAYING THAT DB IS ONE OF
THE MAIN CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS.
A IN URBAN AREAS STEEPLY CPS IS
OFTEN CALLED AND THAT THE AGAIN
THE FEAR OF REMOVING OUR
CHILDREN IS A BIG IT'S A BIG
BARRIER IF NOT THE NUMBER
ONE THE LACK OF CULTURAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO FOR THE NATIVE
POPULATION --
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THERE'S A
TRUST ISSUE AND AGAIN THAT GOES
BACK TO HISTORICAL TRAUMA.
WE LOSE JOBS.
DUE TO LACK OF SICK TIME A LOT
OF OUR PEOPLE DON'T HAVE.
I THOUGHT IT OF FORMAL
EDUCATION.
AND SO.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE RESTRAINING
ORDER PROCESS IT'S AN ENTIRE DAY
IF IT GETS APPROVED IF YOU DO IT
RIGHT AND THEN YOU HAVE TO COME
BACK AND CONTINUALLY PRESSED
CHARGES IN ADDITION TO FIGURING
OUT WHERE YOUR KIDS ARE GOING TO
GO.
GOING BACK AND PICKING THEM UP
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THAT ARE
REGULAR OPERATIONAL THINGS FOR
PEOPLE LIKE US BUT SOMEBODY IN
CRISIS HAS A REALLY REALLY HARD
TIME PUTTING ALL THE PIECES
TOGETHER --
A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES ARE
OSTRACIZED FROM THE COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR OWN FAMILIES FOR
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THE FAMILY.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE NECESSARILY DO IT
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING THAT
HAPPENS ON THE RED STATES ON THE
ROADS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY --
DOT IS PART OF OF HOW WE'RE
RAISED.
AND AGAIN IT'S DUE TO TRUST
ISSUE I THINK IT'S A CULTURAL
THING -- ARE
THE INCREASE IN THE MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN IN THE
COUNTY IN THE NATION AND EVEN IN
OUR STATE.
IS THROUGH THE ROOF OUR NUMBERS
ARE UNDER REPORTED AND THAT IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT CODED
CORRECTLY AT A NATIONAL LEVEL.
OF WE ARE CLASSIFIED AS HISPANIC
NOT AMERICAN INDIAN OR OTHER OR
MULTIRACIAL --
AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I
DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO'S ONE
RACE AND SO IT JUST SEEMS TO
MAKE SENSE THAT EVERYBODY WOULD
BE BOP MULTIRACIAL BUT
APPARENTLY NOT MARKES --
I WILL CLOSE WITH THIS AS FAR AS
YOU SPEAKING ABOUT THE LAWS AND
HOW.
THINGS NEED TO BE CHANGED --
IN FEBRUARY SEVENTH KADISHA
BRITAIN OF COAL BELOW.
I BELIEVE SHE'S Y. LACKEY TRIBE
SHE ONE FEBRUARY [inaudible]
SEVEN TEN POINT.
THE WEEK BEFORE HER ATTACKER --
HER ABUSER ATTACKED HER WITH A
HAMMER.
SHE REPORTED THIS TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE --
SERVICES UP IN KABUL WHERE SHE
LIVES BECAUSE SHE WAS NOT FOUND.
AND BECAUSE SHE STILL MISSING
THE CHARGES AGAINST HIS
KIDNAPPING HIS KIDNAPPING
CHARGES HAVE BEEN DROPPED.
THEIR STATEMENT WAS NOBODY NO
VICTIM.
AND SO THAT FAMILIES THERE ARE
SUFFERING THE RESOURCES ARE VERY
VERY LIMITED AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY SEEM. TO
HAVE ALL OF THOSE YOU KNOW THEY
STILL HAVE LOOPHOLES AS WELL I
UNDERSTAND NOT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME.
SHE'S MISSING BECAUSE BECAUSE
SHE IS AND SO OF COURSE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PROSECUTE BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
YOU NOW SEIZE HOLD THE GUN POINT
AND SO THOSE FAMILIES ALL WE CAN
DO IS PRAY FOR THEM AND ALL WE
CAN DO IS SPEAK OUT. FOR THEM
MOTHERS WHO BRIAN HERE ON THAT
IS DEFINITELY STILL AN INVISIBLE
POPULATION.
OUR DEPENDENCE THAT ARE --
YOUNGER AND IN THE SYSTEM WHO
ARE IN BOLD TRIBAL MEMBERS ARE
COMPLETELY FORGOTTEN BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT THERE TYPES ARE NOT
NOTIFIED.
SO -- I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT --
NEXT WE HAVE A BETH HASSETT CEO
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WE'VE.
THANK YOU HELLO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME --
IT'S AN INTERESTING PANEL TO BE
ON SINCE --
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN THIS FIELD
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ASSURING
PEOPLE THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CAN HAPPEN TO ANYBODY NO MATTER
WHAT THEIR SOCIO ECONOMIC
[inaudible]
SITUATION IS.
YET WE KNOW THAT MOST OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SEEKING SOCIAL
SERVICES.
OUR LOW INCOME AT WE'VE --
THE AVERAGE PERSON WHO COMES IN
OUR SAFE HOUSE HAS AN INCOME OF
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS
SO WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
HIGHLY RESOURCE TO PEOPLE --
WE'VE IS CELEBRATING FORTY YEARS
OF SERVICE THIS YEAR AS ARE MANY
OF THE AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AGENCIES IN
OUR STATE SO EVERY COUNTY
THEORETICALLY.
HAS A WIDE ARRAY OF SERVICES
HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU THAT --
IT LOOKS DIFFERENT IN LA THAN IT
DOES IN SOME OF OUR NORTHERN
NORTHERN COUNTIES WHERE ON THEIR
VERY REMOTE AND PEOPLE REALLY
DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH ACCESS TO
SERVICES.
SPECIALLY IF THEY'RE LOW INCOME
HAVE NO TRANSPORTATION CAN'T GET
TO IT TO THOSE AGENCIES AND THE
AGENCIES ARE OFTEN COMPROMISE
THERE AREN'T AS MANY COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO PARTNER WITH THEY'RE
JUST NOT GETTING TO SOME OF
THOSE.
CLIENTS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
WALKING THROUGH THE DOORS AND
SEEK SERVICES.
I'M OVER THE YEARS WE'VE HAS
REALLY PRIORITIZE THAT MOST --
THE CLIENTS AT THE MOST
BARRIERS.
AND THAT OFTEN HAS TO DO WITH
THEM EITHER LIVING IN AN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY OR SIMPLY
NOT HAVING THE RESOURCES TO EVEN
GET TO OUR OFFICES.
AND IT'S INTERESTING YOU TALK
ABOUT LEGAL SERVICES I MEAN ON
THE ONE SIDE THERE'S THE
CRIMINAL SIDE OF THINGS WHERE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OUGHT TO BE
ARRESTING PEOPLE.
AND OUGHT TO BE THE DA'S OFFICE
OUGHT TO BE CHARGING THEM AND
THEY OUGHT TO BE HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT THEN WE'VE GOT.
VICTIMS WHO ARE UNWILLING. TO TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROCESS THEY DON'T TRUST
LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA CALL LOCK LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THAT THEY'D THEY'D.
THEY DO THEY MAKE IT SO THE SOME
OF THOSE CASES DON'T MOVE
FORWARD.
UP WE HAVE A PRETTY ROBUST LEGAL
DEPARTMENT AND WE PRIORITIZE
VICTIMS WHOSE PERPETRATOR.
IS ALL LAWYER UP AND HAS
RESOURCES AND SHE'S GOING TO
HAVE A VERY POOR OUTCOME.
IN HER CIVIL SIDE OF THINGS
GETTING THAT RESTRAINING ORDER
IF SHE DOESN'T HAVE
REPRESENTATION FROM WE'VE.
AND EVEN THEN AS YOU SAID IT'S
THAT COULD BE THREE YEARS IT IT
COULD NEVER BECOME A PERMANENT.
PERMANENT STAY AWAY ORDER AND
SHE SCRAMBLING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT SHE'S GOING TO DO ONCE THAT
RESTRAINING ORDERS --
GONE.
I THINK ONE OF THE GREAT STRIDES
WE'VE MADE IN THE LAST FORTY
YEARS IS THAT PEOPLE PEOPLE ALL
PRETTY MUCH SAY OKAY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS A BAD THING IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT KEEP BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
BUT EVERYBODY STILL PICTURES
THAT PHYSICAL VIOLENCE AND IF
SOMEBODY EVEN THOUGH THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE.
IF THEY WERE NEVER HIT OR IF
THERE WAS NEVER ANYTHING
PHYSICAL IT WAS --
EMOTIONAL ABUSE FINANCIAL ABUSE.
SPIRITUAL OF YOU ABUSE THEY
ALMOST FEEL LIKE IT DOESN'T
COUNT.
AND I THINK WHERE WHERE PEOPLE
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS IS YOU
GET A CRAFTY ABUSER WHO'S DOING
ALL KINDS OF AGGRESSIVE IN POWER
WIELDING THINGS LIKE SHOWING UP
AT AT SOMEBODY'S.
SOMEBODY'S COMMITTEE MEETINGS OR
I KINGS SOMEBODY BUT DOING IT IN
A PRETTY CRAFTY WAY IT'S HARD
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO REST THAT
PERSON IT'S HARD TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND AND VICTIMS ARE LEFT FEELING
LIKE WELL NOBODY'S GONNA BELIEVE
ME AND I HAVE NO RESOURCES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STATISTICS
OUT THERE BUT THERE AREN'T VERY
GOOD STATISTICS I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS.
WHAT WE KNOW HOW MANY --
CALLS FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE --
RELATED CRIMES ARE WHERE IT IT'S
ALWAYS ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND THAT'S WHAT IT'S
BEEN FOR THE LAST. TEN YEARS IT
SH.
AND WE KNOW THAT --
IN THOSE CASES ABOUT 40% OF THE
TIME THERE WAS A WEAPON USED
USUALLY THE PERPETRATOR'S BODY
IT'S OF PFISTER OF FOOT OR
SOMETHING NOT SO MUCH --
WEAPONS WE THINK OF AS WEAPONS
BUT THAT'S ALL WE KNOW AND WE
ALSO KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CALLING ON FOR SMITH THEY'RE
THEY'RE LIVING IN A COMMUNITY
WHERE YOU DON'T DO THAT.
YOU -- YOU
EITHER DON'T TRUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR YOU'RE JUST NOT
GOING TO DO THAT.
SO THOSE STATISTICS AREN'T
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE INCIDENTS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE
--
I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE MOSTLY
SERVING NEED HOUSING THEY NEED
TRANSPORTATION THEY NEED CHILD
CARE.
AND THAT THEY NEED A JOB AND
RESOURCES AND THEIR PAST ALREADY
COMPROMISED THROUGH DECO WEARS
AN IDENTITY THEFT FRAUD.
EVICTIONS WHERE THEY SHOULDN'T
BEEN THE ONE TO BE A BIT EVICTED
BUT LANDLORDS DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT ONE BIG HOLE RIGHT NOW IS
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN MOBILE HOME
PARKS THE THE LAWS ABOUT.
EVICTION DON'T APPLY BECAUSE
YOU'RE RENTING THE LAND BUT YOU
OWN THE HOUSE AND THAT'S A
THAT'S A HUGE HOLE IN OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROTECTION
LAWS BECAUSE TOO OFTEN VICTIMS
ARE BEING.
EVICTED WHEN THEY SHOULDN'T BE
AFFECTED BECAUSE THERE IS NO LAW
TO PROTECT THEM [inaudible]
COME.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
ABOUT FINANCIAL ABUSE 99% OF THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE HAVE SOME KIND
OF FINANCIAL ABUSE AND THAT IS
WHAT HOLDS PEOPLE DOWN I MEAN IT
IF YOU HAVE NOWHERE TO GO.
YOU STAY AND YOU END UP HOMELESS
AND THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS ARE THE REALLY THE
HIDDEN HOMELESS IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
ON THEIR ON THE VERGE OF BEING
HOMELESS OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK
OF THEM AS BEING HOMELESS.
AND THEY ARE OUT THERE PITCHING
TENTS IN THE STREETS OF PEOPLE
REALLY JUST AREN'T EVEN ARE EVEN
THINKING ABOUT THEM.
AND THEIR NOT HAVING ACCESS TO A
LOT OF THE SERVICES THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THAT CONTINUUM OF
CARE HAVE --
SOME COUNTIES REALLY HAVE IT
DIALED IN BUT FOR INSTANCE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND MANY
OTHERS --
YOU HAVE TO BE PART OF THE H. M.
HMIS SYSTEM TO EVEN BE ELIGIBLE
TO HAVE OF THE ICE BUT THAT DONE
AND TO GET ABOUT ON THE VOUCHER
LIST AND ALL OF THAT.
WELL UNLESS THE COUNTY HAS
GATTACA -- A
CONCERTED EFFORT AND A
COORDINATED EFFORT TO KEEP
VICTIMS NAMES AND IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION OUT OF THE H. AMAYA
BE IN THERE SO IN SACRAMENTO FOR
INSTANCE WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
WITH THAT PROTOCOL LOOKS LIKE.
BUT WE CAN'T PUT VICTIMS WHO ARE
STAYING IN OUR EMERGENCY SHELTER
INTO A SYSTEM THAT ANYBODY IN
THE COMMUNITY COULD LOOK AT SO
IT'S SOME OF IT'S JUST THE
SYSTEMS CHANGE THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
BUT ALSO GIVE THEM ACCESS TO
THOSE RESOURCES THAT.
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE AND THAT WE
DON'T SO.
I WOULD SAY --
THE BIG CHANGES WE NEED TO SEE
OF SERVICE PROVISION A LOT OF
WHAT WE DO IS AND STATE STATUTE
WE HAVE DUBBED SHELTER WE HAVE
TO HAVE A HOTLINE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
BUT WE NEED TO BE SERVING PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE THEY LIVE
WHERE THEY HAVE TRUST IN THOSE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE PROVIDING IT
TO THEM.
WE NEED TO BE IN FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS HAVE MOBILE ADVOCACY
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO PEOPLE WHEN
THEY'RE WHEN THEY'RE SAFELY IN A
HOSPITAL OR OTHER DOCTORS
OFFICES ARE FINALLY SAYING I
NEED HELP.
AND WE NEED WE NEED BE PUTTING
RESOURCES INTO GETTING TO PEOPLE
RATHER THAN ASKING THEM TO COME
TO US AND CHOOSE FROM OUR MENU
OF SERVICES THAT IS VARIAS.
SHOVE A SAID VERY DICTATED BY
STATUTE AND OUR FUNDERS AND WE
NEED TO FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO
SERVE PEOPLE WHERE THEY WANT TO
BE SERVED AND IN A WAY THAT.
IS SURVIVOR CENTER AND HOW THEY
NEED TO HOW THEY'VE HOW THEY
WANT TO BE SERVED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
SOME VERY ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GIPSON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY
--
BUT I ALSO WANTED TO SHARE IT
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER --
GIPSON WAS WITH ME THE LAST TIME
I REALLY APPRECIATED IS HIS AYE
INPUT AND SO WAS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA IS --
CHAIR OF THE SUB ONE OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES US
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND HE'S ALSO A
MEMBER OF HUMAN SERVICES BUT I
WANTED TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO THANK HIM PUBLICLY --
WELL THERE WAS A LOT OF ASKS IN
IN THE STATE BUDGET AND I KNOW
WE ALL WANTED SOMETHING AND I
JUST REALLY HAVE TO SAY THAT
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA WAS.
WAS WAS VERY OF REWARDING FOR ME
I LEARNED A LOT FROM HIM BUT HE
HE WAS ABLE TO HELP BUT AS IN
TERMS OF OF RESOURCES FOR HUMAN
SERVICES THAT ARE DIRECTLY.
AFFECTING --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS ARE A HE WAS ABLE TO
HELP US GET A BUDGET ASK LEADING
GET EVERYTHING THAT WE WANTED
BUT HE WAS HE WAS ABLE TO GET US
TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
ACTUALLY TWENTY IF THEY DID SOME
CREATIVE ACCOUNTING AND IT ENDED
UP BEING TWENTY MILLION HE ONLY
GETS CREDIT FOR TEN BUT I THINK
IN MY BOOK IS ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SERVICES.
BUT WE WILL WERE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE THE THE ARM.
AWARDS --
FOR CAL WORKS AND CAL FRESH DIED
IT WAS AN OVERALL INCREASE BUT
IT FOR THE SAKE.
OF THE DISCUSSION TODAY IT
DIRECTLY AFFECTED A LOT OF THE
BUS VIOLENCE VICTIMS.
AND SURVIVORS AND IN TERMS OF
HOUSING HE WAS GET SOME MONEY
THERE AND AGAIN IT'S NOT
DIRECTLY ALLOCATED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISSUES BUT I KNOW THAT
OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WILL BENEFIT
FROM.
THE WORK THAT HE DID AND YOU
KNOW I'M PUTTING THEM ON THE
SPOT BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THIS BUDGET.
IT'S AN AMAZING PLACE UP HERE I
HAVE TO TELL YOU IT'S AN AMAZING
PLACE BUT THE THE THE
INTRICACIES OF TRYING TO PASS A
BUDGET.
GO THROUGH SO MANY LAYERS THAT
IT WAS JUST.
I WAS BANGING MY HEAD THE WHOLE
TIME AND I HAD TO DEPEND ON ON
STAFF TO TO GO THROUGH IT AND I
KNOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HAS
BEEN DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME
SO HE KIND OF ALREADY KNEW.
BUT THE THE ARM.
WORK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
ARAMBULA DID FOR US AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU IT WAS HUGE SO THANK
YOU FOR FOR YOUR WORK.
AND WELCOME.
RIGHT OUT ANYTHING ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
APOLOGIES FOR BEING TARDY I
HAVEN'T QUITE FIGURED OUT HOW TO
CLONE MYSELF YET AND WE HAVE
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES AT THE SAME
TIME -- BUT
I WANTED TO COME HERE TO ADD MY
VOICE -- MY
MOTHER FOR A LONG TIME WORKED AT
ONE OF THOSE CENTERS THAT YOU
WERE DESCRIBING AND FRESNO WE
CALL IT THE MARJORIE MASONS AND
IT'S A PLACE WHERE.
FAR TOO OFTEN WOMEN AND KIDS ARE
FORCED TO GO BECAUSE OF THE
POVERTY AND EXPERIENCES FROM MY
COMMUNITY.
AND I KNOW THAT WE MUST DO MUCH
MORE TO COMBAT THIS CRISIS.
I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT A TO GENERATION
MODEL TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS
ARE NOT LEARNING FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
AND PART OF THAT MUST COME FROM
US ACKNOWLEDGING THE TRAUMA THAT
THEY EXPERIENCE.
FROM HAVING WATCHED THIS FIRST
HAND HAVING SEEN IT.
AND HAVING LEARNED FROM IT.
WILLINGLY OR UNWILLINGLY.
AND HOUR ABILITY TO ADDRESS THAT
TRAUMA REALLY WILL HELP US TO
GIVE US THE TOOLS TO SUCCEED
GOING FORWARD.
BUT I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT IF
I COULD TO REALLY DRILL INTO
THIS ISSUE OF POVERTY.
POVERTY ITSELF IS DRAMATIC.
I'M HERE TODAY ON MY THIRTIETH
OUR OF A FAST TO BRING.
ATTENTION TO A POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN.
A MOVEMENT IN OUR NATION.
A MORAL REVIVAL.
TOWARDS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES EACH AND EVERY DAY
IN OUR BUDGET IS A REFLECTION OF
OUR VALUES.
IN A FOR NOT WILLING TO STAND UP
IN COMBAT THIS INCOME INEQUALITY
AND POVERTY THAT WE SEE IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE WE HAVE SO MANY
MILLIONAIRES.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE WHO CANNOT
PUT FOOD ON THEIR TABLE.
THAT I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO.
STAND UP AND RECOGNIZE THAT THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT WE SEE.
THE CRIMES THAT ARE COMMITTED
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY OFTEN TIMES COME FROM
THE MOST BASIC [inaudible]
ISSUES.
THE FACT THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOOD TO PUT IN YOUR
STOMACH.
THEY DON'T GET ENOUGH SLEEP AT
NIGHT BECAUSE OF THE COMMUNITIES
THEY LIVE AND THERE IS MUCH MORE
THAT WE CAN DO HAND WHILE I AM.
HAPPY. TO GOTTEN THIS BUDGET
PASSED US.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S MUCH
MORE WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON AND PUSH GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND FOR ALL OF YOU
TESTIFYING HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY WILL BUT THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL
UP OUR SECOND PANEL --
WE HAVE CHRISTENDOM SICK FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO IN
DOMESTIC WEILAND'S.
TIED LAND FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ALARMING
MORENO'S OF FROM THE YOLO COUNTY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WELCOME CHRIS THAT [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON --
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING AND BRINGING ATTENTION
TO AND ISSUE THAT.
WE NEEDS TO BE IN THE LIMELIGHT
AT HER HOME MORE DEDICATED FOCUS
TO IT OFF SO I APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOU BEING HERE ON WHAT I KNOW IS
A BUSY DAY HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN AND I AM THE
PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE ARE THE
STATE WIDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COALITION WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF WORKING WITH LOCAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING IN.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS [inaudible]
SO.
A TAD A BIT OF COMPLEXITY TO
THIS DISCUSSION AROUND THE
INTERSECTION OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND POVERTY WANNA START
BY LAYING OUT SOME OF THE
PROTECTIONS AND SUPPORTS THAT DO
EXIST FOR SURVIVORS ALL STAR AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL HOME WITH SOME
OF THOSE OVER ARCHING --
PROVISIONS THAT IMPACT ALL OF US
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THEN
TRANSITION INTO DRILL DOWN INTO
CALIFORNIA.
COME AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
PRIOR PANEL AND AS MANY OF YOU
SPOKE TO OF THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
POVERTY IS A COMPLICATED NUANCED
INTERSECTION THAT HAS DEEP
IMPACT.
FINANCIAL ABUSE OCCURS AND 99%
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATIONS
AND IS OFTEN THE LEAST
RECOGNIZED HIM LEAST VISIBLE
PART OF THE ABUSE BUT IT CAN
INCLUDE RUINING THE SURVIVORS
CREDIT [inaudible]
A CONTROLLING THEIR BEHAVIOR SO
THAT THEY ARE FORCED TO LEAVE
THEIR EMPLOYMENT CONTROLLING
MONEY WITHIN THE HOUSEHOLD
HIDING ASSETS FUNDS.
ALL OF THOSE WAYS IN WHICH
FINANCES CAN BE MANIPULATED AND
WHICH LIVE SURVIVORS WITH THE
MOST IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE THEY
CONVEY.
WHAT DO YOU DO DO YOU LEAVE AN
ABUSIVE SITUATION?
AND UP HOMELESS TAKE YOUR
CHILDREN INTO HOMELESSNESS DO
YOU STAY IN A HOME WHERE THERE
MIGHT BE VIOLENCE AND ABUSE THAT
YOU HOPE YOU CAN FIND WAYS TO
CONTROL IN MEDICAID.
WHAT'S THE BETTER OPTION.
THE TRUTH IS NEITHER ONE OF
THOSE ARE GOOD OPTIONS AND
NEITHER ONE OF THEM SHOULD BE
OPTION.
SO THERE HAS BEEN DECADES OF
WORK TO HELP ADDRESS THAT OWNS
BUT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT WORK
GOES BACK TO THE MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES WHEN THE FAMILY
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND SERVICES
ACT WAS PASSED.
THIS IS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
ADMINISTERED THROUGH HHS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND THAT PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS AND
SERVICES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IT FUNDS.
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED SHELTERS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND THEN IT ALSO PROVIDES FOR
THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINE COME WHICH PERHAPS COMES
AS NO SURPRISE TO ANY OF YOU
THAT THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
CALLS CHEN HOTLINE EACH AND
EVERY YEAR COMES FROM
CALIFORNIA.
AND BUT THIS IS A TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AVENUE OF SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES FOR SURVIVORS AS THEY
NEED.
THE FAMILY VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AND SERVICES ACT ALSO HOPES TO
FUND A SMALL AMOUNT OF
PREVENTION WORK OF WHICH
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE I'M
GRANT RECIPIENTS WE WORK ON THE
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS --
IN LOS ANGELES AND MARIPOSAS TO
OF OUR SMALL COMMUNITY IS
DEDICATED TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE.
CURRENTLY GRANTEES ARE WORKING
ON COACHING BOYS INTO MEN
CHANGING LOCKER ROOM CULTURE IN
CHANGING THOSE SOCIAL NORMS THAT
EXCESS OF THAT.
YOUNG MAN HAVE HEALTHY MODELS OF
WHAT HEALTHY MASCULINITY CAN
LOOK LIKE.
AND THE FAMILY BONDS PREVENTION
AND SERVICES ACT IS SET TO BE
REAUTHORIZED OF THIS YEAR HOME
THERE'S LEGISLATION INTRODUCED
IT HAS ACTUALLY BEEN EXPIRED FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
HOME WHICH I THINK IS IMPORTANT
TO KNOW BECAUSE IT LEAVES
FUNDING VULNERABLE AND WE KNOW
THAT --
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EXPIRED ARE
OFTEN LESS LIKELY TO BE FUNDED
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO WE ARE.
ADVANCING.
IN TERMS OF HOW THIS PROGRAM
INTERSECTS WITH POVERTY.
OF THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT DOLLARS
ARE REALLY THE DOORS OPEN THE
LIGHTS ON MONEY FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE TASKED WITH
PROVIDING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
RESPONSE AND THE FIFTY DOLLARS
ARE THAT FUNDAMENTAL RESPONDS
AND THE USER THE SHELTERS THAT
ARE THERE TO ANSWER THAT
IMMEDIATE CALL.
WHEN SURVIVORS ARE SEEKING
URGENCY ONE OF THE OTHER KEY
PIECES OF LEGISLATION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IS THE VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT --
FIRST PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR AND REAUTHORIZE EVERY FIVE
YEARS FUNDS THE VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN ACT PROVIDES FOR A RANGE
OF THINGS --
WITH ITS MOST RECENT
REAUTHORIZATION AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN INCLUDE SOME REALLY
HARD FOUGHT.
AND VITAL PROTECTIONS TO ADDRESS
--
LGBT SURVIVORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY SURVIVOR REGARDLESS OF THEIR
GENDER EXPRESSION OR GENDER
IDENTITY OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
CAN RECEIVE THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED WITHOUT FEAR OF
DISCRIMINATION.
IT INCLUDES KEY IMMIGRATION
PROTECTIONS FOR IMMIGRANT
SURVIVORS AND INCLUDES NEW
TRIBAL PROVISIONS TO HELP WITH
THE NATIVE COMMUNITIES AND
TRIBES TO BETTER RESPOND TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT IS
HAPPENING IN PARTICULAR BY NON
NATIVE INDIVIDUALS AGAINST
NATIVE WOMEN.
AND THE US HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE
KEY AREAS OF PROGRESS SO THAT
THE VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT
STATUTES HAVE MADE OF IT ALSO
INCLUDES KEY HOUSING PROTECTIONS
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT PUBLIC
HOUSING --
THE I KNOW HAS BEEN AN AREA OF
MUCH DISCUSSION ALREADY AT THIS
HEARING AROUND HOUSING.
I COULD TALK ABOUT THAT ALL DAY
BUT I WANT ADAM.
YOU KNOW AT SOME OF THE OTHER
PIECES WITH THE VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN ACT THAT ARE MOST RELEVANT
AS WE THINK ABOUT POVERTY IS THE
FUNDING THAT COMES FROM THAT
PROGRAM.
THERE'S A FORMULA GRANT THAT IS
ADMINISTERED THROUGH VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT IT COMES TO
THE STATE TO HELP PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR SERVICES LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROSECUTORS AND
COURTS.
WE'VE HEARD ALREADY ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROSECUTORIAL
RESPONSES AND WHAT OUR COURT
SYSTEMS CAN LOOK AND FEEL LIKE
FOR SURVIVORS AND THE FUNDS
THERE ARE DESIGNED TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT BUT THERE'S MUCH
MORE WORK TO BE DONE. ONE OF THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
SERVICE BONDS INSTRUMENT ACT IS
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR VICTIMS OF
AS HAS BEEN STATED.
ACCESSING AN ATTORNEY AS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
ESPECIALLY IF THE ABUSE HAS
INCLUDED FINANCIAL ABUSE AND A
SURVIVOR IS FACED WITH LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES YOU HEARD
BATHHOUSES SAY.
HOW LITTLE DOLLARS OF
INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO SHELTER
HAVE?
HOW DO YOU PAY FOR AN ATTORNEY
WITH?
ABSOLUTELY GO ASSISTANCE FOR
VICTIMS PROGRAM HAS HELPED
SURVIVORS HAVE ACCESS TO LEGAL
ASSISTANCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
OVER 80% OF SURVIVORS OFTEN GO
INTO COURT AND REPRESENTED.
NOT OFTEN GO UP AGAINST THEIR
ABUSER WHO DOES HAVE THOSE
FINANCIAL MEANS TO PROVIDE FOR
AN ATTORNEY.
THERE'S ALSO FUNDING THERE FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING TO HELP
CREATE A BRIDGE FROM EMERGENCY
THIRTY OR SIXTY DAY SHELTER INTO
LONGER TERM STABILITY AND
PERMANENCE.
AND THEN FINALLY ANOTHER ONE
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS THE
RURAL GRANT PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
THINK YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY.
A HAM AND MANY OF YOU KNOW IS
YOU REPRESENT RURAL AREAS HOW.
HOW SCARCE RESOURCES CAN BE AND
HOW POVERTY CAN BE CONCENTRATED
OUR PERIL AREAS?
SO ALL OF THESE GRANT PROGRAMS
HAVE HELPED US TO MAKE
TREMENDOUS STRIDES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR A GAPS
CONTINUE TO REMAIN BUT THE IS
ARE PROVIDING --
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND SUPPORT.
AND THE THIRD OF THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT'LL TOUCH ON JUST
BRIEFLY AS THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
ACT.
AND SO THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT IS
BROADER THAN DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE THEM AND FUNDS A RANGE
OF RESPONSES TO A RANGE OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
AND THESE ARE NON TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO
THEIR FINES AND FEES COLLECTED
FROM OFFENDERS LARGELY WHITE
COLLAR CRIME AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
AND AND AS MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW
THE IS DOLLARS --
HAVE RECEIVED A SIGNIFICANT A
NUMBER OF YEARS IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS WE'VE SEEN A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN NEW RESOURCE THOSE
--
AS CONGRESS HAS.
INCREASED THE APPROPRIATIONS.
THOSE DOLLARS COME TO THE STATE
IN TWO WAYS THEY COME HERE TO
CALIFORNIA AS REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SURVIVORS OF VICTIMS
COMPENSATION.
TIME AND THIS IS A VOTE TO
REIMBURSE SURVIVORS FOR OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES I'M WHICH CAN BE
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT AS WE
THINK ABOUT SURVIVORS.
HAVE VERY LIMITED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES.
I WILL SAY IT IS A REIMBURSEMENT
MODEL OF WHICH MEANS THAT YOU
NEED TO FIND THE FUNDS TO PAY
FOR THOSE OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES
BEFORE YOU CAN BE REIMBURSED BUT
TO BE ABLE TO BE MADE.
FINANCIALLY HOLE ACCOUNTANTS
TREMENDOUSLY IMPACT.
COME OTHER FUNDS COME TO THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
ADMINISTER THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO QUITE A BIT WITH THOSE
DOLLARS I WON'T.
BY ANY STRETCH GET INTO ALL OF
WHAT THEY'VE DONE THAT.
SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS HAVE GONE
TO SUPPLEMENT THE BIGGEST THE
GRANTS FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER PROGRAMS UP TO HELP
INCREASE AND PROVIDE THE
SUPPORTS WE KNOW THEY NEED.
AND THEY ALSO USE THOSE FUNDS
AREN'T TRANSITIONAL HOUSING MORE
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR SURVIVORS
RECOGNIZING THAT DEEP NEED --
AND PROVIDING HOUSING FIRST
RESPONSES TAILORED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO IT REALLY INNOVATING
ABOUT HOW WE PROTECT SURVIVORS
FROM EVER FALLING INTO.
AND THERE'S MUCH MORE TO SAY
ABOUT ALL OF THOSE BUT AS WE
LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT CALIFORNIA.
ALL THIS FEDERAL POLICY IS COME
TOGETHER TO HELP PROVIDE THE
RESPONSES THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT WITH OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHT SHELTER BASED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS IN A RANGE OF
OTHERS PROVIDING SERVICES FOR
SURVIVORS.
AND I THINK YOU'VE HEARD SOME
SOUNDS BUT AS OF SONS IN FY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE SHELTER
BASED PROGRAMS ANSWERED TOGETHER
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND ONE
THOUSAND HOTLINE CALL
[inaudible]
THEY PROVIDED.
EMERGENCY SHELTER TO TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND SURVIVORS AND THEIR
CHILDREN. FOR A TOTAL OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND BAT
BANG.
SO THAT IS HOW MANY NIGHTS OF
SHELTER THEY PROVIDE.
I'M THEY PROVIDED EMERGENCY FOOD
AND CLOTHING TO OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND ADULTS AND CHILDREN
WHICH I THINK.
SOME OF THE THOUGHTS THAT REALLY
UNDERSCORES.
HOW MUCH IN CRISIS IS SURVIVORS
ARE WHEN FOOD AND CLOTHING?
Z. LEVELLERS OF THE ESSENTIAL
NEEDS THAT THERE MAY
[inaudible]
YEAH.
AND DESPITE THE GREAT WORK THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DOING THE GAPS
REMAIN --
OVER TWO YEAR PERIOD THE AVERAGE
NUMBER OF UNMET NEED UNMET
REQUEST FOR SHELTER WAS OVER
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND REQUESTS
WHICH AGAIN INTERSECTS WITH
THAT.
INCREDIBLE NEED WE SEE AROUND
HOUSING AND A MUST PATENTS
[inaudible]
I'M.
AS WE THINK ABOUT IMMEDIATE AND
LONG TERM NEEDS THE FOCUS IS
OFTEN ON IMMEDIATE MEANS RIGHT
WING HAVE BUILT A STRONG.
EMERGENCY CRISIS RESPONSE THAT
WITH EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND
CRISIS HOTLINES.
AND WHAT CAN OFTEN BE MOST
CHALLENGING AS TO HOW TO HELP
SURVIVORS THROUGH LONG TERM
STABILITY.
HOW DO WE HELP SURVIVORS HOUSING
THAT IS PERMANENT AND AFFORDABLE
AND STABLE?
ESPECIALLY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND CALL.
FOR ALL WHILE SURVIVORS ARE
TRYING TO REBUILD THEIR CREDIT
FI NEW EMPLOYMENT.
DEAL FOR HIM DEAL WITH THE
TRAUMA THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
HELP THEIR CHILDREN BE A SAFE IN
SCHOOL SO THESE LONG TERM
SUPPORTS THE ABILITY FOR
PROGRAMS.
TO HAVE THAT TRANSITION TIME AND
WORK WITH SURVIVORS OF LONG TERM
IS INCREDIBLY ASSUMPTION.
IT'S WHY SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
LIKE THE CAL WORKS TEMPORARY
HOUSING AND OTHER SUPPORTS ARE
SO VITAL AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL WILL
SPEAK AT HOME. TO THOSE IN
GREATER DETAIL.
SO UNDERLYING ALL OF THESE NEEDS
IS REALLY THE ECONOMIC REALITY
AND A YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT HOW
WORKS AND CALL FRESH FROM OTHERS
BUT DIDN'T A LIFT UP THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A RECENT REPORT
FROM THE NATIONAL RESOURCE
CENTER ON TO MY VIOLENCE.
AND THAT WAS TITLED THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SURVIVING AND
NOT SURVIVING AND THE ESSENTIAL
ROLE OF PUBLIC BENEFITS.
IN THE ROLE REALLY IS THAT STARK
COME BY NO MEANS IS THAT THE
TITLE OF WITHOUT REPORT
HYPERBOLIC.
SO A FEW HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE
REPORT THAT I JUST WANNA LIFT UP
FOR YOU ALL.
ASIDE.
OF THE ADVOCATES THAT WERE
SURVEYED NATIONWIDE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TEN OFTEN STOP THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS GOVERNING
CULBERTSON CAO FRENCH.
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS SAY THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS RELY
ON TOWN OF TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS.
AT NEARLY 80% SAY THE SAME OF
SNAP USER VITAL VITAL PROGRAMS.
AND SURVIVORS THEMSELVES
REPORTED AT THAT THEM
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE SERVICES
WERE AND WHAT BENEFITS THEY
COULD PROVIDE.
AND BE ELIGIBLE FOR WAS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW THEY
THOUGHT ABOUT LEAVING WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WERE ABLE TO LEAVE AND
HOW TO DO SO WHERE TO GO.
MANY SURVIVORS WHO FIND
THEMSELVESAND POVERTY IN IN
CRISIS HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS
OF SKILL AND SKILLS THAT WILL
MAKE THEM --
YOU KNOW ECONOMICALLY STABLE AND
BUT THEY NEED THE INTERIM
SUPPORT WHILE THEY DEAL WITH
TRAUMA AND REESTABLISH THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ANTENNA
FINS SNAP ARE KEY PARTS OF THAT.
I'M THESE PROGRAMS GIVE THEM A
MEANS TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES WHILE THEY
BUILD THEIR LIFESPAN.
THEM AND YET THEY ARE NOT
WITHOUT THEIR CHALLENGES AND
BEAT BE REMISS IF WE DIDN'T
ADDRESS THOSE CHALLENGE BUTTONS.
SO LESS THAN HALF OF AND THE
ADVOCATES SURVEYED SAID THAT
DOMESTIC PHONE SURVIVORS WERE
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE BENEFITS
WHEN THEY NEED AT THEM.
MANY SURVIVORS FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN'T ACCESS THOSE BENEFITS
WITHOUT AN ADVOCATE WITHOUT
WHICH SAYS A LOT ABOUT THE HIGH
BARRIER TO ENTRY.
AND HOW COMPLEX THOSE PROCESS
USE OF SIMPLY APPLYING FOR AND
RECEIVING THESE BENEFITS CAN BE
[inaudible]
UP.
RESPONDENTS WHO WERE WORKING
WITH LGBT --
SURVIVORS IMMIGRANT SURVIVORS
THOSE WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY ESPECIALLY RAISED UP
THE CHALLENGES AND STRUGGLES OF
ACCESSING AND THESE PROGRAMS
TIME.
ESPECIALLY FEELING THE SAFE IN
DOING SO. ONE QUOTE THAT I'LL
JUST SHARE FROM THE REPORT WAS
THAT.
TENER FAILS MOST WOMEN WITH
CHILDREN BECAUSE IT IS DIFFICULT
TO ACCESS OPPOSED TO MANY HOOPS
TO JUMP THROUGH FIRST MALL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THIS PROCESS IS FRUSTRATING AND
INTRUSIVE FOR MOST AND DOESN'T
ALLOW FOR REAL ASSISTANCE WITH
THE REALITY FACED BY THE CYCLE
OF POVERTY.
SO NAY INCREDIBLE BRIDGE PROGRAM
PROGRAMS THAT DO SO MUCH FOR
SURVIVORS AND STILL --
MORE WORK REMAINS ARMS SO GLAD
THAT WHERE HAVING THIS HEARING
ABLE TO LIFT UP THE SUCCESSES
AND CHALLENGES.
AND SOLUTIONS WE CAN WORK FOR
ITSELF --
FOR FOR THIS HEARING AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS COMPLEX ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
COULD YOU ACTUALLY JUST REALLY
THAT QUOTE [inaudible]
I KEPT [inaudible]
SO.
THE QUOTE IS TENER FAILS MOST
WOMEN WITH CHILDREN BECAUSE IT
IS DIFFICULT TO ACCESS AND HAS
TOO MANY HOOPS TO JUMP THROUGH.
FIRST SMALL AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THIS PROCESS IS FRUSTRATING AND
INTRUSIVE FOR MOST.
AND DOESN'T ALLOW FOR REAL
ASSISTANCE WITH THE REALITY
FACED BY THE CYCLE OF POVERTY.
SO THE SURVEY THAT YOU PROVIDED
INDICATED PEOPLE DO SEE THE
VALUE OF IT.
BUT THE VALUE IS OFFSET BY THE
CUMBERSOME BURDENSOME INTRUSIVE
NESS.
THE LOAN AMOUNT OF THE BENEFITS
THAT EVERY LOT OF MEMBERS FOR A
LIMITED DIEM.
BUT IT IS A BETTER TOOL THAN.
NO TWO ABSOLUTELY ARE IT IS
ESSENTIAL IT IS SORT OF PEOPLE
RESORT TO IT.
BUT IS VERY BURDENSOME DE.
AVAIL THEMSELVES.
AND YOU KNOW AGAIN I WILL SAY
THIS WAS A NATIONAL SERVICE OF
THOSE EXPERIENCES DIFFER.
A STATE BY STATE PER OUT IMAGINE
COUNTY BY COUNTY OF IN SOME WAYS
BUT YES IT IS THE YOU KNOW LOW
BENEFIT AMOUNTS --
IT IS A CHALLENGING PROCESS AT
TIMES TO APPLY FOR AND THE KNOW
WHEN THERE'S DOMESTIC FOUNDS
INVOLVES AT HOME.
TRIGGER SOME OF THE SPECIFIC HOW
WORKS PROTECTIONS ARE TEN OF
PROTECTIONS AFFECT HER DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE YOU HAVE TO DISCLOSE
THAT YOU'RE AFFECT ADAM.
I'M AND NOT SO HARD PROCESS OF
THEM YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT THAT
IS DONE AND I'M CAN BE DONE TO
HELP MAKE THAT MORE COMFORTABLE
BUT IT.
CAN FOR SURVIVORS WHEN THEY'RE
AND HAMA THEY END UP HAVING.
TO SCHOOLS THAT TRAUMA AND ABUSE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN DIFFERENT
WAYS AND SO.
AND THAT CAN JUST BE ANOTHER
ANOTHER BURDEN TAFFETA TELECAST
WORKER ABOUT YOUR SITUATION.
YOU VERY MUCH AND SHARE.
THE CIVIC CENTER SO HOW HOW WHAT
SUGGESTIONS WOULD YOU GIVE THIS
BODY THE SELECT COMMITTEE. TO
EXPLORE TO LOOK AT TRY TO REMOVE
SOME THOSE THAT THAT PARTICULAR
BAY AREA WHERE. ONE DON'T HAVE
TO DISCLOSE BUT STILL RECEIVE
THE KIND OF BENEFITS THAT.
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS SEEKING.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION --
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THERE'S
CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT SURVIVORS ARE EVEN AWARE
THAT THERE'S A FAMILY VIOLENCE
OPTION AS PART OF COLOR SINCE SO
MAKING SURE THAT SURVIVORS GET
THAT INFORMATION AND THAT.
ALL COLOR X. APPLICANTS GET THAT
INFORMATION WHEN THEY'RE
APPLYING --
AND KNOW THAT THEY CAN SHARE
THAT INFORMATION AT ANY TIME AND
I THINK THAT UNDER CURRENT LAW
THEY DO NEED --
TO DISCLOSE TO BE ABLE TO
TRIGGER --
THOSE PROTECTIONS INCLUDING
STOPPING SOME OF THE CLOCKS ON
CAL WORKS SINCE PERFECT FOR
ACTIONS BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT ONGOING COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES.
BROWN'S PROGRAMS ON HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
KISS WORKERS ARE CREATING A SAFE
SPACE FOR SURVIVORS TO SHARE --
THAT THOSE DISCLOSURES ARE ABLE
TO BE LIMITED TO THE SIMPLE
INFORMATION OF I AM A SURVIVOR
WITHOUT ASKING FOR EXPECTING YOU
KNOW FULL DETAIL OF THE HISTORY
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF TIME COULD
CONTINUE TRAINING THAT KID.
FROM IF I MAY NOT OWN OF THE
LABOR BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAVE TO
LOOK OTHER PRESENTERS.
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE BECAUSE I
KNOW WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE MERELY LOOK
AT TO SEE ONE PICTURE.
WE SEE THE WOMAN WHO'S BEEN A
THE VICTIM WHAT ABOUT THE MAN
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AT MEN OUT
THERE.
WHO IT ALSO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE --
WHAT NUMBERS DO YOU HAVE AND
ALSO IS THERE A GREAT
APPREHENSIVE?
ON THE AND MALES PART TO RECEIVE
ANDTO ACCESS SOME OF THE SAME
PROGRAMS AND BENEFITS THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED IN YOUR
TESTIMONY.
ABSOLUTELY --
ONE IN SEVEN MAN WILL EXPERIENCE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I'M OF THE
NATIONWIDE STATISTIC.
I THINK ABOUT IT.
IT IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE THAT IT
DOES OFTEN GET LEFT OUT OF THE
MAIN NARRATIVE AROUND GNOSTIC
VIOLENCE AND YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE
A LOT OF WORK WITH THOMAS FOUND
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THERE'S FACES FROM EMERGENCY
SHELTER TO COUNSELING ARE --
COMFORTABLE INAPPROPRIATE FOR A
PERSON OF ANY AGE UNDER.
BUT I THINK THAT AS THE SOCIETAL
STIGMA IS IMPORTANT TO KNOWLEDGE
WE AS A SOCIETY HAVE OF USE
AROUND MASCULINITY THAT DON'T
MAKE SPACE.
FOR OF ADMITTING VULNERABILITY
ADMITTING THAT IT IS STILL
HARDER FOR MALE VICTIMS TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD FEEL
LIKE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
SERVICES THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
FOR THEM AND SO DOES.
AND AN ONGOING AREA THAT IT JUST
REQUIRES A LOT OF WORK AND
REALLY INTENTIONAL OUTREACH TO
MAKE SURE THAT --
BELL SURVIVORS ARE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
--
NEXT WE HAVE TODD PLANTED
PROJECT DIRECTOR OF FAMILY
DETERMINE AND EMPOWERMENT
DIVISION DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND SHE SAID ON
TODD PLAN WITH CALIFORNIA PART
IN SOCIAL SERVICES.
ADEPTLY DIRECTOR FOR THE FAMILY
IN CAJUN EMPOWERMENT DIVISION.
WELL I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AS IS THE CASE
WITH THE OTHER WITNESSES TODAY.
ARM I'M GONNA TALK TO YOU ABOUT
ON SOME OF THE MAJOR CDSS
PROGRAMS AND HOW THEY SERVE.
ON VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
LISTING TO THE TESTIMONY ON THE
FIRST PANEL AND A WITNESS HERE
TODAY ARM I JUST JUST REMINDED
ABOUT HOUSING EVERYONE HAS
MENTIONED HOUSING IN THE HIGH
COST OF HOUSING.
IN THE CRISIS THAT THAT PUTS ON
SO MANY CALIFORNIANS I IS JUST
JUST OVERLAY SO MANY ISSUES THIS
ONE INCLUDED.
ON MY DIVISION DOES INCLUDE THE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS BRANCH LA WHICH OVERSEES
ON SOME OF THE HOUSING PROGRAMS
IN OUR DEPARTMENT COURSE OUR
PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING IN THE DEVELOPMENT OTHER
PLACES AS WELL --
TODAY LIKE IT'S I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON ON THE TWO MAJOR
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED ON THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM WHICH IS OUR VERSION OF
THE FEDERAL TANF PROGRAM.
AND A LITTLE BIT ON THE CAL
FRESH PROGRAM ALSO TOUCH BRIEFLY
ON THE TRAFFICKING AND CRIME
VICTIMS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
SOMETIMES CALLED TO SEE ABOUT.
ON AND FINALLY WILL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME
IMMIGRATION ISSUES AT THE AND
TURNING FIRST TO CAL WORKS ARE
AS AS I THINK YOU ALL KNOW IT'S
OUR PROGRAM A CASH ASSISTANCE.
AREN'T FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN IT SERVES FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND LOW INCOME FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND NEARLY A MILLION
INDIVIDUALS AND MOST OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE CHILDREN.
AS A TALK ABOUT CAL WORKS
INTEREST CAN TALK LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SORT OF CURRENT LAW AND
THEN GET INTO A DISCUSSION OF
WHAT IS PERHAPS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGE AND
CAL WORKS WHICH IS OF COURSE.
YOUR LEGISLATION ON AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN WHICH BECAME CHAPTER.
SIX NINETY ONE AND THEN I'LL
CLOSE ON CAL WORKS WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF A LITTLE BIT OF
STATISTICAL INFORMATION.
CURRENTLY ALL APPLICANTS AND
RECIPIENTS OF CAL WORKS ARE
INFORMED OF THE AVAILABILITY OF
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED WITH
OPPORTUNITIES. TO CONFIDENTIALLY
SELF IDENTIFY AND DISCLOSE
ISSUES OF DOMESTIC ABUSE AND A
SWORN STATEMENT IS SUFFICIENT.
TO ESTABLISH THAT ABUSE.
AND ESTABLISH THAT TYPE OF CASE
VICTIMS ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
OPTION TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW TO RECEIVE OF COMMUNICATION
CORRESPONDENTS.
ON AND CONFIDENTIALITY IS
MAINTAINED AND THEY MAY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S HOME SAFE PROGRAM WHICH
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS THEM.
TO KEEP THEIR ADDRESS ON
COMPLETELY PRIVATE SENSUALLY ABI
SERVE THROUGHOUT POST OFFICE BOX
[inaudible]
ON A SCREENING FOR DOMESTIC
ABUSEAS PART OF THE CURRENT LAW
COM ONLINE CAL WORKS APPRAISAL
TOOL THERE ARE QUESTIONS IN THAT
LATER I'LL GET TO SOME OF THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT.
ON SERVICES THE COUNSELING OR
OFFER TO IMPACT INDIVIDUALS AND
HOURS IN THESE ACTIVITIES IT CAN
COUNT TOWARDS A CLIENT'S WELFARE
TO WORK PARTICIPATION HOURS.
ON CAL WORKS ALLOWS UNDER
CURRENT LAW OF MANY
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS TO BE
WAIVED OFFER INDIVIDUALS
IMPACTED BY DOMESTIC ABUSE.
ARE THESE INCLUDE TIME LIMIT ON
RECEIVING CASH ASSISTANCE
PATERNITY ESTABLISHMENT AND
CHILD SUPPORT COOPERATION.
IN FACT VIRTUALLY ANY PROGRAM
REQUIREMENT CAN BE WAIVED WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF ASSETS INCOME
AND DEPRIVATION --
THERE ARE ALSO IN CURRENT
REGULATION AS ALL GET TO IN A
MOMENT IN STATUTE THERE ARE --
EXCEPTIONS TO RULES AROUND
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE AT
IMMUNIZATION BUT CAN ALSO BE
APPLIED TO THOSE WHO ARE VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ON EIGHTY FIVE FIVE SEVEN ON
MADE SOME HUGE CHANGES SOME OF
THOSE WENT INTO EFFECT IN
JANUARY OTHERS ARE GOING TO GO
INTO EFFECT NEXT MONTH.
IN JANUARY ON CHANGES COM
ESSENTIALLY CODIFYING A LOT OF
OUR EXISTING PRACTICES AROUND ON
A ESSENTIALLY WAIVERS OF
REQUIREMENTS AROUND SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE AND IMMUNIZATION
THOSE ARE NOT CODIFIED ARE NOT
PART OF THE LAW.
NOT JUST A REGULATORY PRACTICE
AND NOTICING REQUIREMENTS WERE
ALSO UNCODIFIED AS WELL.
BUT PERHAPS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES ARE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT MONTH ARM.
UNDER AB.
FIVE FIVE SEVEN AND THAT IS ON
ESSENTIALLY A NEW ESSENTIALLY
HOMELESSNESS BENEFIT THE
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WILL
BE AVAILABLE HA TO THOSE WITH A
SWORN STATEMENT.
AND UP TO THIRTY TWO DAYS OF
THAT BENEFIT WILL BE AVAILABLE.
AND THE HUGE CHANGE IS.
PREVIOUSLY A BARRIER TO GETTING
TO CAL WORKS WAS THAT IF YOU.
CAME DIRECTLY FROM AN ABUSER'S
HOME.
I TRY TO APPLY FOR CAL WORKS WE
WOULD COUNT THE INCOME AND
ASSETS OF THE ABUSER.
AT AGAINST YOUR ARM AGAINST
ESSENTIALLY OUR CASE THAT WASN'T
THE CASE IF YOU'RE IN A SHELTER
BUT YOU CAME DIRECTLY.
SO PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
CHANGES WERE SUFFERING THAT FOR
POTENTIALLY THE RECEIPT OF THE
THIRTY TWO DAYS ON THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE UP DOLLARS WHICH ARE
SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS A DAY.
AND THAT'LL BE BEING INCREASING
TO EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS A DAY
UNDER THE BUDGET AGREEMENT THE
MISTER RIDICULOUS WELL AWARE OF
THE THOSE ARE HUGE CHANGES THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE THOSE THOSE ARE
YET TO COME THROUGH AND THEY
GOING TO AFFECT NEXT MONTH.
A WE'RE HOPING TO GET OUT OUR
GUIDANCE ON THAT WE'RE WORKING
VERY HARD ON GETTING US
STAKEHOLDER REVIEW ON HOPING TO
HAVE THAT OUT VERY SOON THE
OTHER CHANGES ON WE WERE MADE
AND WERE REFLECTED IN ALL COUNTY
LETTER THAT WAS ISSUED.
BACK IN MARCH --
A FEW A FEW DATA POINTS ABOUT
ABOUT CAL WORKS AND CLIENTS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ON AS I MENTIONED WE DO HAVE THE
ONLINE CAL WORKS APPRAISAL TOOL.
AND IT IS DESIGNED TO BE A VERY
SENSITIVE TOOL AND ESSENTIALLY
IT'S A SERIES OF QUESTIONS AND
DEPENDING OF THOSE QUESTIONS ARE
ANSWERED LEADS TO MORE
QUESTIONS.
AND A BASED ON THE APPROXIMATELY
21% OF CLIENTS WHO GO THROUGH
THAT APPRAISAL COM.
ARE HOW ARE ARE ESSENTIALLY
HAVING DOMESTIC ABUSE IDENTIFIED
AS AN ISSUE THAT PERHAPS NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN THERE IS --
THAT THE CLIENT ARM.
FELT IT WAS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THAT.
IT'D BEEN DISCUSSED AND A CHOICE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MADE BECAUSE IT
WAS IDENTIFIED AS A POTENTIAL
BARRIER [inaudible]
ARMED [inaudible]
ANOTHER.
PIECE OF DATA WHICH ACTUALLY IS
MUCH THAT IS A MUCH SMALLER
NUMBER IS FROM ARE ARE
ESSENTIALLY AGGREGATE DATA FROM
WITH THE COUNTY SUBMIT TO US IN
THE WELFARE TO WORK.
TWENTY FIVE ABOUT TWENTY TWO
POINT 1% OF ENROLLEES IN WELFARE
TO WORK ON ESSENTIALLY ARE
ENGAGE.
IN DOMESTIC ABUSE SERVICES AT
ANY POINT IN TIME THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR MORE WITH TOUCH THAT THAN
THE TWO POINT 1% THAT WOULD BE
AN AVERAGE MONTHLY FIGURE.
ABOUT POINT 5% RECEIVE A WAIVER
OF REQUIREMENTS THAT IS OF
COURSE SIGNIFICANTLY LAST IN THE
21% I MENTIONED EARLIER.
SOME OF THAT IS A FUNCTION OF IT
BEING SENSITIVE AND NOTS WANTED
ARM AND NOT NECESSARILY AYE AYE.
A LACK OF REFERRALS BUT THAT IS
KIND OF THE NEXT CHALLENGE FLORA
FOR US THAT CDSS IS TRYING TO
LOOK AT THAT ONLINE CAL WORKS
APPRAISAL TOOL DATA AND NOT JUST
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR ALL
SERVICES.
AND SEEING HOW THAT WINDS UP
WITH THE SERVICES CLIENTS ARE
GETTING AND YOU KNOW THE CAL OR
CAL WORKS ACCOUNTABILITY
OUTCOMES REVIEW PROCESS AND
COUNTY SELF ASSESSMENTS ARE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT THOSE KINDS
OF ISSUES AS WELL.
INTO THE FUTURE.
ON TURNING TOOK TURNING TO CAL
FRESH CONFERENCES AGAIN OUR FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM --
FOR SERVING OVER FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ON ABOUT TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS COM AND
ACROSS THE YEAR.
ALTHOUGH IT ONLY SERVES FOUR
MILLION AT A GIVEN MOMENT IN
TIME WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW MANY
IT'S TOUCHED IN THE WHOLE YEAR
IT'S MORE LIKE FIVE OR SIX
MILLION BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE ON
IT.
OFFER MAYBE A SHORTER AMOUNT OF
TIME --
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MAY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR EXPEDITED
SERVICE ON AND BE ABLE TO
ESSENTIALLY GET THE BENEFIT MORE
QUICKLY [inaudible]
ALSO ON A UNDER UNDER ARE UNDER
OUR STATUTE ON VICTIMS OF ABUSE
CAN ESTABLISH THEIR OWN
HOUSEHOLD A POTENTIALLY RECEIVE
UP TO ONE MONTH OF DUPLICATE
DATE.
SORT OF ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE OF
SORT OF SEPARATING AND THE
ABILITY TO GET SOME BENEFITS
RIGHT AWAY [inaudible]
ON THOSE ARE THOSE ARE OUR TWO
BIGGEST PROGRAMS AND THOSE ARE
SORT OF THE WAY THEY INTERACT
AND TOUCH ON THAT OF COURSE
INCOME MAINTENANCE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT CAL WORKS
DOES IS IS CRITICAL FOR NOT JUST
THE DUMBEST VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BUT BUT ALL ALL LOW
INCOME.
RECIPIENTS AND I GUESS I WOULD
JUST ALSO SAY THAT AT THE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF THAT WE HAVE A ROBUST
CAL ARTS PROGRAM OUR VERSION OF
THE TANF PROGRAM.
AT THE AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
ONLY ABOUT 18220% OF THE
CHILDREN IN POVERTY IN THE CITY
UNDER THE OFFICIAL POVERTY
MEASURE ARE ACTUALLY SERVED IN
THE NATIONAL TANF PROGRAM.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA THAT NUMBERS
HIGHER.
IT'S IN THE IT'S IN THE 50%
RANGE CAN'T THAT'S NOT AS HIGH
AS IT WAS AND I'M NOT SAYING
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM IS PERFECT
BUT WE ARE.
PROUD IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE ROBUST PROGRAM THAT WE DO
HAVE [inaudible]
ON TURNING TO ITEM TO
TRAFFICKING AND CRIME VICTIMS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ESSENTIALLY
ON CERTAIN ON CERTAIN --
IMMIGRANTS OF CERTAIN --
STERN TYPES OF STATUS
ESSENTIALLY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL PROGRAMS BUT UNDER T.
SIVA ESSENTIAL THAT'S A STATE
ONLY PROGRAM ESTABLISHED OVER A
DECADE AGO AND ESSENTIALLY IT
PROVIDES STATE ONLY FUNDING IT
SORT OF HELPS FILL.
A GAP ARM SPECIFICALLY ON IT
HELPS IMMIGRANTS WHO FLED WITH
THE U. VISA PETITION I CAN
QUALIFY FOR CASH ASSISTANCE FOOD
BENEFITS EMPLOYMENT OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES.
ON IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ON THE
ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT SIXTY ONE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
SERVE STATEWIDE BY TO SEE ABOUT.
AND MANY OF THOSE ALTHOUGH NOT
ALL WILL BE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE.
FINALLY I JUST LIKE TO MENTION
THAT ON THE YEAH THROUGH THROUGH
OUR DEPARTMENT OFFERS LEGAL
SERVICES ON TO IMMIGRANTS AND
AND THROUGH VARIOUS PROGRAMMES
AND NONPROFITS.
AND ESSENTIALLY VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE CAN BE ELIGIBLE
TO PURSUE IMMIGRATION LEGAL
REMEDIES THROUGH THROUGH OUR OR
ON U. VISAS ARE SILENT AND LEGAL
ASSISTANCE IS AVAILABLE THROUGH
OUR NONPROFIT CONTRACTORS.
THOSE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS OF HOW
CALICO FOR HIS PROGRAMS INTERACT
WITH DOMESTIC.
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONYX WE HAVE
LARA MANUALS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
SPECIALIST THREE OF YOLO COUNTY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
AND SO I I WORK BASICALLY I
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES --
SPECIALIST FIELD COUNTY SO WHAT
I DO IS THAT I WORK WITH ALL OF
THE WONDERFUL PROGRAMS I HAVE
BEEN CREATED AND I AM A CASE
MANAGER FOR WELFARE TO WORK
FAMILY STABILISATION THE HSP
PROGRAM WHICH IS HOUSING
ALLOCATION.
AND LINKAGES THOSE ARE THE CASES
THAT ARE LINKED WITH CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SO.
WE DO SERVE PROBABLY SENT OUT
WHAT.
CAN BE QUITE ROLLED INTO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AT ANY MOMENT
IN TIME.
SO THEY MAY COME THROUGH AND WE
DO IDENTIFY DOMESTIC --
VIOLENCE VICTIMS THROUGH THE
INTAKE PROCESS WHEN THEY'RE
COMING THROUGH INITIALLY
APPLYING FOR CASH ASSISTANCE.
ON ELIGIBILITY WILL PROVIDE THE
BOTH THE D. V. INFORMING NOTICE
SO THEY ARE TOLD ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT WE CAN
OFFER THEM WITH REGARDS TO THE
MYSTIC VIOLENCE RIGHT AT
APPLICATION.
WE DO RECEIVE REFERRALS FROM
LIKE THE TV SHELTER SO WE HAVE A
GOOD PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UP
EMPOWER YOLO WHICH IS THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CENTER.
WITHIN YOLO COUNTY ON THEIR
SHELTER --
WILLED.
UP MOMS OR IF IT'S A FATHER I
THOUGHT YOU HAVE A FATHER THAT
I'M CURRENTLY WORKING WITH BUT
THEY'D USE ON THE PLUS DEL LET
US KNOW THAT ARE SENDING THEM
OVER. TO THE WE GET KIND OF
GUIDE THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS
BECAUSE IT IT CAN BE A VERY.
CONFUSING PROCESS FOR THEM IF
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN ON AID SO IF
THEY LET US KNOW WE KIND OF GOT
HIM THROUGH THE PROCESS OR HELP
THEM SET UP APPOINTMENTS WITH
ELIGIBILITY TO WILL SPEAK WITH
SUPERVISOR SO THAT THEY CAN KIND
OF EXPEDITE PROCESS FOR THEM.
WE ALSO RECEIVE REFERRALS FROM
--
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES OF THEIR
THOUGHTS THEY KNOW IT'S NOT
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE THEY WILL
SEND THEM TO US AS WELL SO THERE
ARE WAYS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THEY ARE RECEIVING EXPEDITED
SERVICES TO ENABLE THEM.
TO ACCESS OTHER SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES UNTIL ONE OF THE THINGS
IS BASICALLY AFTER SEEING THEIR
SAFETY FIRST AND FOREMOST UP YOU
KNOW DO THEY HAVE A SAFE PLACE
TO BE AT IF THEY ARE NOT COMING
FROM THE SHELTER.
AND IF NOT CAN WE LOCATE ONE SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE IS THROUGH THE HEALTH ALLOW
OCCASION PROGRAM IS.
IF THE FAMILIES ARE COMING IN
THERE HOMELESS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
LEFT THE HOME ESSENTIALLY WE
WILL PUT THEM IN A MOTEL SHORT
TERM AND WORK WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW TO ACHIEVE --
PERMIT HOUSING LATER ON BUT IT'S
REALLY TAKING CARE OF THEM AT
THAT PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME
AND WE DO LOOK AT REFERRING THEM
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES NOT
JUST THE ADULTS BUT THE CHILDREN
ITS WEALTH WITH THERE BEING
IMPACTED.
UP ONE OF THE THINGS TO CONSIDER
IS THAT THERE MAY BE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE --
GOING ON AT THE SAME TIME AS
WELL SO THOSE ARE OTHER SERVICES
THAT WE DO NEED TO ADDRESS BUT
THE FIRST IS THE THE SHELTER
ISSUE AND THEN MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE SAFE AND THEN LATER ON
REALLY.
WE HAVE TO MEET THE CUSTOMER
WHERE THEY'RE AT SO.
IT'S AND THEN YOU KNOW IT JUST
ADDRESSING BARRIERS ARE STE AS
THEY COME UP ONE OF THE THINGS
[inaudible] TO PARTICIPATE IN
THINGS LIKE.
THERE'S NOT TIMELINE YOU THEY
HAVE TO BE READY FOR THOSE
SERVICES WHEN THEY THEY COME AND
SO THE OTHER THING THAT WE WILL
ANOTHER WAY OF IDENTIFY THE IN
AND IDENTIFYING THEM AS THROUGH
SELF DISCLOSURE.
AS WELL SO ON INDIA WE DO YOU
APPRAISE SEVESO IT THROUGH THE
UP ONLINE ON TELEWORK SUBBASAL
TOLD THERE IS A SPECIFIC
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SECTION THAT.
YOU KNOW TOUCHES UPON THOSE SO
WE DO IDENTIFY THEM IN THAT
REGARD AS WELL.
ON A LOT OF THE TIMES THEY HAVE
PISSED DOUBLE TRUST THE WORKER
TO BE ABLE TO DISCLOSE THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL SO WE DO
WORK WITH THEM AT THAT
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME.
AND THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE
OUR WHICH TO BE AS COMPREHENSIVE
AS POSSIBLE SO BASICALLY UP
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
SERVICES WE UP AND ROLLED UP MY
FAMILY CIVILIZATION FOR THE
WEEKEND.
ACCESS OFFER MORE SERVICES TO
THE CHILDREN AS WELL SO WE WANT
TO WORK WITH THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
ON TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS UP WE
HAVE -- IF
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN EDUCATION
THAT THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE
WORK TOWARDS IF THEY NEED WORK
EXPERIENCE OR WE REFER THEM FOR
SUBSIDIZED DEPLOYMENTS OR REALLY
TRYING.
TO WORK WITH THEM OVER TIME TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS ALL OF THEIR
NEEDS BECAUSE EVENTUALLY WE WANT
THEM TO BE.
SELF SUSTAINING TO ESTABLISH
THAT ON THE STABILITY AND BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
AND THEIR KIDDOS ON SO.
IT'S REALLY A COMPREHENSIVE OF
SERVICE PROVISION THAT INCLUDES
ALL THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE.
AND WE HAVE HAD SOME VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
YOU KNOW FAMILIES AYE HOW TWO
LADIES WHO HAVE GONE OFF OF THE
VAGUE NOW BECAUSE THEY HAVE FULL
TIME EMPLOYMENT.
ON THE WAR PART OF A FAMILY SAY
WELL ISOLATION.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO DO LIKE OF
ACTUAL PREVENTION FOR THEM FOR
TO MAINTAIN THEIR HOME.
AND SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DID FOR THEM --
I HAVE ANOTHER ONE THAT I JUST
--
AND WHEN SHE CAME THROUGH I MEAN
SHE LITERALLY MOVED INTO A
APARTMENT THAT WASN'T REALLY
SUBSTANDARD BUT THAT WAS THE
ONLY THING THAT YOU COULD GET
INTO NOW SHE'S IN OF MICE PLACE.
SHE'S LIKE UNSAFE YOU KNOW I
SHE'S GONNA COMPLETE HER NURSING
PROGRAM IN.
MAY.
AND JOHN SHE'S HAPPY.
THE REAL WORLD.
WOULD YOU LIKE THAT ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WILL BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
IF THE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
FOR OF THIS SECOND PANEL
[inaudible]
SURE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
MY QUESTION WAS FOR MISS MINIONS
AND AGAIN I WANT TO LOOK AT THE
TWO GENERATION MODEL YOU SAID
THAT THERE WERE SERVICES THAT
WERE PROVIDED TO THE CHILDREN
CAN YOU BE MORE EXPLICIT.
WORD I THAT OF SCREENINGS DO WE
DO HOW DO WE HELP TO IDENTIFY
TRAUMA.
WHAT IS CURRENTLY BEING DONE AND
DOES THERE NEED TO BE SOME
STRENGTHENING? TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE KIDS ARE BEING TAKEN CARE
OFFICE WHAT.
DO WE ARE OFFERING SERVICES
THEIR FAMILY STABLE ISOLATION
THE WINDOW ROLLED UP FAMILIES
AND FAMILY STABILIZATION AYE WE
DO REFER THAT CHILDREN. TO
RECEIVE COUNSELLING SERVICES BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE OFFERING
THEM -- YEAH
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES TO
KIND OF HELP THEM.
WITH THEIR EXCITING WHAT NOT SO
FOR THIS IS ONE OF MY COWORKERS
AND THAT PAIN --
FOR UP WRITING LESSONS FOR THE
KIDDO AND THAT REALLY HELPED
THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE INTERACTING
WITH OTHER PEOPLE YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE ANIMALS LET'S THERAPY FOR
THEM AS WELL.
AND SO THEY'RE BENEFITING FROM
THAT SO IT'S REALLY.
SHOWING THEM A DIFFERENT WAY.
OF OF LIFE ESSENTIALLY SO KIND
OF LETTING THEM KNOW THERE IS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT IT'S DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE WHAT YOU EXPERIENCE
BEFORE BECAUSE THERE'S OTHER.
YOU KNOW THAT IT WILL ESTABLISH
IN A SUPPORT NETWORK FOR THEM AS
WELL SO THAT THEY CAN RELY ON SO
THEY CAN.
ON HAVE DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES
AND JUST DIFFERENT ROLE MODELS.
REVEAL FOLLOW UP WITH MISTER
BLAND THEN IS THERE A SCREENING
MODALITY IS THERE A TOOL THAT WE
COULD USE THAT WOULD HELP REALLY
GOOD QUESTION I MEAN IT REALLY
REALLY ARE SCREENING TOOLS FOCUS
ON THE ADULT WHILE THE FAMILY
STABILIZATION ONE CLEARLY WAS
DESIGNED.
IT WAS SORT A BEFORE THE TO CHEN
NAME WAS REALLY SO COMMON WE
DIDN'T CALL IT TO CHEN THEN BUT
IT DOES LOOK AT SERVICES FOR THE
WHOLE FAMILY.
IT'S A REALLY GOOD POINT ABOUT
HOW WELL DO WE SCREEN BEYOND
WHAT ACCOUNT IS DOING AND AND
WHAT THE PARENTS ARE CHOOSING TO
DISCLOSE ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S
NEEDS AND HOW THEIR CHILDREN'S
NEEDS OF FACT.
ON THAT I THINK.
I THINK IT INTERESTING AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL DEBATE IS ON
POTENTIALLY THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT ADDING CHILD COM.
REDUCING CHILD POVERTY AS
POTENTIALLY A GOAL OF THE TANF
PROGRAM IS NOT CURRENTLY ON BUT
I THINK --
YOU KNOW THE VERSION THAT I'VE
SEEN OF THAT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL SPEAK IN TERMS OF ONLY
THINKING ABOUT CHILD POVERTY IN
TERMS OF THEIR PARENTS INCOME
BUT IT'S SO MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
THE CHILDREN HAVE SO MANY MORE
NEED SO I HOPE OF CONGRESS IS
THINKING OF ADDING THAT KIND OF
THING THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD
IDEA -- THEY
CAN THINK MORE BROADLY ABOUT THE
THE CHILDREN'S NEEDS BUT YOU
RAISE A REALLY GOOD QUESTION NOT
BRING THAT BACK TO MY ON MY TEAM
CONGRESS HAVE PROBLEM.
AT YOU KNOW I'D I'D BRING IT UP
AGAIN I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT
MARJORIE MASON CENTER I'M A I'M
A BIG FAN OF THEM IN THEIR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND A YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SHE
DOES IS SHE SCREAMS FOR ASUS.
FOR EVERY CHILD WHO COMES
THROUGH FOR THE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES THE TRAUMA
THAT THEY'RE EXPOSED.
TO I WONDER IF THERE'S A ROLE
FOUR PIECES TO PLAY IN TERMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO ENSURE THAT
--
WE ARE NOT [inaudible]
CONTINUING A A TREND TO SECOND
GENERATION THOUGH IT MAY
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO NIP IN THE
BUD AND IDENTIFY THE TRAUMA AND
GIVE THEM THE RESILIENCY
ENCRYPTING.
OKAY.
REAL QUICK TAKE AWAY WHAT CAN WE
DO TO TO HELP MAKE THINGS BETTER
[inaudible]
MISS WILLIAMS [inaudible]
HOUSING.
RIGHT NOW I MEAN WE HAVE THE YOU
KNOW IF YOU.
WE WERE TALKING TO ALLOW.
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE A PICTURE
OF THINGS.
AND IT'S REALLY [inaudible]
NOBODY EVER [inaudible]
VETERAN TRYING TO NEGOTIATE --
SO THAT THEY WON'T REMOVE IT
FROM THE RECORDS AND EVEN THEN
YOU KNOW A LOT OF IT.
FOR A PARTICIPANTS TO PAY OR
BURN THREE TIMES THE RENT.
I DON'T THINK FAUCETS BY IT'S
JUST.
BUT RIGHT NOW A ONE BEDROOM
YOU'RE LOOKING AT TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS DENIES THAT.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY COULD POINT
MADE IN THERE TO PEOPLE ON THE
HOUSEHOLD.
SILICON ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
SOMETHING DOLLARS THERE'S NO WAY
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD. TO PAY THE RENT AT ANY
GIVEN MOMENT TIME [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
MR BLACK.
I WAS GOING TO SAY THE SAME
THING AT THE I THINK I THINK
HOUSING HOW THEY TAKE IT TAKEN
FROM BOTH DIRECTIONS I MEAN I IN
OUR PROGRAMS --
DEAL WITH SUBSIDIES THEY DEAL
WITH ISSUES AROUND BARRIERS AND
WORKING WITH LANDLORDS IT AND
THAT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD BUT AND
AND AND YOU KNOW THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE HAVE GROWN AND AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
INVESTMENTS IN THEM.
ARE BUT ALSO ISSUES A BIGGER
ISSUES THAT ARE THE GO BEYOND
THIS COMMITTEE AND AND THIS
GROUP OF A NO OF SUPPLY AND TO
AND CONSTRUCTION AND AND
DENSITY.
AND AND JUST SORT OF BRINGING --
BRINGING UP BRINGING BRING THE
PRICE OF HOUSING NOT DOWN
THROUGH SUPPLY --
THIS IS JUST IT'S JUST A HUGE
ISSUE.
AND I JUST PUT IT.
WE HAVE A MURPHY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT RIGHT ACROSS FROM
OUR OFFICE --
A LA COUNTY THERE WERE.
THREE HUNDRED TRUE OR INTERESTS.
UP FOR FORTY EIGHT UNITS WHILE
OF SUBSIDIZED HOUSING SO I MEAN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT FORTY EIGHT
UNITS AND YOU HAVE. SIX HUNDRED
JUST YOU KNOW INTEREST.
APPLICATIONS THROUGH THAT'S NOT
EVEN THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WERE APPLYING FOR THOSE
UNITS.
ON BUT THERE'S REALLY A GREAT
DISPARITY WHEN IT COMES TO THAT
--
AND THEN THE THERE ARE SOME
OTHER --
SPECIALIZED YOU KNOW UNITS BUT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOU KNOW --
DISABILITY VERIFICATIONS TO
QUALIFY FOR THOSE SOCIALIST SO
IT.
WE SAID WE UNDERSTAND HOUSING
AND SO THIS LEGISLATURE AMONG A
SELECT COMMITTEE UNTIL HOUSING.
AND SO --
WHEN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WE GOT
SOME MONEY --
DEDICATED TO HOUSE AND WE HAVE
TO DO.
A LOT MORE AND SO CERTAINLY WILL
BE ABLE TO SHARE SOME OF THINGS
THAT COME OUT OF THIS HEARING --
WITH THOSE COMMITTEE WITH
COMMITTEE CHAIR OF HIS DAVID
CHIU OF HEALTH FOR THEY CAN
CONSIDER SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU HAVE ALREADY EXPRESSED THAT
HELPS US GET A LITTLE CLOSER TO
TRY TO RESOLVE.
OF THIS MUCH BIGGER ISSUE SO WE
WANT THANK.
PRESENT IS THAT THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH.
NEXT ONE A CALL UP OUR NEXT IS
GIVEN ROUND.
WHEN A CALL UP OUR NEXT PANEL
WHERE COULD PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES BE STRENGTHENED TO
BETTER SERVE SURVIVORS?
I WANNA CALL OF REPRESENTATIVE
WHO WAS SELF INTRODUCED
THEMSELVES --
WE HAVE THE PLOY ABILITY CASE
MANAGE AND SAFE ALTERNATIVE
VIOLENCE ENVIRONMENTS.
I WOULD YOU PLEASE COME FORTH
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT ADVOCATES
WAVED TO PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
ALSO POLICY ADVOCATES WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
THANK YOU LADIES FOR JOINING US
OUR CHAIR WILL BE BACK IN
MOMENTARILY SHE HAD A GO AND
PRESENT A BILL IN COMMITTEE.
AYE WE PLAY A NUMBER TO FOR
ROLES HERE SO WE'LL BE IN AND
OUT THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
SO -- PLEASE
SOBRE INTRODUCE [inaudible]
AND KELLY.
SO HI THERE THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING ME IN THE GEN MY AUNT
KELLY KEEP.
PLAYABILITY CASE MANAGER AT SAY
IF.
DAVID IS IT SAFE ALTERNATIVES A
VIOLIN FIREMEN'S RIGHT NONPROFIT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AGENCY ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
SOME OF THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE IS OUR SAFE HOUSE OR
EMPOWERMENT CENTER.
WHERE CLIENTS CAN GO AND
RECEIVE?
A WALK IN SUPPORT SERVICES AND
CASE MANAGEMENT WE ALSO HAVE A
CLINICAL COUNTING DEPARTMENT AND
ARE YOU SERVICES DEPARTMENT
[inaudible]
SO -- MY
ROLE AT THE EMPLOYABILITY CASE
MANAGERS THAT I'M ON THE GROUND
EVERY DAY IN THE SHELTER WORKING
WITH THE CLIENTS AND HELPING
THEM APPLY FOR BENEFITS AND
RESOLVE ANY ISSUES.
THAT COME UP WITH THEIR BENEFITS
PUBLIC BENEFITS ARE A LIFELINE
TO OUR CLIENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
TRAUMA AND TRANSITION.
I DEVELOPED A THOROUGH
UNDERSTANDING OF THE COUNTY'S
ELIGIBILITY PROCESS RULES AND
EXEMPTIONS PERTAINING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
OFTENTIMES WHEN A CLIENT NEEDS
COUNTY BENEFITS IS THEIR FIRST
TIME NAVIGATING THE SOCIAL
SERVICES SYSTEM.
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO WALK
THROUGH THE PROCESS HAND IN HAND
WITH A SURVIVOR. TO BEGIN I WANT
TO TELL YOU A STORY [inaudible]
SO.
I HAVE EVERYTHING CLIENT WHO'S
RELUCTANT TO APPLY FOR COUNTY
BENEFITS BECAUSE HER ABUSER HAD
THREATENED TO KILL HER.
IF THE COUNTY CAME AFTER HIM FOR
CHILD SUPPORT.
NINE SO AFTER CONNECTING WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT SOCIAL SERVICES
AND EXPLAIN THE PROBLEM I WAS
PROVIDED INFORMATION FOR THE
CLIENT TO FILE A GOOD CAUSE FORM
THAT WOULD EXEMPT HER FROM THE
CHILD SUPPORT COLLECTION CARMEN.
SO THE CLIENT HAD TAKE THOUGHT
HAD TO TAKE TIME OFF WORK WHICH
WAS ALREADY IN JEOPARDY OF
LOSING HER JOB BECAUSE OF THE
MISTAKES FROM ALL THE OTHER
PRIOR DOMESTIC ROUTES
INCIDENCES.
THE CLIENT APPLIED AND DURING
THAT PROCESS THE CLAIM WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE WORKER
WITH THE ABUSERS INFORMATION
ANYWAYS WHICH MADE HER VERY
NERVOUS.
ULTIMATELY SHE WITH THE NIGHT
THE COUNTY BENEFITS.
SO WITH THAT I COUNTY BENEFITS
BECAUSE OF HER TWO THOUSAND
DOLLAR A MONTH INCOME WHAT'S TOO
HIGH.
SO THIS IS THE MOTHER OF THREE
DO KEEP IN MIND THAT THE FAIR
MARKET RATE FOR STUDIO APARTMENT
ALAMEDA COUNTY IT'S EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY EVEN AFTER THE KIND
EXPLAINE HER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION AND THAT USE CURRENTLY
HOMELESS IN OUR SHELTER.
IT WOULD DISCOVERED IN A PROCESS
THAT THE COUNTY HAD MADE A
MISTAKE IN CALCULATING HER
BENEFITS FROM.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IS NOW
REQUIRING HER TO PAY BACK THE
OVERPAYMENT EVEN KNOW IF THE
COUNTY AIR.
SINCE THE KIND WITH THE NIGHT
BENEFITS SHE'S NOW INELIGIBLE
FOR THE COUNTY SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE SERVICES WHICH WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED HER TO CONTINUE
WORKING FULL TIME.
SO THE STORY IS NOT UNIQUE.
THERE ARE OTHER OTHER EXAMPLES I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THAT OUR DAY
TO DAY CHALLENGES I OFTEN SEE.
CLIENTS LANGUAGES ARE NOT ALWAYS
ACCOMMODATED WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES.
I HAD A SPANISH SPEAKING QUITE
RECENTLY GOING TO STILL CERTAIN
SOCIAL SERVICES AN OFFERING
INTERPRETER.
THERE IT'S ALL JUST DEVELOP THE
PAPERWORK AND BRING IT BACK.
THE CLIENTS THAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW TO FILL IT OUT I
WOULD LIKE INTERPRETER.
THERE ARE TOLD WE DON'T HAVE AN
INTERPRETER SO YOU CAN JUST COME
BACK ANOTHER DAY.
SO FOR OTHER VERY THREE THIN
CLIENTS ARE ALSO DENIED
BENEFITS.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN ONCE THE COURT
MANDATES CHILD SUPPORT --
DECLINES LOSE THEIR BENEFITS
BECAUSE IT IS SEEN AS AN
ALTERNATIVE --
SOURCE OF INCOME.
SO THEN THE CLIENT HAS TO RELY
ON THEIR VIEWS HERE TO PAY THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT ON TIME OR IF AT
ALL.
WHICH THEN IS PERPETUATING THE
CYCLE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SO I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THINKING ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS
LIKE BE PUT IN PLACE.
AND THAT COULD EASE SOME OF THE
HARDSHIP FOR SURVIVORS THAT WE
WORK WITH. FOR ONE PROVIDING
SOCIAL SERVICE WORKERS WITH MORE
EXTENSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TRAININGS.
THIS WILL HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
THE SURVIVOR MORIN HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THE CRIME
MAY BE RELUCTANT TO SHARE
INFORMATION ARE WHY THE KIND IS
PRESENTING THE WAY THAT THEY DO.
THIS WOULD HELP COUNTY WORKERS
BECOME MORE COMPASSIONATE AND
SENSITIVE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS.
I WAS ON THE PHONE RECENTLY THIS
WEEK WITH --
WITH THE COUNTY WORKER AND WITH
MY CLIENT.
IN MY CLIENT WAS ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT THE ABUSE A LITTLE BIT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE CRIME WAS
NERVOUS ABOUT SHARING THAT SHE
WAS IN A SHELTER.
SO THE CLIMATE BEGAN TO CRY AND
THE WORKERS.
PLAYERS UP TOGETHER [inaudible]
SO.
IN MY EXPERIENCE.
THEIR SITUATIONS WHERE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE NOT MADE AWARE OF
INTERNAL PROCESSES EXEMPTIONS
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
THE INCONSISTENCY IS THE MOST
CHALLENGING. FOR INSTANCE THE
CLIENT HAD THEIR BENEFIT
SANCTION FOR NOT PARTICIPATING
THE WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM WHEN
IN FACT THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
SOME CLIENTS ARE TONIGHT
EMERGENCY CATCH IT IN FOOD STAFF
BECAUSE THEY ARE TOLD ONCE
THEY'RE IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER BUT THEY DON'T QUALIFY.
CLIENTS DO NOT STAY WITH ONE
CASEWORKER THEREABOUTS TO DALY
WORKERS THEREFORE HAVING TO
REPEAT THEIR STORY TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
THEREFORE IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
HAVE A UNIVERSAL FROM PROVIDING
THE SERVICES.
IMPLEMENTING ADDITIONAL TRAINING
TO PROVIDE WORKERS WITH
INFORMATION RESOURCES TO BETTER
SERVE THE SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
THE OVERALL APPLICATION PROCESS
COULD BE ALSO GREATLY
SIMPLIFIED.
MOST PEOPLE DO NOT UNDERSTAND
LEGAL JARGON NUYS ON SOCIAL
SERVICES PAPERWORK.
I OR AGENCY WE SERVE CLIENTS
FROM A DIVERSE EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUNDS THEREFORE WE DEVELOP
OUR DOCUMENTS TO BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND MORE EASILY
UNDERSTOOD BY THE GENERAL
PUBLIC.
CLIENTS THAT NEED TO GET BIRTH
CERTIFICATES OF SECURITY CARDS
AND OTHER DOCUMENTS IN ORDER TO
MOVE FORWARD ELIGIBILITY
PROCESS.
SIMPLIFYING THE DOCUMENTS AND
INFORMATION NEEDED. FOR SOMEONE
TO RECEIVE BENEFITS COULD SPEED
UP THE PROCESS MAKING IT THE
BENEFITS IN THE SAME DAY.
ANOTHER SOLUTION COULD BE
EXTENDING SOCIAL SERVICES HOURS
ARE ADDING WEEKENDS TO A COMIC
CLIENTS WHO WORK OR HAVE
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL.
GOING TO SOCIAL SERVICES IS AN
ALL DAY EVENT CLIENTS HAVE TO
CHOOSE WHETHER TO GO TO WORK
TAKE THE KIDS TO SCHOOL ORBIT GO
GET BENEFITS.
ALTHOUGH SOME EXPERT I PROCESSES
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE LIKE AT
THE APPLICATION BEING ONLINE IF
YOU DO FILE THE ONLINE
APPLICATION IT TAKES THIRTY DAY
THING STILL HAVE TO GO DOWN TO
THE COUNTY INTO AN IN PERSON
INTERVIEW.
ALSO CAL WORKS IS BASED OFF THE
FEDERAL PARTY LIMIT WHICH FOR
FAMILY FOREST TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
CALATHEA GUIDELINES ARE BASED
OFF THE CLIENT'S GROWTH INCOME
AND NOT THEY'RE NOT WORTH NOT
WHAT THEY TAKE HOME.
HEARING CALIFRNIA A FAMILY FOR
MAY NOT EXCEED GROSSLY. FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR IT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL IF THEY
INCOME LIMIT WITH BASED OFF OF
OUR STATE OR EVEN --
CERTAIN COUNTY POVERTY LIMITS IT
WOULD SOLUTION COULD BE
INCREASING WILL --
INCOME LEVEL TO REFLECT THE
REALITY OF THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
INCREASING THE INCOME LIMIT FOR
ELIGIBILITY WITH SUPPORT THOSE
WHO MAKE TOO MUCH TO QUALIFY BUT
NOT ENOUGH TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS. FOR EXAMPLE MANY CLIENTS
HAVE BEEN DENIED SOME OF MY
CLIENTS HAVE BEEN DENIED BECAUSE
THEY EXCEED THE ELIGIBILITY
INCOME LIMIT I HAVE CLIENTS
BEING THE NIGHT FOR MAKING ONE
DOLLAR OVER THIS LIMIT AMOUNT.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE IS LIKE
CLIENTS WHO OWN CARS ARE OFTEN
AYE BECAUSE THE EXCEED THE ASSET
LIMIT.
CLIENTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
USES THESE CARS TO GET TO WORK
TAKE TAKE TAKE THE KIDS TO
SCHOOL OR IT'S THEIR ONLY SOURCE
OF HOUSING IN SHELTERS ARE FULL.
IN OUR COUNTY IN MY COUNTY
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE'RE LUCKY TO
HAVE THE CALVERTS COLLABORATIVE
WHICH IS THE GROUP AT THE MATH
OF BROWN'S PROVIDERS FUNDED BY
CAO WORK THAT MEET TOGETHER TO
BRIBE TO PROVIDE.
COORDINATING SERVICES FOR
SURVIVORS THIS COLLABORATION
IT'S HELPFUL BUT NOT ENOUGH.
HOWEVER MANY YEARS AGO ARE
COUNTY HAD SPECIALLY TRAINED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ADVOCATES WHO
WORKED AT SOCIAL SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY ARE COUNTY HAD AN
ACTUAL DOMESTIC BALLOT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
REESTABLISHING THE ADVOCATES
ROLES IN THIS COMING ACROSS
COOPERATE AND CROSS TRAIN TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS.
WE FINISHED YET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF WHAT WAS A COLLABORATIVE
CALL.
THE DVD COLLABORATIVE DEEP IN
HIS DILLON EXISTENCE.
THAT EVEN COVERED IT.
THEY'VE BEEN IS STILL MEET.
NOT OFTEN ENOUGH.
OKAY BUT YOU DO WORK YOU DO WORK
IN A CLUB TO FATTEN TO HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES ON
THE BED AND TRY TO ADDRESS ON
THESE BEARS AS YOU BROUGHT OUT.
THAT OTHER COUNTIES ARE ARE
EXPERIENCING YEAH AYE YOU AND BE
GOOD IF YOU WOULD PROVIDE US
WITH THAT INFORMATION SO THAT WE
CAN CERTAINLY.
TRY TO PASS ALONG THIS IN HOPES
THAT ONE OTHER COUNTIES COULD
TRY TO IMPLEMENT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT BECAUSE I'M A FIRM BELIEVER
THAT YOU CAN BRING ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO TRY.
TO TEAR DOWN SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS THAT YOU BROUGHT
FORWARD --
CERTAINLY THEY SEEM REASONABLE A
PERSON MAKING ONE DOLLAR OVER OR
OWNING A CAR I MEAN COME ON WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT YUMMY
ONES ABILITY TO GET AROUND. TO
TAKE PICTURES OF DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS AND THINGS OF A TO
BUY GROCERIES AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE RIGHT --
AND THAT'S NOT BE A A A A
BARRIER OR A STRIKE AGAINST YOU
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE FORTUNE OF
HAVING OWNING A VEHICLE AND SO
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I THINK A
A COLLABORATIVE GROUP WORKGROUP.
COMING TOGETHER --
TO SHARE SOME OF THESE IDEALS IT
HELPED TEAR DOWN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT BEAR SO IF YOU HAVE A
TEMPLATE THAT YOU CAN SHARE WITH
US THEN CERTAINLY LOBBY MORE
THAT HAPPENED I'M SURE --
SPEAK INTAKE A TICKET CHALLENGES
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CHAIRWOMAN WILL BE HAPPY TO HELP
INSTIGATE SOME OF THESE AND IN
OTHER AREAS WHERE WE CAN TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE BARRIERS I
THINK IS A WONDERFUL IDEA.
GREAT THANK YOU YEAH THANK YOU.
THIS AND BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEES THIS ANYONE OF THE
SCHOOL YOU HAVE QUESTION.
IBM SAID IF YOU COULD SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE JUST CONVEY THAT
YOUR SUMMARY OUTLINE --
THE THOSE POINTS YOU WENT
THROUGH I THINK THERE WOULD BE A
GOOD TO MEMORIALIZE THAT FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
AND IF YOU HAVE EXAMPLES YOU
TALKED ABOUT HOW SOME OF YOUR
INTAKE FORMS.
ARE DESIGNED THE KIND OF GET TO
THE HEART OF THE INFORMATION THE
LESS CUMBERSOME WAY.
YOU MIGHT SHARE SOME SAMPLES OF
HOW YOU TAKE INFORMATION.
AND HOW THAT MATCHES UP WITH A
STATE FORM CAN HELP US.
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE OF HILL OUR
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES --
A BARRIER YEAH I'M REALLY
SIMPLIFYING THE LANGUAGE THAT
THE SYSTEM HAS FORCED ALLOW
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS CAN BE A
VERY.
AND I THINK JUST COME.
PROVIDING HOW HOW YOU'VE EVOLVED
IT AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS.
I THINK THAT WOULD HELP US.
I THINK IF.
YOU.
NECKS PRESENTER.
HI MY NAME IS SACRIFICE ANJA I
AM I HAVE WORKED WITH WE'VE
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN THE
CAPACITY AS A VOLUNTEER IN AN
EMPLOYEE ON THE TOPICS OF
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT AND
FINANCIAL ABUSE.
I RETIRED FROM TWENTY YEARS IN
MORTGAGE BANKING IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN BEGAN
RESEARCHING THE TOPIC OF
FINANCIAL ABUSE.
AFTER WHAT I'D SEEN IN THE
BANKING INDUSTRY IN MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES HER SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN FINANCIAL
ABUSE.
I WAS ENERGIZED TO EXPLORE THE
ARENA AND SEE WHAT I CAN DO TO
HELP AT THE TIME THERE WAS VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION ON THE TOPIC
BUT A FEW STATS THAT KEPT COMING
UP WHICH CAUGHT MY ATTENTION
WERE.
AND STILL ARE THESE. 98299% OF
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NATIONWIDE HAVE BEEN FINANCIALLY
BEAST.
WOMEN LIVING IN POVERTY THAT'S
EARNING UNDER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND A YEAR.
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO SUFFER
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ONE OF IF
NOT THE LEADING CAUSE OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG WOMEN IN OUR
NATION. ONE IN THREE FAMILIES
ENTERING SHELTERS SITE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AS THE CAUSE.
AND YET EIGHT IN TEN SURVIVORS
LEAVE EMERGENCY SHELTERS WITHOUT
A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
GO.
DENNIS DOT THAT REALLY HAS ME
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY IS THE ONE
THAT PROVES BEING HERE IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO WITH MY TIME.
VICTIMS WHO WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
ECONOMIC STABILITY HAVE 70%
INCREASE IN SUCCESSFUL
SURVIVORSHIP.
THAT 70%.
WHAT I DISCOVERED WAS THAT
SAFETY FOR LOW INCOME SURVIVORS
WAS YOUR?
HAS REAL MONETARY COSTS
INCLUDING RELOCATION NEW OR
INCREASED RENT [inaudible]
TRANSPORTATION CHILDCARE QUARTER
LEGAL FEES AND TIME SPENT
ACCESSING ADVOCACY AND SERVICES.
THESE ARE OFTEN HARD COSTS
INFLEXIBLE TO INCOME
RESTRICTIONS.
THEY REQUIRE SURVIVORS TO MAKE
UNTENABLE CHOICES.
CHOICES BETWEEN VIOLENCE AND
POVERTY.
COMPOUNDING THESE EFFECTS
ABUSIVE PARTNERS YOU SYSTEMATIC
TACTICS OF CONTROL IN CORE XIN.
FINANCIAL ABUSERS EXPLOIT THEIR
PARTNERS THROUGH A VARIETY OF
METHODS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED.
TO LIMITING THEIR ABILITY TO
WORKER RETAINED EARNINGS
MAINTAINING CONTROL OF ALL
PROPERTY IN SAVINGS FORCING THEM
INTO COURSE DEBT AND SABOTAGING
EMPLOYMENT.
MOST OFTEN THE ABUSER KEEPS
TIGHT CONTROLS ON THE
INFORMATION ACCESSIBLE TO THE
VICTIM REGARDING THEIR FINANCIAL
WELL BEING.
HIDING ALL DATA ON DEBT SAVINGS
AND CREDIT STANDINGS.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL THOUGH IS
ALWAYS TO LIMIT THE AUTONOMY OF
THEIR PARTNER.
INTRIGUED BY THIS INFORMATION I
SOUGHT EDUCATION ON THE TOPIC
AND FOUND VERY FEW OPTIONS TO
LEARN MORE. ONE GROUP I FOUND
WAS OUT OF WASHINGTON DC.
THE CENTER FOR SURVIVORS AGENCY
AND JUSTICE.
THEY HAD STARTED TO DEVELOP A
CURRICULUM WHICH TO THIS DAY HAS
PROVED TO BE THE MOST CUTTING
EDGE LIBRARY OF INFORMATION ON
THE TOPIC I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
FIND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I LOOKED FOR RESOURCES WITHIN
SACRAMENTO IN CALIFORNIA AND
COMING UP NEARLY EMPTY HANDED WE
CREATED A FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT
CLASS THAT WE'VE.
IN THE CLASS WE EDUCATED PEOPLE
ON THE BASICS OF CREDIT AND
BUDGETING.
HOW TO IDENTIFY ISSUES?
WHAT TO DO TO PROTECT ONESELF
FROM IDENTITY THEFT AND FRAUD
AND HOW TO START THE SLOW PARTS
PROCESS OF REBUILDING THE
FINANCIAL PICTURE?
WE BEGAN PULLING CREDIT THROUGH
THE ANNUAL CREDIT REPORT DOT COM
SITE WHICH ALLOWS ALL AMERICANS
FREE ACCESS TO CREDIT REPORT
EACH YEAR.
AND FOUND THAT A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF ITS VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COULDN'T GET
PAST THE BASIC SECURITY
QUESTIONS TO ACCESS CREDIT.
DUE TO FINANCIAL ABUSE.
IN OTHER WORDS YOU HAVE TO KNOW
YOUR CREDIT TO ACCESS TO CREDIT.
THAT BEING THE CASE WE SOUGHT
OUT A PORTAL FOR CREDIT REVIEW
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO ACCESS
CREDIT REPORTS WITHOUT THE
SECURITY QUESTIONS AND FOUND OUT
PLATFORM.
WITH TRANS UNION IN A PORTAL
THEY'D BEEN USING FOR CHILDREN
EATING AGING OUT OF THE FOSTER
SYSTEM.
WITH THE AID IT STATE CONTROLLER
WE ARE ABLE TO GET THEM TO GRANT
US ACCESS FOR WE'VE CLIENTS.
SO THAT WE COULD HAVE ACCESS TO
REVIEW DISPUTE CREDIT ITEMS WITH
THE INDIVIDUAL.
YOU CAN ALSO GIVE A COPY OF THE
CREDIT REPORT TO THE CLIENT SO
THAT THEY COULD HAVE RECORD.
AND BEGIN THE LONG JOURNEY OF
ADDRESSING THE CREDIT ISSUE.
THIS MADE WE'VE THE FIRST AGENCY
IN THE COUNTRY TO USE THIS FOR
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
NOW YOU'LL PROBABLY BE MOST
INTERESTED IN IS THE ACTUAL WORK
I'VE BEEN DOING WITH
INDIVIDUALS.
MOST LIKELY WHY WAS ASKED HERE
TODAY AS I AM IN A ELITE SLASH
SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO DO
WHAT I DO IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA.
AND TO MY KNOWLEDGE ACROSS THE
STATE.
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS I'VE MET
WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
WOMEN IN SACRAMENTO WHO HAVE
SUFFERED FINANCIAL ABUSE.
I'VE SEEN EVERYTHING FROM SIMPLE
LATE PAYMENTS TO COURSE DATA
MORTGAGES.
IDENTITY THEFT RESULTING IN
CREDIT DEBT AND TENS OF
THOUSANDS AND ADULTS USING
CHILDREN'S IDENTITY TO FILE
TAXES IN CREATE CREDIT PROFILES.
WHAT I TYPICALLY SEE A CLIENT
AND THEY MAY HAVE ALL OR ONE OR?
SEVERAL.
NO BANK ACCOUNT OR ACCESS TO
FUNDS.
MANY TIMES THEY FIND THEY OWE
MONEY TO A BANK AND THEREFORE
CAN'T GET A BANK ACCOUNT AND IF
MARRIED CANNOT REMOVE THIS UP
SPELLS FROM THE ACCOUNT WITHOUT
THE SPOUSE PRESENT.
SAME IS TRUE WITH MOST CREDIT
CARDS.
REPORTER CREDIT AND LOW CREDIT
SCORE THE CREDIT SCORE SCALE
RUNS FROM.
THREE HUNDRED TO EIGHT FIFTY
WITH MOST CLIENTS I MEET WITH IN
THE THREE HUNDRED FIVE SEVENTY
NINE CATEGORY ALONG WITH 16% OF
THE NATION.
MAJORITY FOLKS IN THE COUNTRY
HAVE BETWEEN SIX SEVENTY AND
SEVEN NINETY NINE AND THAT
NUMBER MAKES UP APPROXIMATELY
47%.
THE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY.
I DEBT TO INCOME RATIOS THEY'RE
OFTEN UNEMPLOYED OR
UNDEREMPLOYED.
THEY HAVE ONE OR MORE
ADDICTIONS.
USE OF ACTIONS ARE OFTEN TIED TO
THE ABUSER AND CREATE EXTREME
DIFFICULTIES AND WE HOUSING EVEN
WHEN APPLYING FOR SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING.
JUDGMENTS ARE CHILD SUPPORT IN
ARREARS.
TAX LIENS OR TACK ISSUE THAT TAX
ISSUES CAUSED BY MISS FILINGS
NON FILINGS OR TAX FRAUD.
STUDENT LOANS IN DEFAULT.
WE SEE MULTIPLE STUDENT LOANS
AND FALL AND MOST OFTEN THEY'RE
FORCED TO DROP OUT BY THE ABUSER
OR DUE TO LACK OF CHILDCARE OR
TRANSPORTATION. ONE OR MORE
VEHICLES HAVE BEEN TOTALED
IMPOUNDED --
REPOSSESSED.
IT'S A COMMON TACTIC OF ABUSER
TO DESTROY THE VICTIM'S CARS
THEY CAN'T LEAVE AND IT'S FAIRLY
WELL KNOWN THAT A CAR IS SEEN BY
A VICTIM.
AS ITS INITIAL WAY OUT
ESPECIALLY WHEN CHILDREN ARE
INVOLVED.
IF THE SURVIVOR HAS BEEN A
VICTIM OF TRAFFICKING WE ALSO
SEE MANY AUTO LEASES WITH EARLY
TERMINATION IN OUTSTANDING
BALANCES.
AS THE ABUSERS HOPES CYCLES OF
LEASING HIGH AND CARS IN THE
VICTIM'S NAME AND TURNING THEM
BACK IN AFTER TWO TO THREE
MONTHS.
LEGAL FEES FOR DIVORCE AND CHILD
CUSTODY THIS CAN BE ANYWHERE
FROM A COUPLE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO SOME. TO SEVERAL CASES I'VE
SEEN THAT IT ENDED UP COSTING
CLOSER TO THIRTY FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AND SOME CASES GET DROPPED BY
LEGAL AID AS THE CASE BECOMES
TOO COMPLEX MOST OFTEN AT THE
WELL IN CRAFT OF THE ABUSER.
THEY HAVE A SPOUSE THAT DOESN'T
WORK OR HIDES INCOME THEREFORE
REDUCING ANY SUPPORT LEAVING THE
VICTIM PALACE PENNILESS UPON
SETTLEMENT.
AND MOST OF THE CLIENTS.
OUR EMBATTLED IN CUSTODY CASES
MANY OF WHICH INVOLVE CPS.
ALMOST ALL SUFFER SOME DEGREE OF
PTSD TYPE SYMPTOMS.
WHICH CREATE HUGE CHALLENGES ONE
TRYING TO FOCUS ON ALL DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF RECREATING THEIR
LIVES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
FINANCIAL ASPECTS OF THEIR
LIVES.
WHICH MOST OF THEM HAVE LITTLE
TO NO EDUCATION OR EXPERIENCE IN
MANAGING.
MOST OFTEN WHEN I MEET WITH THE
CLIENTS THE FIRST TIME THEY'VE
SEEN THEIR ENTIRE FINANCIAL
PICTURE IN CREDIT REPORT.
THEY MAY ASSUME THEIR CREDIT
REPORT IS DAMAGED.
THEY MAY KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
KICKED OUT OF AN APARTMENT.
BUT THEY MAY NOT KNOW THAT THEY
OWE THREE TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PASS LANDLORDS.
THEY KNOW THEY'RE LEFT WITH ONLY
THE MONEY THEIR POCKET IF ANY.
AND THE MAJORITY THINK
BANKRUPTCY IS THE ONLY WAY OUT
BUT WHAT THEY DON'T KNOW IS IT
BANKRUPTCIES COST MONEY.
AND HAVE TO QUALIFY WHICH TAKES
OFF THE TABLE FOR MANY OF THEM.
UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN TIPPED OFF BY
MAIL OR PHONE CALL FROM THE IRS
TO CREDITORS THIS IS VERY
TYPICALLY THE FIRST TIME THE
VICTIM IS ALLERGIC TO THE EXTENT
OF THE FINANCIAL ABUSE.
IT'S A VERY EMOTIONAL EXPERIENCE
FROM US VICTIMS AS MONEY RUNS
THROUGH EVERYTHING IN OUR LIVES
YOU CAN GIVEN A COUNT OF WHO YOU
ARE AND WHATYOU'VE BEEN THROUGH
BY LOOKING AT YOUR CREDIT REPORT
AND BANK STATEMENTS.
IF YOU HAVE ACCESS TO THEM.
IN THE MOST SEVERE CASES CLIENTS
FIND THE ON PROPERTIES THEY
DIDN'T KNOW INTEL THEY'VE NEVER
PHYSICALLY VISITED.
THEIR CREDIT CARDS IN THEIR
NAMES OF BALANCES THEY DIDN'T
KNOW THEY HAD THEY HAVE
ADDICTIONS COLLECTIONS FOR
EVERYTHING YOU CAN IMAGINE.
AND THE MOST HURTFUL OF THOSE
COLLECTIONS ARE FOR COSIGNED
BAIL WHERE THEY WERE FORCED TO
BAIL OUT THEIR VERY OWN ABUSER.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM FOR THE
AVERAGE KIND OF MET WITH ISRAEL
HOUSING.
IN AN ALREADY TIGHT HOUSING
MARKET A PERSON WITH CREDIT
ISSUE HAS AN EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
TIME FINDING A LANDLORD THAT
WILL GIVE THEM A CHANCE WITH LOW
CREDIT SCORES AND POOR RENTAL
RATINGS.
AND WHEN THEY FIND THAT RARE
COMBINATION OF AFFORDABILITY AND
SECOND CHANCE CREDIT.
THE HOUSING ISN'T USUALLY CLOSED
TO TRANSPORTATION IN GOOD SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEAR GOOD PAYING JOBS
OR NEAR AMPLE CHILDCARE OPTIONS.
I HAVE A KIND OF IN WORKING WITH
FOR MONTHS WHO HAS COLLECTIONS
AND EVICTIONS DUE TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND FINANCIAL ABUSE.
SHE WAS TURNED DOWN BY ONE LAND
ART AFTER THE OTHER FOR POOR
CREDIT PARENTAL HISTORY AND
COLLECTIONS TOTALING MORE THAN
THE RENT.
SHE WOULD WALK FROM SHELTER EACH
DATA PUBLIC TRANSIT.
TRANSIT WITH THREE KIDS DROPPED
THEM OFF AT SCHOOL GO BACK TO
TRANSIT TO APPLY FOR EMPLOYMENT.
GET BACK ON TRANSIT OR WALK TO
HUMAN SERVICES OFFICE TO OBTAIN
SERVICES OR GET TO THE FOOD BANK
FOR GROCERIES.
GET BACK TO PICK UP CHILDREN
FROM SCHOOL IT BACK TO SHELTER
VIA MULTIPLE BUSES.
WITH THREE CHILDREN IN TOW ALL
THEIR BELONGINGS PLUS GROCERIES
AND IMMEDIATELY UPON RETURN
ATTEMPT TO MAKE A DOZEN CALLS ON
HOUSING WAITING LIST TO SEE IF
ANY OPENINGS CAME UP BEFORE THE
OFFICES CLOSE.
WHAT WE FOUND IS MOST PLACES
HAVE WAITING LISTS NOW AND THE
REPORT THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER
CALLING IN ON ON THE LIST?
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT SURE IF
THEY'RE STILL LOOKING FOR
HOUSING.
I AM HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THIS
CLIENT WAS ABLE TO FIND A GOOD
JOB IN ON JUNE FIRST WE WAS ABLE
TO ASSIST US CLIENT WITH THEIR
DEPOSIT AND SHE WAS ABLE TO
OBTAIN HOUSING.
WITH SIGNED LEASE IN HAND SHE
CAME INTO MY OFFICE AND SOBBED
FOR OVER AN HOUR.
SHE WAS HAPPY SCARED RELIEVED
AND ANXIOUS ABOUT OUR FUTURE
FUTURE BUT MOSTLY SHE WAS FLAT
OUT EXHAUSTED.
THAT WAS ONLY THE FIRST STEP NOW
SHE BEGINS A LONG CLIMB UP THE
MOUNTAIN OF DEBT FINANCIALLY
RECOVER FOR HERSELF AND HER
THREE CHILDREN.
ON THE OTHER SPECTRUM IS A
CLIENT I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SINCE LAST OCTOBER WHO RIDER
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT CLASS WITH
A BAG FULL OF MAIL SHE JUST
STARTED RECEIVING IT HAD NO IDEA
WHAT ANY OF IT WAS.
THIS CLIENT IS A HIGHLY EDUCATED
PERSON WITH AN EXCELLENT CLICK
CAREER.
SHE HAS BEEN EMPLOYED FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AS A HIGH END
EDUCATOR.
AS IT TURNED OUT THE BAG WAS
FULL OF MAIL LETTERS FROM
CREDITORS IN THE IRS.
WHAT WE FOUND WAS OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DEBT HER
NAME ON MULTIPLE CREDIT CARDS
FOR WHICH DID NOT APPLY?
A BUSINESS THAT WAS CREATED IN
OUR NAME.
WITHOUT OUR KNOWLEDGE BUT DEBT
ACCRUED UNDER COMPANY CREDIT
CARDS.
IRIS INFORMATION WITH THAT RICH
REVEALED TAX REFUND SHE EARNED
BUT NEVER SAW FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
INSURANCE INSURANCE FUNDS THAT
APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN FRAUDULENTLY
OBTAINED AND DISPERSED BY HER
ABUSER.
THERE ARE NO LAWS TO PROTECT
HER.
THE POLICE TOOK REPORT BUT DON'T
HAVE THE MANPOWER TO LAUNCH SUCH
COMPLEX FINANCIAL INVESTIGATION.
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
WON'T TAKE AN IDENTITY THEFT
CLAIM OVER THE PHONE.
AS THE PERSON WHO SOLD HER
IDENTITY AS HER SPOUSE AND THEY
DON'T CONSIDER THAT A QUALIFYING
EVENT.
SEVERAL ATTORNEYS INCLUDING THE
DA'S OFFICE HAVE REVIEWED THE
CASE GOING TO TURN THE CLIENT
AWAY DUE TO LACK OF CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
THAT CAN APPLY TO THE CASE.
BANKRUPTCY WILL MOST LIKELY BE
OUR ONLY COURSE OF ACTION THIS
POINT.
WHAT SHE CAN GET HER DIVORCE
FINALIZED IF YOU CAN?
AND THAT WILL HAVE AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON HER FOR YEARS SHE WILL
STRUGGLE TO FIND A RENTAL SHE
WILL BE KEPT FROM BUYING A HOME.
AND WHAT SHE IS ELIGIBLE SHE
WILL PAY A HIGHER INTEREST RATE.
SHE WILL PAY HIGHER INTEREST
RATE SHE GOES TO BUY A CAR.
AND SHE WILL LOSE ALL OF HER
GOOD CREDIT THE CREDIT SHE
ACTUALLY APPLIED FOR AND
MAINTAINED PERFECTLY.
IN ORDER TO GET RID OF ALL THE
BAD DEBT HER ABUSER TOOK OUT HER
NAME.
THIS CLIENT WILL HAVE TO START
OVER FINANCIALLY AT A TIME IN
HER LIFE WHEN SHE SHOULD BE
MAKING PLANS FOR RETIREMENT.
SHE WILL BE FORCED TO REINVENT
HERSELF AND HER FINANCIALS.
BEFORE I WALKED IN HERE TODAY
AYE LETTER NO I'VE SPEAKING
HERE.
BOB AND I RECEIVED A TEXT FROM
HER.
WHERE SHE OUTLINED HER THIRD
VISIT TO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
TODAY IN HOPES OF GETTING A
WARRANT?
THAT SHE COULD USE WITH THE DA.
SHE WAS TOLD THAT ALTHOUGH.
HIS ACTIVITY WAS CRIMINAL IT WAS
NOT ILLEGAL.
SHE GOES ON TO STATE THAT IF IT
WERE NOT FOR HER DAUGHTER.
SHE IS AT THE POINT WHERE SHE
WOULD TAKE HER LIFE.
BECAUSE SHE IS SO TIRED OF THE
MANIPULATION THE ABUSE.
AND SHE'S JUST FLAT OUT DONE.
SO I'VE HEARD YOU ASK HOW WE CAN
HELP.
ON HERE'S FEW IDEAS WELL JUST
JUMP RIGHT TO IT --
WE NEED LAWS TO PROTECT VICTIMS
OF FINANCIAL ABUSE --
FINANCIAL ABUSES MENTIONED
INVOLVED BUT IT'S NOT COVERED.
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
WE NEED TO BE A LOT MORE
TRANSPORTATION ANSWERS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE HAULING CHILDREN AROUND.
CHILDCARE AND MORE RAPID PAYMENT
OF PROVIDERS SO MORE PROVIDERS
WILL COME ONLINE.
THEY NEED CHILDCARE.
WHILE THEY APPLY FOR WORK THEY
NEED PROGRAMS THAT WILL
TRANSPORT KIDS FROM SCHOOL TO
AFTER SCHOOL CARE.
THEY NEED SUMMER CARE FOR KIDS
THAT COVER WORK HOURS.
WHEN YOU LANDLORDS ARE WILLING
TO WORK WITH CHALLENGE CREDIT?
WE NEED MORE ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ARE PROVIDING INFORMATION OF
FINANCIAL ABUSE AND ACCESS TO
CREDIT REPORTS AND CREDIT
COUNSELORS.
MANY MORE LEGAL AID FOR DIVORCE
AND CUSTODY CASE WITH SLIDING
PAY SCALES.
WE NEED TO CREATE MORE LONG TERM
HOUSING SHELTERS SO TO TWELVE
MONTHS I WOULD SAY. FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
FINANCIAL ABUSE THAT THEY HAVE
THE TIME TO ADDRESS ISSUES THAT
KEPT THEM FROM FINDING LONG TERM
HOUSING CHILDCARE TRANSPORTATION
AND EMPLOYMENT.
WE NEED TO CREATE MORE AVENUES
TO ADDRESS UNLAWFUL DETAINER. TO
HELP PEOPLE AND CLEARING THEM
OFF THE RECORDS.
OR REDUCTIONS IN SETTLEMENTS
WERE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
FINANCIAL ABUSE CAN BE SHOWN TO
BE THE CAUSE OF ACTION TO
INCREASE SURVIVORS ABILITY TO RE
HOUSE THEMSELVES.
AND WE NEED TO EDUCATE AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL REGARDING
CREDIT BUDGETING FINANCIAL
SAFETY.
ESPECIALLY AROUND TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
YOUR INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARMY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK WE GOT ALL YOUR POINTS
DOWN BUT YOU HAVE A DOCUMENT
THAT YOU'RE READING FROM YOU CAN
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE JUST
SO WE CAN GET.
AND HAVE EVERYTHING ACCURATELY
OF DOWN YOU KNOW I I I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS A
WAY -- TO
FURTHER VICTIMIZE --
ONE WHO HAS BEEN ABUSED I'M I'M
THINKING OF A GENTLEMAN WHO'S AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP WOES
[inaudible]
WHOSE PARTNER.
DID EVERYTHING HE COULD
LITERALLY BY CONVINCING THE BANK
THAT THEY WERE THAT HE HAD.
ACCESS SO THEY WERE JOINT
CUSTODY ON ACCOUNT CLOSE THEY
COUNT MOVED ALL THE MONEY OUT --
AND THEN PUT HIS NAME ON THE
LEASE --
WHICH WAS NOT LEGAL PUT HIS NAME
ON THE LEASE AND THAT WAS A WAY
TO CONTINUE TO FURTHER.
ABUSE -- OF
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND ALSO THAT
THAT THE MENTAL --
ABUSE AND THE MOST ABUSED AT
THAT PLAYED --
AS A ROLL OF THIS INDIVIDUAL AND
SO I'VE TRIED SEIZE GIVES ME
NOTES I POSSIBLY CAN IN TERMS OF
SOME YEARS SUGGESTS I
APPRECIATE.
UNDER PRESENTATION OF MISTER
COOLEY.
HOMELESS FOUR I DID WANT TO JUST
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT ABOUT
NEEDING MORE TIME AND HOUSING.
SELECT TO JUST GIVE THEM PLACE.
SAFETY FORCING TRY TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE ISSUES
[inaudible]
I THINK.
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY OF FINANCIAL ABUSE IT
MAY NOT EVEN COME TO THEIR
ATTENTION.
UNTIL IT COMES OUR ATTENTION IN
A BIG WAY [inaudible]
THE IT JUST MAKES SENSE TO ME
THAT PEOPLE NEED A PLACE FROM
WHICH THEY CAN TAKE A DEEP
BREATH AND TRY TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE [inaudible]
ISSUES AND TIME.
IS AN ELEMENT IN THAT SOLUTION
AS WELL AS THE OTHER.
TYPES OF HER CONCRETE
SUGGESTIONS YOU HAVE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR KIND OF PUT THE
SPOTLIGHT.
ON EVERYTHING BUT THAT REALLY
JUMPED OUT AT ME IS VERY
PRACTICAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I NEXT AND
FINAL PRESENTER.
THANK YOU I'M A SURCHARGE
ESCOBAR'S LOW AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY I WANT
TO THANK A CHAIRPERSON RUBIO
FORD AT CONVENING.
THE COMMITTEE AND FOR EACH OF
YOU THAT WHO HAVE ATTENDED.
AND PARTICIPATED.
I'M I AM AN EXPERT ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND NOT ONLY BECAUSE I
WORK ON THE POLICY SOME OF THOSE
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT TODAY
THAT BECAUSE I'VE EXPERIENCED
DOMESTIC.
ABUSING MY HOME I'M GROWING UP
AS A CHILD.
MY FATHER A SUFFERED GREATLY
WITH MENTAL HEALTH A DISORDER OF
POST STRESS DISORDER THAT HE
OBTAINED WHILE HE WAS A SOLDIER
IN VIETNAM.
AND HE DIDN'T RECEIVE AT ANY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT THE
TIME.
THESE WEREN'T WIDELY AVAILABLE
FOR VICTIMS OF POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER FAMILIES --
WERE TOLD THAT IT DIDN'T EXIST
AND AND HE WAS SPIT ON BY PEOPLE
IN HIS COMMUNITY AND AND MY
BROTHER FAMILY --
SO HE AND HE SUFFERED GREATLY
FROM THAT I DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
IF HE WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN
ABUSIVE HAD YOU NOT HAD PTSD
BECAUSE I NEVER KNEW HIM WITHOUT
PTSD.
DID ABUSE THAT WE HAD IN OUR
FAMILY -- IT
WAS VERY CYCLICAL EVERY WEEKEND
THERE WAS SELF MEDICATION ABUSE
AND VIOLENCE GUN VIOLENCE --
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE MONETARY ABUSE
UPON [inaudible]
AND CONTROL.
AND FOR US AS CHILDREN WHAT IT
MEANT IS THAT WE HAD A LOT ON
THE WEEKENDS WE HEAD IN THE
BATHTUB WHEN THE GUN WAS OUT.
WE HAD A VERY BADLY HIDDEN R.
TOY BOXES --
AND ONCE AFTER MY MOTHER WENT TO
THE HOSPITAL --
FOUND FROM A BRADLEY --
HORRIBLE WEEKEND WE WE ESCAPED.
I WE WENT AWAY FOR A WHOLE A
WEEK.
ON MY SYSTEM MYSELF AND MY MOM.
CAN WE LIVE IN THIS TOWN IN LODI
WE WENT TO A MOBILE HOME PARK IN
LODI.
AND I REMEMBER IT REALLY FUNNY
BECAUSE IT WAS A WEEK OF OF JOY
ELATION [inaudible]
PLAY FUN ON AND A WE DIDN'T
WORRY ABOUT THINGS.
IT WAS SUMMER WE HAD WATER
BALLOON FIGHTS AT THE OTHER KIDS
[inaudible]
AND THE WAS A GOAT WHO LIVED IN
A MOBILE HOME PARK AND HE WOULD
COME INTO OUR HOME.
AND LIKE CASES AROUND THE HOME
IN THE MOBILE HOME.
IT WAS A REALLY GREAT MEMORY.
A LOSS OF I REMEMBER NOT BEING
AFRAID.
WHEN THE WEEK WAS OVER WE WENT
BACK?
AND MY SISTER AND I STOOD SAT IN
THAT.
IN THE END.
IN THE STATION WAGON.
AND WE WOULDN'T LEAVE.
AND IT GOT DARK AND WILL CRY
[inaudible]
AND FINALLY MY DAD CAME OUT.
AND PULL THE SAID.
AND FROM THAT MOMENT ON I MEAN
WE NEVER REALLY HAD A CLOSE
TRUSTING RELATIONSHIP WITH MY
FATHER OBVIOUSLY.
ON BUT WE ALSO DIDN'T HAVE A
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH MY
MOTHER.
BECAUSE WE WERE ANGRY AT HER FOR
BRINGING US BACK.
I WOULDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY SHE
WOULD DO THAT.
MY SISTER ESPECIALLY.
AND FROM THERE THINGS DIDN'T GET
BETTER.
EVERY TIME THAT MY MOTHER WOULD
COME TO THE POINT OF WANTING TO
LEAVE MY FATHER WOULD SAY
REMEMBER WHEN YOU LEFT.
AND YOU CAME BACK.
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T MAKE IT ON
YOUR OWN.
WHEN I GOT OLDER I ASKED MY MOM
WHY DID YOU GO BACK?
BECAUSE WE ASKED ALL THE TIME TO
LEAD.
AND SHE SAID WE HAD NO MONEY.
WE RAN OUT OF MONEY.
MY FATHER CONTINUED TO TOOK
CONTROL IN OUR LIVES
ECONOMICALLY AS WELL.
AND THE WAY HE DID THAT WAS HE
PREVENTED MY MOTHER FROM GETTING
[inaudible]
CHILD CARE.
SHE WASN'T ABLE TO GET CHILD
CARE.
THAN HER GOING TO TO WORK ON
WHERE SHE WORKED AT CHEVRON.
IN THE MAIL ROOM.
WOULDN'T BE ENOUGH TO PAY.
FOR THE COST OF CHILDCARE SO HE
REFUSED THE TO PROVIDE ANY
PORTION OF THE AMOUNT OF CHILD
CARE.
AND SHE COULDN'T AFFORD TO KEEP
US IN CHILD CARE.
I'M EACH TIME SHE WOULD TRY TO
GET A JOB IN ENOUGH MONEY TO
ESCAPE [inaudible]
ON YOU NOTE SHE'D HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ALSO KEEP US IN CHILD
CARE.
I WOULDN'T WHEN SCHOOL WASN'T
THERE [inaudible]
ON AND AS A RESULT WE FOR THE
MOST PART DIDN'T HAVE CHILD
CARE.
WE WERE IN THE LEFT AT PEOPLE'S
HOUSES.
OR WE WERE AND AND LOCKED DOWN
IN OUR OWN HOUSE.
AND ADMIT WE HAD INJURIES THAT
WE DIDN'T REPORT.
AND BECAUSE WE'RE AFRAID THAT IT
WOULD COST MONEY TO GO THE
DOCTORS [inaudible]
ON WE FOUND WE WERE HURT AND AND
AT ABUSED BY THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
SUPPOSED TO TAKE CARE OF US.
I'M AND THESE ALL HAPPENED
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE CHILD
CARE MY MOM MOM TRIED.
TO HER HER WAY OUT OF THIS.
SO AND THE THINGS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY WITH THE TESTIMONY AND
PEOPLE HELPING AND PEOPLE AND
I'M SUPPORTING.
THOSE A SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE TO ESCAPE POVERTY --
ARE ALL THINGS THAT FOR ME
PERSONALLY RING TRUE.
PROFESSIONALLY I SERVICE THE
SERVICE CENTER FOR THAT CAL
FRESH AND CAL WORKS SUPPORT
CENTER FOR LEGAL SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO THEY ALSO RING TRUE
PROFESSIONAL.
A LOT OF THE THINGS WE THINK WE
HEAR FROM STORIES COMING THROUGH
--
TWO TO LEGAL SERVICES
[inaudible]
AND AND WHAT I WANNA SAY ABOUT
THIS IS THAT WE KNOW FROM THOSE
STORIES.
THAT POLICY WORKS TO INTERCEPT
DOMESTIC ABUSE M. AT AT THE
INTERSECTION OF POVERTY.
I'M AND I'M GONNA YOU HEARD SOME
SOME OF THOSE MENTIONED TODAY
HER DEPUTY DIRECTOR BLAND TALK
ABOUT THAT CAO WORKS PROGRAM AND
SOME OF THE CHANGES WE'VE
RECENTLY MADE AN ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE AT SEVEN BUT THE AUTHORED
BY YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER UBIO.
AND AT THIS IS NOT THESE PIECES
OF FIVE I SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE BY SEVEN ARE NOT YET IN
PLACE UP BUT THEY WILL BE SOON
AND WE EXPECT THEM TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
I YOU ALSO HEARD ABOUT COW
FRESHEN HOW WE NOW ALLOW
FAMILIES TO APPLY AS A SEPARATE
HOUSEHOLD FOR CAO FRESH.
AND UP TO APPLY FOR A DIFFERENT
EBT CARD ELECTRONIC BENEFIT
TRANSFER CARD --
SO THEY'RE NOT ASKING FOR FOR
REPLACEMENT BENEFITS ON THE SAME
CARD THAT THE PERSON WHO ABUSED
THEM HAS ACCESS.
TO AND THIS IS A NEW POLICY AS
WELL AND ONE THAT AYE WE ARE
UNIQUELY DOING IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK OTHER STATES CAN BENEFIT
FROM.
WE'VE ALSO A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
THAT PUT THESE TWO TOGETHER BUT
FOR US AT LEGAL SERVICES THEY
WERE VERY MUCH CONNECTED WE
REPEALED THE FAMILY CAP.
THE MAXIMUM FAMILY GRANT PROGRAM
UP IN THE NEXT MONTH AND THE
GRANT OF RULE IN OUR CAL ARTS
PROGRAM WE HAD A A RULE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DENIED AID TO A
CHILD WHO WAS BORN.
INTO A CAL WORKS HOUSEHOLD AND
AN A COUNTLESS NUMBER OF OF
PARENTS OF MOTHERS AT WORK WERE
DENIED AID FOR CHILDREN THAT
THEY CONCEIVED AS A RESULT OF
ABUSE.
A BUT WE WE DIDN'T HEAR A LOT
ABOUT IT TODAY ON THE PANEL BUT
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IS ALSO A
FORM OF ABUSE THAT MANY A WOMEN
EXPERIENCE.
AND WHERE THEY ARE DENIED A AS
YOU NOTE SERVICES EITHER
ABORTION SERVICES OR AND A
PREGNANCY PREVENTION SERVICES.
AND WE ALSO HAD A YOU KNOW
SPOUSES THAT WERE RAPED BY THEIR
SPOUSE OR RAPES BY AT AND A
PERSON WHO LIVE WITH THEM.
AND I IF THEY WERE RAPED THE
CHILD IF THE IF THE CHILD WAS
CONCEIVED AS RAPE IN THE PRIOR
RULE THAT THAT FAMILY COULD GET
AID FOR THE CHILD.
BUT IF THEY WERE A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
THEY COULD NOT.
AND SO THAT LINE WAS A WITH BILL
IS NOT THAT IT WAS A VERY THIN
LINE AND AND OFTENTIMES PEOPLE
WOULD.
NOT RECEIVE AID.
A FOR A CHILD THAT THEY AT
CONCEIVED THROUGH ABUSE.
THAT RULE HAS BEEN REPEALED AND
IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
OTHER THINGS MAKING A DIFFERENCE
THAT WE AT THE HAVE RECENTLY
BEEN PASSED I'M EXCITED ABOUT A
THE GRAND INCREASES I THINK WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THE INCREASE IN THE DATA FROM
SIXTY FIVE TO EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR THE TEMPORARY
SHELTER IS GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HOME VISITING THE
JUST PETS HOPEFULLY WILL BE
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
BUDGET --
SOON CREATING A NEW PROGRAM SO
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WHEN THEY
HAVE WHEN THEY'RE PREGNANT AND
AND HAVE A SMALL CHILD.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS
BUT AND DOMESTIC ABUSE IS OFTEN
ONSET AT THE MOMENT OF
PREGNANCY.
IT'S IT'S ONE OF THE ENTRY
PLACES FOR ABUSE AND SO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NOW HAVE
SOCIAL WORKERS AVAILABLE TO LOW
INCOME PARENTS --
WHO ARE PREGNANT --
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
PREGNANT.
THAT WILL AND WE HOPE THAT CAN
BE A PLACE ANON RAMP FOR
DOMESTIC ABUSE SERVICES AT A
MOMENT WHERE WE SEE AN UPTICK
AND DOMESTIC ABUSE.
AND PEOPLE DON'T THINK ABOUT IT
THIS WAY BUT WE DO BECAUSE WE
SEE CLIENTS SSI CASH OUT.
AS I CASH SO A ENDING THE BAN
FOR CALPERS FOR PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE CAP AT CAT SSI WILL HELP
THEM SECURE AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELDERLY OR DISABLED.
AND LIVE ALONE THEY'LL NOW BE
ABLE TO GET AT CAL FRESH WHEN
THEY HAVEN'T BEFORE MAKING THEM
MORE AND INDEPENDENT AND MORE.
LIKELY A TO BE ABLE TO LEAVE.
ON A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE RELY ON
SSI BECAUSE THEIR WAGES HAVE
BEEN SUPPRESSED THROUGHOUT THEIR
EARNINGS THEIR YEARS OF EARNINGS
AND SO VICTIMS OF THE DEMANDS OF
OF ABUSE SURVIVORS OF ABUSE.
AND OF HAVING LOWER EARNINGS
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFETIME MORE
LIKELY TO RELY ON SSI WHEN THEY
GET OLDER SO THAT A THAT THE
CHANGE IN POLICY PREDICT. FOR
OLDER.
VICTIMS OF ABUSE AND SURVIVORS
OF ABUSE.
WHAT CAN WE DO MOVING FORWARD?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR AND I KNOW THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS EARLY ON IN
THE IN THE LEGISLATIVE YEAR WITH
YOUR BILL LAST YEAR.
IS WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
EXEMPTIONS FROM WELFARE TO WORK.
BEYOND JUST WHEN THE PERSON.
IS UNABLE TO WORK DUE TO A
DIRECT LINK TO THE DOMESTIC
ABUSE.
AND WHEN SOMEBODY APPLIES TO
HAVE A WAIVER FROM THE WELFARE
TO WORK RULE IN CALIFORNIA THEY
HAVE TO SHOW THAT SOMEHOW THERE
DID THEIR ABUSE IS DIRECTLY
LINKED. TO THEIR INABILITY TO
WORK -- BUT
SOMETIMES A CONNECTION IS NOT AS
CLEAR FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO STILL HAVE TO LIVE IN THE
SAME NEIGHBORHOODS AS A PERSON
WHO HAS ABUSE THEM.
AND LEAVING BACK AND FORTH TO
WORK HAVING A* A AND A VERY
VISIBLE PATTERN OF TRAVEL
TRANSPORT FROM YOU KNOW IN
PUBLIC TRANSIT FROM FROM THEIR
HOME TO THEIR WORK PUTS THEM IN
DANGER.
ALSO IM WHEN YOU ARE SURVIVING
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
YOU ARE IN A A A PLACE MENTALLY
WITH THE OR AND MENTAL HEALTH
RECOVERY AND WITH YOUR SPIRITUAL
RECOVERY SOMETIMES OF THE
PHYSICAL RECOVERY WHERE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN YOUR
INABILITY TO WORK.
ON AND THE ABUSE IS SOMETIMES
NOT AVAILABLE AND VISIBLE TO
OTHERS SOMETIMES YOU'RE STILL.
COTTON CONNECTING THE DOTS
YOURSELF.
ON AND SO BEING FORCED TO
EXPLAIN SOMETHING YOU'RE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IN ORDER TO
HAVE THE SPACE AS YOU SAY IF I
REMEMBER COOLEY --
TO GET THROUGH THE ABUSE AND
SURVIVED THE ABUSE AND I THINK
IS REALLY UNFAIR.
AND AN AND THE OTHER PIECE OF
THAT IS THAT WE WE ALSO.
WHEN SOMEBODY DOES FINALLY
DISCLOSE A THAT MAYBE THEY THEY
ARE IN A TRUSTING RELATIONSHIP
NOW WITH THEIR WORKER AND
THEY'RE DISCLOSING THE DOMESTIC
ABUSE -- AT
THE END AND THEY DISCLOSE THAT
HAPPENED PRIOR [inaudible]
AND THEY AND THEIR NOT ABLE TO
GO BACK AND RECAPTURE THOSE
THOSE YEARS AND MONTHS OF
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES AND MAKE THE MOST
OF THEM WE'VE ASKED FOR SOME ON
TAKE THE ABILITY TO AND TAKE
SOME OF THOSE.
MONTHS AND THAT YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN COMPLYING WITH THE WELFARE
TO WORK REQUIREMENT BY DOING
WORK FARE.
ON BUT YOU'RE JUST GETTING BY
YOU'RE TRYING TO SURVIVE AND BE
AND SURVIVING IS NOT THE SAME AS
DRIVING IT'S NOT AN OPPORTUNITY
OF WORK.
AND SO WE WOULD LIKE PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO RESET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK AND GO BACK SET
RETROACTIVE AND TAKING AND AND
AND THAT KIND OF LOOSER
CONNECTION ON THE WELFARE TO
WORK WAIVER FOR THAT SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC ABUSE.
I ALREADY TALKED ABOUT CHILD
CARE IT'S IN A CENTURY YOU
MENTIONED --
BEING ABLE TO HAVE A CHILD CARE
AFTER YOU LEAVE BUT BEFORE.
YOU LEAVE YOU NEED TO IN ORDER
TAKE TO EARN YOUR WAY OUT OF A
SITUATION WHERE YOU WON'T BE
HOMELESS.
AND AND AND AND CRIMINALIZE
BECAUSE OF YOUR HOMELESSNESS BY
THE WAY --
CRIMINALIZE BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN
THE CAR THAT YOU HAVE THANKFULLY
AND THAT YOU HAVEN'T GIVEN UP
YET.
A BECAUSE OF THE COWARDS ASSET
RULE [inaudible]
ON IT IN ORDER TO SAVE THAT
MONEY YOU NEED CHILDCARE IN
ADVANCE SO JUST.
FUNDING CHILD CARE ACROSS THE
BOARD WE NEED TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO THAT.
INCREASING GRANTS AS WELL AND
CAL WORKS OF CAO WORKS AND CAL
FRESH COULD HELP FAMILIES GET TO
A PLACE ABOVE THE POVERTY AND
AND INTO --
AND THEY WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO
BE ABLE TO LEAVE.
ON FOOD HELP YOU KNOW A IT AS
YOU HEARD SOME OF THE THE
SURVIVORS OF ABUSE ARE --
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND THEIR
SPIRIT HAS BEEN CHALLENGED.
NOT GOING HUNGRY AND ME OF SOME
OF OUR ERA PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
THIS HUNGER STRIKE FOR THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN ARE HERE RIGHT
NOW BUT BEING HUNGRY.
NOT ONLY MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
YOU TO FOCUS ON FINDING A JOB
AND FINDING HOUSES AND TAKING
CARE OF YOUR KIDS AND SURVIVING
YOUR ABUSE.
BUT IT ALSO MAKES IT DIFFICULT.
TO BE EMOTIONALLY WELL.
AND ON THAT NOTE THEY'LL SAY FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE THE OF MORE
PEOPLE ARE LIKELY TO COMMIT
SUICIDE WHEN THEY'RE HUNGRY.
I'M SO WE CAN JUST KEEP FOOD M.
ON THE IT IN THE FRIDGE OF FOOD
IN THEIR COOLERS AS THEY'RE
LEAVING A THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
[inaudible]
WE ON WE WE TALKED ABOUT YOU
HEARD ABOUT WORKER RIGHTS AND
WORKER RIGHTS BEING ESSENTIAL
BEING ABLE TO EXPAND PAID SICK
DAYS FROM THREE DAYS TO SEVEN
DAYS FOR EXAMPLE WOULD MAKE A
BIG IMPACT ON HELPING PEOPLE TO
LEAVE -- AT
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
YOU HEARD ABOUT THE OVERPAYMENT
SITUATION WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CHANGE OUR
OVERPAYMENT ROLE LAW FOR CAL
WORKS THIS IS NOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE A DOMESTIC
ABUSE SURVIVOR AND HAVE AN
OVERPAYMENT THAT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE.
OVERPAYMENT WE COULD ACCOMMODATE
THOSE OTHER SITUATIONS ARE NOT
FORCE PEOPLE TO PAY UP BACK
MONEY THAT THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG TO RECEIVE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES CAN
BE COMPLICATED BECAUSE YOU ARE
TRYING TO PARSE OUT THE WORKERS
TO TRY TO PARSE OUT IS THIS YOUR
ASSET OR YOUR ASSET --
THAT EXISTS A IT THE INCOME THAT
YOU HAVE DOES BELONG TO YOUR EX
HUSBAND OR IS IT YOURS --
AND SO HAT AT HOT HELPING THE
THE WORKERS BE RELIEVED OF THE
BURDEN THAT IF THEY DO AN
OVERPAYMENT THIS PERSON WOULD
HAVE TO PAY IT BACK I THINK
WOULD BE.
A VERY HELPFUL POLICY CHANGE.
YOU HEARD ABOUT CONVICTIONS AT
HOW YOU HEARD ABOUT AND SORRY
AND THE VIXEN'S I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
CONVICTION EXPUNGEMENT. FOR THIS
POPULATION TOO MANY OF THE THE A
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
A SURVIVORS THAT WE SEE ALSO
HAVE A CONVICTION THEMSELVES
WHEN THEY CALLED THE POLICE THE
POLICE --
GIVE A CITATION TO A THE ABUSER
AND THEY GIVE A CITATION TO THE
PERSON WHO CALLED.
AND IF THEY HIT BACK IF THEY
PUSH THEM AWAY AND SO AND THEY
END UP WITH.
PERHAPS NOT A CONVICTION BUT AN
ARREST AND ARREST STAYS ON THEIR
RECORDS CAN KEEP THEM OUT OF
OTHER HOUSING UP UNTIL RECENTLY
IT'S BEEN ABLE TO GET WELL IN IT
CAN STILL KEEP YOU FROM.
A JOB OF THE BAND THE BOX IS
HELPING A LOT WITH THAT AND TO
KEEP PEOPLE FROM BEING
DISCOURAGED FROM APPLYING FOR
WORK BECAUSE OF A CONVICTION BUT
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE SURVIVORS WITH CONVICTED
WITH --
ARRESTS AND A FEW WITH
CONVICTIONS YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
DOCUMENT AYE DEKE AT ASSISTANCE
CONSUMER CLEAN UP I THINK WE
HAVE GREAT MODELS FOR THE FOSTER
CARE AND FORMER FOSTER CARE THAT
WE CAN MIGRATE.
TO A COW WORKS TO SUPPORT A
DOMESTIC ABUSE AND AND THE
BROADER POPULATION.
M. AND THEN I'M YOU KNOW FINALLY
I THINK THAT THERE.
IS A LOT TO DO AND HERE IN LEGAL
AID -- LEGAL
AID IS STILL A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN GO TO GET HELP.
AND WE ARE FACING A TAX AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AS MANY THINGS ARE
--
AND THIS THIS INSTITUTION HAS
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF LEGAL
SERVICES ESPECIALLY FOR MIGRANTS
AMONG WEEK WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND TO THINK ABOUT OTHER
WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN SUPPORT
THESE KIND THE COLLABORATIVE'S
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WERE LEGAL
SERVICES IS A BIG PART OF THAT
--
AND AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
LEGAL SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE AND
A VERY UP BROADWAY.
I'M SO WITH THAT I WILL GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE AND I'M REMAIN FOR
NICK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE OR
COMMENTS.
THEY WERE WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
I JUST WANNA GO --
THE SAY THAT --
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE EXPERTISE
ESPECIALLY AYE AYE IN THE ALSO
LONG.
SENDS HER REGARDS AND SAID I
THAT CHRIS FORD IS --
BEEN AMAZING OF FOUR WE'VE THE
THAT SHE SPENDS MANY MANY HOURS
OF VOLUNTEERING AND I KNOW WHERE
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I KNOW
THAT MANY OF YOU DO AS WELL AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THESE
HEARINGS ONE I THINK BUT
COMMITTEE OUR MEMBERS FOR ALSO
BEING HERE ALOT BUT AGAIN YOU
KNOW I KEEP STRESSING RETURN
WITH ME.
THAT THIS IS MUCH MORE THAN A
CONVERSATION CHANGES TO COME OUT
OF THIS AND SO I THOUGHT LOOKING
FORWARD TO SOME IDEAS ON ON THAT
I KNOW YOU STATED BY BOB MORE
POLICY CHANGES FOR FOR ME IN
PARTICULAR AND I THINK SO FOR
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS --
WILL FOR THE FOLLOWING
LEGISLATIVE YEAR I AM I GOING TO
WORK VERY HARD TO BE HERE FOR
THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AND SO SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE THAT TURNED OUT TERM
LIMITING JUST BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THAT IS GOING TO HELP US.
REALLY MAKE SOME DIFFERENCES IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF OF
THOSE CHANGES SO WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN THANK
EVERYONE --
UP FOR BEING HERE AND I WITHOUT
IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AS
WELL PLEASE I COME UP AND SHARE
YOUR THOUGHTS AND AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN WE DO OUR CHANGES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I I DON'T TODAY.
MY NAME IS SIERRA HARRIS IM
CLIENT THE A COMMUNITY FOR PEACE
WHICH IS THE FIFTH OF WE'VE.
ARM WANTED A COLLABORATORS --
START BY SAYING.
IBM ORIGINALLY FROM SAINT LOUIS
MISSOURI.
SPEAKING TO YOU ESPECIALLY THIS
IS A DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE FOR ME ARM.
BUT NEEDED DRESS HOW I CAN
ACTUALLY.
HOW WE AS A TEAM COULD MAKE
APPROVED MEN'S ON ON THE
PARTNERSHIP OF DOMESTIC
BALANCING AND?
THE H. I I WILL ACTUALLY HAVE TO
GO BACK.
TO MY EXPERIENCED AS A CHILD ARM
I WAS BORN WOOD AT A STATE.
DUE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NOMOGRAM I WAS GONNA COSTING ME
AT THE AGE OF ONE AND A HALF.
SO DUE TO THIS ON WAY BEFORE SHE
WAS GRANTED CUSTODY [inaudible]
I WAS [inaudible]
LITERALLY.
FOURTH WITH THE CONCEPT OF A IN
THE MOMENT.
I COULD BE SEPARATED FROM MY
SIBLINGS IN MY FAMILY SO IT WAS
THE AQUATIC FOUND DRIPPED IT
WAS.
FIGHT A FIGHT I WAS NEVER ABLE
TO THINK WHAT MY FOR CAPACITY OF
MY BRAIN DUTIES.
NO LACK OF SECURITY BASICALLY
ALL.
THURSDAY I HAVE ANXIETY --
HEAVY PS [inaudible]
TST.
ARM.
ASA CHILD.
WHEN IT CAME TO MY EDUCATION?
I LITERALLY WAS TESTED SO MANY
TIMES DO TO MY INABILITY TO
SPEAK OUT AND USE MY VOICE.
THAT I WAS ALMOST LOS.
LABOR DAY A BABY HD INPUT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF ME NOT
BEING ABLE TO BRIEF.
BRITAIN IS SO IMPORTANT TO THE
HUMAN -- AS
IN PTSD PREVENTS YOU TO BRIEF
THINKING WITH THE BACK PORTILLO
BRAIN SURVIVAL BOWL.
PREVENTS YOU TO BREED.
THE SOCIETY IS PREVENTING.
NOT JUST WOMEN WITH CHILDREN TO
BRIEF.
YES I AM A WOMAN OF COLOR.
BUT I AM NOT STANDING HERE JUST
FOR BLACK WOMEN TODAY.
I AM STANDING HERE FOR THE YOUTH
OF AMERICA.
WHEN IT COMES TO HER CPS?
B. HA INDO MYSTIC ABOUT.
THIS HAS AFFECTED MY WHOLE
TWENTY NINE YEARS OF LIVING.
DUE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I HAVE BEEN PLACED IN SITUATIONS
AND ENVIRONMENTS THAT NO CHILD
SHOULD HAVE TO INTO.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT MY MOTHER
WAS LABELLED UNSTABLE AS A
MOTHER IT WAS SCRIPT.
APPROACH TO ADJOURN.
SHE SUFFER FROM PTSD.
MY MOM HAS BEEN FIGHTING.
CRACK COCAINE ADDICTION. FOR
OVERTHIRTY TWO YEARS I AM.
TWENTY NINE I WAS BORN.
BUT BIG PICKED [inaudible]
DISPLAYPORT MI PTSD AND EXILE
ID.
I WILL PERSONALLY LIKE THE STATE
THAT I DO NOT LIKE THE TERM
STATISTIC DUCATI'S.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHEN YOU
DEALING WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THIS IS NOT IT IS BIG ENOUGH A
FATTY EACH CASE.
HAS A DIFFERENT OUTCOME.
EACH CASE YOU DEAL WITH A
DIFFERENT INDIVIDUAL WHAT A
DIFFERENCE AS HOUSEHOLDS
SUFFERING WITH DIFFERENT MENTAL
ISSUES.
AND DIFFERENT POEMS YOU WERE
HALF THE HANDLE THEM DIFFERENTLY
YOU CANNOT GOING EACH CASE.
THINKING THAT IS ALL COULD BE
HANDLED THE SAME WAY.
BUT MY EDUCATION SO MUCH OUT
EDUCATION TO MARK MY TOWN TO
HAVE A CHECK.
IT IT'S BEEN TOTALLY IMPACTED
ARM.
FAST FORWARD --
DUE TO MY HOUSING SITUATION.
AND LIMIT THIS SOURCES MY
GRANDMA TOOK ON ALL FOR MOM WITH
THE KIDS DUE TO HER NOT WANTING
US TO BE SEPARATED SHE TOOK ON
MY MOTHER RESPONSIBILITY
[inaudible]
ARM IT BECAME VERY OR SHE TOOK
UPON ITS MANY ODD JOBS AS
POSSIBLE STILL TRYING TO MEET
CPS MANDATED REPORTS
[inaudible]
ARM.
IT LANDED US IN A LOT OF
MULTIPLE HOMES WITH A LOTTA.
MORE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SELF
MEDICATION SEXUAL ABUSE NOT
JUST.
THROUGH THE FEMALES BUT SAMAD
MALE SIBLINGS WHICH IS.
A TABOO IN AMERICA.
WHICH IS JUST NOW BECOMING A FED
--
SEXUALITY AND MY HOUSEHOLD TO
THUMP DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WAS IT SPOKEO.
THAT MADE US EVEN MORE BONTA
BROUGH NOT ONLY THAT WE OR CPS
KEEPS WE WERE CPS CASE THEREFORE
WE LAX SECURITY SO.
EVEN IF SOMEONE WAS TO MODESTO
BUT THE FACT TO LET THE MATTER
WITH US.
NOBODY'S THERE TO PROTECT YOU.
SOLD TO THE E. BIDDING
[inaudible]
SPEAK GONE.
DILLON BAND OPEN FILE THE SILLY
JUVENILE COURT SYSTEM CPS.
JUST MAKE IT EVEN HARDER FOR YOU
TO WALK AND SEWER.
BE HIV OFFICE IN A MEAT THAT YOU
NEED HELP TO TO YOU BECOMING AT
OPEN FALLIBLE PLUG.
SO THIS IS WHY ADVOCACY IS VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
DOMESTIC VALLEY.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
[inaudible]
ISSUES WITH KING UP.
IN ASKING FOR HELP IS NOT THAT
THEY DON'T WON'T HELP THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO EXPLAIN HELP.
ONCE I BECAME A CERTAIN AGE IN.
THE DOMESTIC.
BECAME.
BETWEEN THE COURT SYSTEMS ALL OF
MY SIBLINGS OR RUNNING AWAY FROM
HOME NOW THEY'RE SEXUALLY ACTIVE
YOU UNDERSTAND THERE IT IS IT'S
A MONEY PROBLEM --
WE FOUND OUT GRANDMA'S GET A
CHECK PLUS.
SHE'S WORKING AS LIKE A SLAVE TO
MAKE THE AINSLEY FOR CPS SOARED
NONSENSE MAKE ENDS MEET.
BUT WE'RE NOT SEEING ANY OF IT
SO I'M GOING TO RUN AWAY FROM
HOME THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE.
SO MANY CHILDREN.
AT THE AGE OF FIFTEEN RUNNING
AWAY FROM HOME BECAUSE THEY
PARENTS OR SUFFERING
[inaudible]
FINANCIALLY.
AND SECULAR BICU SAT ON THE
CHILDREN.
IN THEIR GAMES SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED WHEN THEY WENT AWAY
FROM HOME.
AT THE AGE OF FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
MY GRANDMA FORECLOSED ON HER
PROPERTY.
IT WAS A FAVORITISM SITUATION
AND HOUSEHOLD MUSCLES THE WAS
RECEIVING SSI SHE WAS RECEIVING
MORE FUNDS.
SHE HAD A VOICE TO TODAY'S.
THESE ARE YOUR FOLLOWS THE THESE
ARE BEING USED ON A BE ALSO YOU
NEED TO KNOW YOUR MONEY GOING.
YOU ON THE OTHER HAND YOU ONLY
SEE FULL STEPS [inaudible]
SHUT UP [inaudible]
ONCE AGAIN.
ITS FINANCIAL ABUSE SO WITH THAT
BEING SAID WHEN HE CAME TO
FORECLOSE ON THE PROPERTY.
ALL I GET IS A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS AND GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE ON FIFTEEN YEARS OLD.
YOU BETTER MAKE IT LAST.
THIS IS NO LONGER HOME ACT TODAY
WE DISPEL ALL DIS DOUBLENEST.
SO I'M FIFTEEN YEARS OLD. SIX
WEEKS BODY MYSELF BECAUSE THIS
IS ALL THAT I KNOW.
AND I'M TOO YOUNG TO GO APPLY
FOR GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE ON MY
OWN IN THIS IS HOW MY FAMILY.
FIT ME.
THIS IS OUR WAS ACCEPTED BY
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS IN A
HOUSEHOLD.
SO IF I DON'T HAVE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE.
WHAT DO I HAD TO RELY ON AND I'M
NOT ABLE TO WORK IT AS A
CITIZEN?
IT MADE ATTENDING SCHOOL VERY
LOWER.
ARMY WAS I WASN'T EVEN THE A
GREAT.
WELL WAS IT A GREAT WITH THE
OPTION OF ME GRADUATING A GREAT
IN BECOMING THE A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT [inaudible]
AND BEEN A PART OF THE SEX TRADE
IN THIS. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN I
JUST LOST MY VIRGINITY.
SO IF YOU WANNA SPEAK ON ONLY
STE TERMS YOU HAVE TO SPEAK ON
THE TERMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HUMAN RIGHTS.
PRIMACY SEXUAL EXPLOITATION AND
IMMIGRATION.
THESE ARE LONG TERM AFFECTS FOR
MY CANTONA PEOPLE FOR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS SO THIS IS NOTHING
NEW.
SO WE CAN'T SPEAK ON JAZZ
[inaudible]
CERTAIN BASICS.
WE WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
MAIN ROUTE [inaudible]
ARM [inaudible]
I JUST.
GOT FED UP WITH IT.
THEJUSTICE FOREST'S AYE I HAVE
A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION I HAVE
MY GED.
I HAVE GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE.
THE BURDENS THAT I HAVE FACED
SWEET.
D. H. A AND MEGAN CERTAIN
MANDATED REPORTS WHEN IT CAME TO
MY EDUCATION FROM COLLEGE I
LITERALLY.
I FOUND MYSELF.
HOLDING COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALL
BECAUSE OF ONE PLAYER'S BAND
DROPPED OUTSIDE OF MY CONTROL
BECAUSE STUDENTS NOT A RABBIT
BUT DUE TO ME HAVING A MANDATE.
REPORT THAT I AM A PART OF
SOMETHING FOR THIRTY HOURS.
AND I JUST LOS ONE PLAYS.
DROP ME COMPLETELY MY I FEEL
BAY.
STANDARDS IT WAS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I ADMIT THE
OBSTACLE SO MANY TIMES EVERY
TIME THE OPPOSITE OF THE?
OF I DON'T WANNA WORK AT FAST
FOOD ANYMORE.
I WANNA GO BACK TO SCHOOL TO
CONTINUE MY EDUCATION
[inaudible]
YES.
MISTER WHO HAS A QUESTION FOR
YOUR CIRCLE IT.
YOU SAID YOU HAVE AN AFFILIATION
WITH COMMUNITY FOR PEACE ELAINE
WHITE FEATHER HOW DID YOU FIND
HOW'D YOU CONNECT WITH SALMON
OKAY WHAT WHAT'S YOUR IF ALL BET
THAT WOULD BE.
AVAIL YEAR THANK YOU FOR SHARING
--
BACHARACH THANK A PLEA ON THIS
WHICH YOU FAST FORWARD BOMB.
I WAS BONTA DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SLEEP IN MY CORRUGATA POINTS
WHILE SLEEPING AMARCORD THE SHIP
SHELTER.
THE DOC CAME ACROSS IN SAINT
LOUIS -- I'M
A BIG FAN A TWO ONE I GOTTA GIVE
SET OUT TO TWO ONE ONE ON UNITED
WAY.
THEY REFERRED ME --
TO PLACE OPERATES WAY BREACH
WAY.
HELP ME GET BLOW.
PROTECTIVE LOTS WERE MY ABUSER
CAN FIND OUT MY WHEREABOUTS.
BUT I WAS STILL HAVING TO FACE
MANDATED REPORTS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE HE WORKS I WAS.
SO MANY MILES AWAY.
BUT I HAVE TO GO BACK INTO THE
CITY.
YES THE MEAT B. H. A MANDATED
REPORTS IN THE STATE OF MISSOURI
[inaudible]
NOW ON I JUST I'D THE SHELTER
WAS THAT WE MONEY THAT WAS MORE
SO OF WE HAVE DEGREES IN IS IT
NOT PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IN
[inaudible]
BOMB.
DOES BEING COMPLETELY HONEST AND
I JUST PACKED UP EVERYTHING IN
THE SHELTER ARDUOUS ALMOST
LOSING SLEEP SLEEP IN AMARCORD
UNDERSTATED HIM.
IF MY INCOME TAXES COME THROUGH
BECAUSE I KNOW DAMN WELL I CAN
GET NOW PLAN TO TRYING TO GET
OUT THE EXCITEMENT BEING
COMPLETELY HONEST.
JUST BY THE GRACE OF GOD MOUNT
MY INCOME TAX CAN'T DO OUT.
BOOK THE TRYING.
SEIFERT TRAIL ON MY HAT THREE
DAYS. THREE DAYS THE COME OUT
WITH WHAT IT WAS MY I WAS HAD
CLOSE ARE WAS DOING EVERYTHING
SINCE THE CAN YOU CAN YOU CALM.
MARK MCCORMACK GREED OUT MIDDLE
EAST STEP UP NIGHTS THINKING
IMIA EXPAT POINT THIS IS NOT NO
DAMN EASY TAX.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU WHAT DIRECT
TAP OUT THEIR SLEEPING OR
WATCHING IN ANYBODY CAN BE FSU
ANYTIME MITCHELL BIGGEST
VERBATIM A CASE.
THAT WAS MY BIGGEST [inaudible]
FOR ON ALL I HAD BEEN COMPLETELY
HONEST WHICH OUGHT TO HAVE WAS
MUFFLED STEPS IN MY GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE.
IN THE STATE OF MISSOURI I WAS
ONLY GIVEN [inaudible] TO NINETY
SEVEN TEN OF AND WHAT. THREE
SIXTY FIVE BOZEMAN'S
[inaudible]
SO.
WHEN I GOT TO CALIFORNIA I HAD
THE WHOLE THREE DAYS ON THE
TRAIN SOON?
THIS BOARD KNOWS HOUSING AS
BEING FEE.
WHEN I GOT OFF THAT CHINA
SACRAMENTO?
JUST PUT AN INSULT.
THE AMTRAK STATION THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHAT UNDER TRYING THE
INSIDE THE CITY LIKE I'VE GOT
THE PANIC AND LIKE.
I USE MY RESOURCES WHICH WAS.
TWO ONE ONE THEY GAVE ME EVERY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE [inaudible]
LIST [inaudible]
IN THIS [inaudible]
REGION [inaudible]
FROM.
IF I WERE OUT SIT ATOP SABRINA
LIST TODAY.
IT WOULD SHOW WHO OF YOU BROUGHT
YOURSELF IF YOU ME CHECK IT OFF
LITERALLY.
SECOND OFF OKAY.
WE MAG DOT.
I LEFT ST LOUIS THURSDAY MARCH
TRAIN PULLED UP AMTRAK IT THAT
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO SATURDAY
MORNING -- I
CALLED.
I AM NOT MISTAKEN BY THE JOHNS
ARE CALLED SAVE OUR CALL WE ARE
CALLED [inaudible]
EVERYBODY.
THE BIGGEST DIFFICULTY IN THIS
APPOINT DISCOURAGEMENT ARE HUNG
MY HEAD SO WELL YESTERDAY.
ORIENTATION A TWO WEEKS THEY WE
DON'T TAKE PEOPLE WHEN THE
WEEKENDS.
I AM CRYING OUT FOR HELP.
I DON'T I DON'T HAVE MONEY FOR
HOLD GOVERNMENT.
NOT ONLY THAT THEY'RE TELLING ME
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT IT TAKE
FOR ME TO EVEN GET ACCEPTED IN A
SHELTER OUT THAT I'D BE.
ALL GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE IN THE
STATE THAT I'M BRINGING NO.
I DON'T.
WHAT DO YOU I DON'T EVEN KNOW
THE ROPES ON CREE LIKE LITTLE
LEAGUE [inaudible]
SO.
KNOWING THAT I'M BANNED IN THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE WHICH IS CAL WORKS
CAO FRESH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE ACCEPTED AT THE
SHELTERS.
I AM FORCED TO GO BACK AND FIGHT
AND FIGHT MOPE.
SURVIVAL MORE WHAT IS MY
SURVIVAL MODE.
FIRST THING COME TO MY MIND I
GOT ATTORNEY TRICK.
WHAT I FIND SOME DRUGS THE FIELD
IN?
STUFF THIS LEGAL.
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE THIS IS MY WAY OF
LIVING BUT AT THE SAME TIME I
THINK I HAD LIKE TWELVE DOLLARS
A MONTH WAS BEEN COURT BY TIME I
GOT UP PICTURING.
I HAD
ONLY ENOUGH A WARM ROOM ONE
NIGHT OF A HOTEL ROOM A COURT.
NOT ENOUGH TO THE POINT TO WORD.
I ENDED UP SOMEWHERE DOWNTOWN
BAG.
NEXT TO A MAC DONALD'S THAT
HIGHWAY.
I WALKED ACROSS THE STREET THEY
DIDN'T TAKE DEBORAH COURTS I HAD
TO WALK ALL THE WAY LIKE JAY
STREET TO THE SO WAITED AT THE
ONLY PLACE I CAN FEED MY BORDER
WITH THE SLOW WAIT.
I KNOW FOR WHOM MY HE ON THE BUS
STOPS OLD LOW I'VE BEEN HER YEAR
[inaudible]
ON THE SAFE HOUSE THE TRANSITION
BETWEEN THE SAFE HOUSE IN
ACTUALLY.
NOT BEING ABLE TO HOLD HIS THING
WAS COMMUNICATING DUE TO BE HIV
FROM THE SAFE HOUSE PO BOX YOU
KNOW HOW HORRIBLE IS GETTING
MAIL OUT A MAILBOX THAT ANGEL
MAILBOX YOU CAN'T JUST.
WALK UP AND GET. TO MAIL OUT YOU
LATE WE DON'T EVEN KNOW YOU GOT
A MANDATED REPORT BECAUSE IN THE
PO BOX IN A CHECK EVERY TWO
THREE DAYS.
OR YOU TALK OF THE DO EMAIL BUT
YOU IN A SAFE HOUSE YOU CAN'T
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS IN A SAFE
HOUSE [inaudible]
IS LIMITED.
SO IF IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
BUT IS STEEL [inaudible]
OTHER THINGS [inaudible] FOR
REQUIRE.
I THINK FIRM BUT THANK YOU FOR
FOR THAT AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHY
WE'RE HAVING THE SCOOBIES CALL
CONVERSATIONS AND I WOULD LOVE
TO OFFER.
ON MY COMMITTEE STAFF TO CONTACT
YOU SO THAT YOU CAN.
HELP US UNDERSTAND BECAUSE TO BE
QUITE FRANK WITH YOU IT DIDN'T
EVEN OCCUR TO ME THAT WHAT
HAPPENS WITH WOMEN THAT COME
FROM OTHER STATES AND AND WHEN
YOU'RE FLEEING.
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO GET AS FAR
AWAY AS POSSIBLE AND AND GETTING
AWAY TO ANOTHER STATE IS AN
OPTION BY.
THE ALL THOSE BARRIERS THAT ARE
PRESENTED WHEN YOU GET HERE AND
SO I WOULD BE LOVE FOR MY
COMMITTEE STAFF TO REALLY TALK
TO YOU ABOUT.
WHAT OTHER ISSUES THAT WE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
FOLKS HERE BY?
TAKING CARE OF SOMEBODY LIKE YOU
THAT CAME IS ALSO SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY BECAUSE AT THE END IF
YOU'RE HERE WITH US.
YOUR YOU BELONG TO US AND YOU'RE
YOU'RE TAUGHT CHILDREN YOUR
CHILD AND IT ALL THE OTHER
CHILDREN ARE GOING TO BE IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM HOPEFULLY AND SO
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH A PLAN
TO HELP --
SITUATIONS LIKE YOURS SOMEONE OF
THANK YOU FOR REALLY --
SHARING THAT WITH YOU BECAUSE WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE THOSE --
IT EXAMPLES THOSE EXAMPLES I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
OKAY IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SETTLING OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
HEARING AND FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS OF COURSE SOME OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE GONE BUT THAT ALL
OF YOU HAVE ASKED TO THE
WITNESSES TODAY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT I THINK IT'S
GIVEN.
EVERYONE A LOT OF GROUNDING IN
REALITY OF WHAT GOES ON FOR SO
MANY WOMEN AND THEIR CHILDREN
AND AND THAT'S BEEN REALLY
APPRECIATED I KNOW IT'S VERY
HARD. FOR THE WITNESSES TO TELL
THOSE STORIES AND SO I WANT TO
THANK THEM AS WELL FOR FOR
SHARING.
JUST A COUPLE THOUGHTS --
ARE THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW WE ENGAGE IN HOW DO WE
TALK TO PEOPLE AND HOW WORKS AND
HOW TO WE INSURER THAT WORD TAKE
IT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
EXPERIENCES.
AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE AND THEN WHAT CAN THEY
ACCOMPLISHED REALISTICALLY I
THINK ON ONE OF THE EXCITING
THINGS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON IS
WHAT WE CALL.
THAT CAO WORK STRATEGIC
INITIATIVE WORK HOURS TO PLANO
WE TALK WITH YOUR STAFF ABOUT IT
AND IT'S REALLY TRYING TO CHANGE
THE WAY WE ENGAGE WITH
RECIPIENTS NOT JUST RECIPIENTS
WERE SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE.
BUT I THINK THAT HAS IT HAS A
LOT OF POTENTIAL FOR THOSE
CONVERSATIONS RATHER THAN JUST
FILLING OUT A FORM AND SAYING
HERE BE HERE ON THURSDAY OR
YOU'RE GONNA GET THANKS AND IT'S
A CONVERSATION.
THAT WE CAN HAVE TO TALK WITH
THEM ABOUT WHERE THEY ARE AND
NOT JUST THEM BUT THEIR CHILDREN
TO AND THE REST OF THEIR FAMILY
SO AGAIN.
GETTING AT THAT SORT OF MULTIPLE
GENERATIONAL IF YOUR KID IS
TRUANT.
AND YOU GOTTA GO DOWN TO DEAL
WITH THAT YOU'RE NOT GONNA MAKE
IT TO WORK IF YOU'RE HOMELESS
DELIVERY YOUR CAR WE CAN SEND
YOU THE JOB CLUB THERE'S OTHER
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY FIRST.
AND REALLY THINKING ABOUT THAT
FIGHT OR FLIGHT AREN'T WE TRYING
TO REALLY DRAW ON UNDERSTANDING
THAT AND HOPING.
TO TOWARD THAT SELF SEE AND A
REALLY REALISTIC WAY AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT SOMETIMES
IT'S JUST WHAT'S THAT NEXT STEP
YOU CAN TAKE WHAT IS LOVE WE
CAUGHT THE ADJACENT POSSIBLE
WHAT'S THAT POSSIBLE NEXT THAT.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THIRTY
HOURS A WEEK IT COULD BE A SMALL
STEP AND THAT'S A POSITIVE AS
WELL.
AREN'T SO THAT'S ONE THING THAT
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT I
WANTED TO SHARE.
ALSO TO DOCTOR ARAMBULA QUESTION
ABOUT EASES FROM EARLIER ON HIS
AB THREE FORTY FROM LAST YEAR
DOES REQUIRE A MAN AS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE YOU HEARD IN THE
COMMITTEE IN A TICKET SIGN.
DIE EPS CT SCREENINGS AND
MEDICARE HOT OF COURSE ALL
CHILDREN ON CAL WORKS SERVE MEDI
CAL ELIGIBLE THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT FOSTER KIDS THIS IS ABOUT
ALL KIDS.
THE SCREENING TOOLS ARE BEING
REVISED TO ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
TRAUMA AND ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND THAT PROCESS IS
UNDER WAY WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE GROUP OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS ON THE GROUP
AS REPORTED THAT IT'S GOING VERY
WELL.
THERE'S DOCTORS THERE'S
PRACTITIONERS AND THEIR OVER THE
MOON TO BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION SO WE THINK THAT
DOES HOLD A LOT OF PROMISE.
AND THEN THINKING THOUGH HOW DO
WE CONNECT THAT TO CAL WORKS HOW
DO WE INCLUDE THAT IN THE
CONVERSATIONS SEEMS REALLY
CRITICAL AND WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE FULFILL THE PROMISE OF THAT
LEGISLATION.
AND NOT JUST THE CHILD WELFARE
PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN KIND OF
THINKING ABOUT IT BUT IN A
BROADER WAY AND THEN FINALLY
JUST A COMMENT ABOUT THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS WHICH IN
RESPONSE TO A QUESTION I THINK
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
WHAT'S THE ONE THING.
ON THAT YOU WOULD DO I THINK
THAT YOLO COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE
I MENTIONED HOUSING IN AND OUT
DIRECTOR BLAND I'M FROM DSS TIME
THEN.
I WANT TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THAT AND PARTICULARLY TO
EVICTION I THINK IT CAME UP AS A
THEME ON A FEW OF THE PANELS
TODAY.
THE WHAT WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT
ADDICTION IN RECENT YEARS
ESPECIALLY FOR THE WORK OF
MATTHEW DESMOND ON WHO WROTE THE
BOOK CALLED EVICTED AND RUNS THE
VIXEN LAB IS THAT.
ARE SURPRISINGLY A VIXEN
ACTUALLY IS ARM.
A PRECURSOR TO LOSING YOUR JOB
LOSING YOUR JOB DOESN'T HAPPEN
GENERALLY AND THEN YOU GET
EVICTED YOU GET ADDICTED AND
THEN YOU HAVE NO PLACE TO LIVE.
AND THEN YOU LOSE YOUR JOB IT
CUT IT SPIRALS DOWN AND THOSE
ADDICTIONS CAN BE LIFE CHANGING
FOR PEOPLE THEY STAY ON A RECORD
THAT MAKE IT HARDER TO GET AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE.
THAT ACTUALLY HAS RUNNING WATER
IN THE SIX THAT WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED AND THE OTHER THING I
WOULD IMAGINE IT'S JUST THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN THE VIXEN
AND DOMESTIC ABUSE.
WELL ON SOME OF THE STORIES THAT
HE TALKS ABOUT HE LIVED IN
MILWAUKEE FOR A YEAR TO AND AND
RESEARCH THAT'S BUT I'M SURE
IT'S APPLICABLE HERE.
IS LANDLORDS DON'T LIKE IT WHEN
YOU CALL THE COPS SO IF YOU HAVE
A VIOLENCE GOING ON IN YOUR
HOMEOWNER CALLING THE COPS FOR
PROTECTION THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
TO PICK YOU.
AND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
PROTECTION AGAINST THAT THE TO
THINK ABOUT POLICIES THAT ARE A
LITTLE OUTSIDE OF THE ROOM THAT
I WORK IN AT C. WTA IT AND
DIRECT HUMAN SERVICES.
THINKING ABOUT KENYA VIC
SOMEBODY THAT QUICKLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEEK
PROTECTION FROM THE POLICE FOR A
DOMESTIC INCIDENT ON JUST FOOD
FOR THOUGHT BECAUSE THE VICTIM
CAN TOUCH OFF ALL OF THESE OTHER
PROBLEMS.
AND REALLY BECAUSE THE SPIRAL
AND THEN THAT TOXIC STUFF THE
POVERTY THAT WE KNOW WHEN
CHILDREN GROW UP AND IT'S JUST
SO TERRIBLE FOR THEM.
ANYWAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS DONNA BROWN AND
I'M FROM A COMMUNITY FOR PEACE
SOME AYE ONE OF THE ASSISTANT
DEPUTY DIRECTORS AND I USED TO
BE ONE OF THE SAFE HOUSE
MANAGERS BUT I'M ALSO A SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OF TWENTY
YEARS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WITH SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BECAUSE WE
TALK ABOUT ALL THESE ISSUES BUT
IF A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAS PTSD.
ANXIETY DISORDERS AND SO ON AND
SO ON AND SO FORTH THAT STEM
FROM THE TRAUMA OF THEIR
VIOLENCE.
I MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH THE SYSTEMS ON
THEIR OWN BUT ALSO MAKES THEM IT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
FILL OUT FORMS AND DO BASIC
THINGS LIKE ON AN APPLICATION
FOR RENTAL PROPERTY.
OR IF THEY'RE BEING ASKED A LOT
OF QUESTIONS THEY MAY GET
OVERWHELMED BY AND FLEE FROM IT
AND NEVER RETURN MAYBE NEVER
TIMELY THINGS IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE ARE WE ARE WE
ADDRESSING YOU KNOW HOW FOLKS
ARE RECEIVING SERVICES SO I HAVE
SOME CLIENTS THAT I'VE DEALT
WITH THAT THEY GO TO KAISER.
AND THEY SAY BECAUSE OUR HOUSE A
REALLY GOOD --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THEY ASKED
ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
THEIR ROLE THOROUGH ABOUT ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS BUT THEN THEY
CAN ONLY GO TO THERAPY FOR SO
LONG.
AND THEN THERE THAT GO FROM THAT
THEY'RE BEING IN THEIR SHOT BACK
OVER HERE AND THEN THERE SHOT
OVER HERE TO GO GET SERVICES
OVER HERE. FOR SOMEBODY WITH
PTSD BECAUSE I KNOW I SUFFER
FROM COMPLEX PTSD AND I KNOW
WHEN I WAS IN THE HEIGHT NO BED
AT ONE POINT IN MY LIFE.
DOING A TO BE WAS LIKE DOING A
TO Z..
AND SO I WILL PROBABLY DO A AND
YOU WILL NEVER SEE ME ABBY.
IWALKED AWAY FROM DE AJ
SERVICES AND ME AND MY KIDS JUST
SUFFER THROUGH IT AND I GOT MY
NEED THE BEST WAY I KNEW HOW.
BECAUSE OF MY PTSD WILL ALLOW ME
TO GO SIT IN OFFICE FOR HOURS
AND HOURS ON END ARE ALL DAY
GOING FROM WINDOW TO WINDOW.
BEING TALKED DOWN TO BENT TALK
AT BEEN ASKED DEMEANING
QUESTIONS.
THAT SOUNDED LIKE MIGHT BE USER.
SO YOU KNOW INSIDE OF THE
SYSTEMS YOU KNOW IT'S ABOUT.
REALLY EVEN ANXIETY. FOUR PEOPLE
WHO ARE RECEIVING SERVICES AND
EVEN WORKING IN THE SHELTER WHEN
I WOULD HELP WOMEN WHO WOULD
COME FROM OTHER COUNTRIES OR
OTHER STATES.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE THEM
THROUGH STAFF.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE IT
AGAIN BEGAN IN THAN THEY'VE
THEY'LL GO AND DON'T TRY TO DO
IT NOW COME BACK AND I'LL SAY A
WHILE.
MISS GHANA.
I GOT THE DOOR SLAMMED IN MY
FACE THEY TOLD ME THAT THIS IS
NOT AVAILABLE BUT I KNOW AS A
ADVOCATE BECAUSE I'VE DONE MY
RESEARCH YET THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO YOU AND THAT IN THAT IS YOUR
RIGHT TO HAVE THAT AS A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR SO ALSO
TRAINING.
MAKING SURE THAT SYSTEMS AND
FOLKS WHO ARE PROBABLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE DOING THE SERVICE ARE
ALSO GIVING A TRUTHFUL
INFORMATION TO THE CLIENTS.
IS IT IN WRITING SO THEY CAN
READ IT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT I TELL
YOU BECAUSE WITH PTSD YOU WON'T
REMEMBER IF YOU HAVE A TV AYE
YOU WON'T REMEMBER IT SO AS I
WALK OUT THE DOOR I'LL FORGET
HAVE WHAT YOU SAID.
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW.
MY QUESTION TODAY IS HOW ARE YA
GONNA ADDRESS.
PUTTING TOGETHER A SYSTEM BACK
ALSO CREATES STABILITY FOR
FOLKS.
THERE IS NO STABILITY ITEM ONE
THE YOUNG LADIES AND I WAS A
LITTLE MOVE EMOTIONALLY MOVED BY
IT BECAUSE SHE IS RIGHT.
IF THEY MAKE ONE DOLLAR OVER A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY THEIR
CUT OFF ON THIS AND SO IT
PROMISE OF OUR GROSS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND I LEAVE MY HOME AND I GO GET
ON ASSISTANCE AND I GET FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY DOLLARS IF I GO
GET A JOB THAT FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS.
I MADE A HUNDRED DOLLARS OVER A
LITTLE OVER A CERTAIN AMOUNT
THEIR STILL DON'T QUALIFY FOR
ANYTHING. FOR WOMEN WHO ARE
MARRIED.
OR YOU VICTIMS WHO ARE MARRIED.
THE MISUSE OF THEIR AND FOR
PERSONAL INFORMATION THERE ARE
NO LAWS OUT THERE THAT PROTECT
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN RELATION OR IN
RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
SO THEY'RE STUCK THEY'RE STUCK
WATCHING THEIR WHOLE LIFE BE
RIPPED DOWN [inaudible]
THEIR NAME [inaudible]
THEIR CREDIT.
THERE FINANCES THEIR BANK
ACCOUNTS.
SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
INSIDE A DOMESTIC BONDS THAT.
NEAR NO NOBODY'S LOOKING AT ARE
THEY BEING PROSECUTED FOR THE
CRYING.
JUST IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS WE'VE
I'VE SEEN.
PROBABLY ABOUT TEN CASES.
WHERE THE PERSON WAS?
ONLY CHARGED WITH A VIOLATION OF
THE RESTRAINING ORDER BUT NOT
PROSECUTED FOR THE ACTUAL CRIME
ONE OF MY LATEST THE ABUSER
AMBUSHED HER THE DAY AFTER SHEEP
WE WILL START WITH THE
RESTRAINING ORDER.
AND STRANGLED HER ON HER FRONT
PORCH THE NEIGHBORS CALL ON
FORCE.
HE WAS ONLY CHARGED WITH A
VIOLATION BECAUSE THEY LOOK THE
THING HE HAD ANOTHER CASE
SOMEWHERE ELSE THERE LIKE HE'S
GONNA GO TO JAIL ANYWAY.
HE'S NOT CHARGE FOR THE CRIME
AGAINST HER.
SO IT'S THESE LITTLE THINGS THAT
SLIPPED THROUGH THE CRACKS.
OR THE ARE THE ARE THE ARE THE
ELEMENTS OF THINGS THAT CAUSE
BARRIERS FOR VICTIMS.
WHAT JURISDICTION WAS AT AND
MISS BROWN --
NOTHING SHE LIVES ANA DEL PASO
HEIGHTS AREA ONE OF YOU KNOW
CARMICHAEL AREA.
SO I'VE STRUCTURE COUNTY IN.
THANK YOU AYE WHO WERE M. AND
THAT'S AGAIN THE PURPOSE OF OF
THESE HEARINGS TO HEAR THESE
DIFFERENT STORIES AND SCENARIOS.
UP BECAUSE WE HELPING THEM YET
SO WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHEN VISION OF WHAT
THIS IS BUT IT IT'S SO MUCH MORE
AND I THINK YOU APPRECIATE ABOUT
THE COMMENTS AND YOU KNOW AND
AGAIN MY MY STAFF IS HERE.
HE ONE LEAVE NUMBERS AND I
DEFINITELY --
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS WHEN
WE HAVE MORE HEARINGS SO THAT WE
CAN COME UP WITH IDEAS OF OF
PROPOSALS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
ARE.
YOU KNOW THAT'S AN AREA WHERE
THERE IS IS APPALLING YEAH THAT
I THINK.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE TRYING --
TO TO JUST CITING FIVE
VIOLATIONS THAT OF OF THE ACTUAL
CRME SO AGAIN PLEASE --
YOU KNOW REACH OUT TO US AND WE
WILL GIVE YOU INFORMATION SO
THAT WE CAN COME UP WITH ACTUAL
TANGIBLE SOLUTION SOOTHING AND
YOU KNOW AND IT'S NEVER ABOUT
POINTING OUT WHAT SOMEBODY DID
WRONG OVER HERE SOMEBODY DIVINE
I HEAR IT'S COLLECTIVELY ACROSS
OUR COUNTY IN IN OUR STATE.
JUST REALLY HONING DOWN ON WHAT
IS THE BIGGEST ISSUES THAT WE
ARE OVERLOOKING OR THAT'S NOT
DIDN'T TALK OR NOT GET AND
SHOWED OR NOT GET ADDRESS SO
THAT WEEK ALL TOGETHER
COLLECTIVELY CAN SAY HEY.
LET'S.
GET RID OF THIS THIS IS NOT OKAY
AND MOVE ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
THIS IS MY SON JOHN.
MY DOLLAR AUTUMN IS SITTING BACK
HERE MANY MISS ACTUALLY.
SHERRY I AM NOT HERE IN
REPRESENTATION OF ANY AGENCY I'M
ACTUALLY HERE REPRESENTATION OF
pMY LITTLE FAMILY AND OTHER
FAMILIES LIKE MINE --
ALTHOUGH I DO CURRENTLY WORK FOR
A RAPE CRISIS CENTER WITHIN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M AGAIN
NOT HERE IN REPRESENTATION OF
THEM.
BUT LIKE SO MANY OTHERS HERE IN
THE I WAS MOVED I'M ALMOST
BROUGHT TO TEARS AT ONE POINT AS
ONE SO MANY THINGS --
THAT OTHERS ON THE PANELS WERE
--
SHARING WITH YOU ALL THAT MY
LITTLE FAMILY HAS GONE THROUGH
AND EVEN IN SOME WAYS IT'S STILL
GOING THROUGH I'M I THINK THE
CONSISTENCY I AM NOT A LOT OF
THE PANELS.
PANELIST ARM EMPHASIZED WAS
HOWELL ON THE COMING OUT EVEN
NOW THE AFTER NOT HAVING THE
IMMEDIATE BEING IN THE IMMEDIATE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOW YOUR LIFE
IS STILL.
SO DRASTICALLY IN DRAMATICALLY
AFFECTED AND MYSELF AS A SINGLE
MOTHER ON ONE OF MY ARM.
BIGGEST THINGS EVERYDAY IS I'M
TRYING TO MAKE A BETTER LIFE FOR
THIS NEXT GENERATION THAT MY
CHILDREN ARE PART OF BECAUSE
WHEN IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE AND
WE THAT WERE SITTING HERE AS
ADULTS.
ARE IN THE GROUND AND OUR DAYS
ON THIS EARTH ARE GONE THESE ARE
GOING TO BE THE ONES THAT ARE
GONNA BE FOLLOWING IN OUR
FOOTSTEPS AND THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON WHY I BROUGHT MY CHILDREN
TODAY I WANTED THEM TO SEE
FIRSTHAND.
THAT YOU CAN OME AND YOU CAN
TAKE THE STEPS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO TRY TO CHANGE THE
THINGS THAT YOU HAVE GONE
THROUGH AND JUST EVEN --
ONE THING THAT REALLY JUST STOOD
OUT TO ME THAT HAS BEEN AND HAD
BEEN A STRUGGLE FOR US IS THAT
ALL WERE ABUSER --
WAS ABLE TO UTILIZE BECAUSE HE
HAD MORE MONEY THAN WE DID WAS
ABLE TO UTILIZE THE COURT
SYSTEMS.
AS A MEANS TO BE ABLE TO ABUSE
US ARM HE WAS ABLE TO FILE FOR
WHATEVER HE WANTED WHICH MEANT
THAT.
I WOULD HAVE TO SHOW UP A COURT.
AND THAT MEANT THAT I HAD TO BE
IN THE SAME ROOM WITH HIM AND
THAT MEET MY CHILDREN HOW TO BE
IN THE SAME ROOM HE WAS ABLE TO
FILE.
FOR READING OF REUNIFICATION
THERAPY AND DIFFERENT THINGS
LIKE THAT WHICH REQUIRED ME TO
HAVE TO BRING MY CHILDREN TO
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT.
AND THEN BE THERE HE ACTUALLY
IMPORTS BUSH DOES IN THE LOBBY
PAID SOMEONE TO AMBUSH US IN THE
LOBBY AND NO.
ONE NOT EVEN THAT THIS THAT THE
SHARE OF STANDING THERE CAME TO
OUR AID.
AND THEN AFTER THAT.
I HAD TO WALK INTO COURT.
WORRIED ABOUT HER SAFETY.
TRY TO DEFEND OUR FAMILY WHEN HE
HAD AN ATTORNEY HAD THE MONEY
HAD EVERYTHING THAT HE NEEDED
AND I HAD TO STAY AND TRY TO
STAY COMPOSED BECAUSE ALL THE
WHILE.
OUR ABUSER WAS TRYING TO USE
THAT AS A MEANS TO SHOW THAT I
WAS EMOTIONALLY UNSTABLE
[inaudible]
AND SO THROUGHOUT ALL THE YEARS
THAT WE WENT THROUGH THIS
ONGOING ABUSE AFTER EVEN GETTING
OUT OF THE IMAGE IMMEDIATE
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE --
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO GO AND SEEK
OUT [inaudible]
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE OUR
CONFIDENTIALITY.
WAS NOTHING THERE WAS NOTHING IN
PLACE THAT THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
OR DOT.
COM REALLY SEEMED ALLOTTED TO US
BECAUSE EVEN WHEN WE WENT FOR
COUNTY SERVICES HE MANAGED TO
FIND A WAY LIKE SOMEONE OTHER
SAID IN HERE EARLIER.
ARM TO CONVINCE EVEN YOLO COUNTY
AIDS THAT WE WERE STILL TOGETHER
HE LIVED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE LIVE AND HAVE LEAD HERE BACK
HOME WHERE I GREW UP.
AND HAD EVEN APPLY FOR SERVICES
WITH US ON THE THING AND I HAD
NEVER BEEN OUT THERE.
HOW HE WAS ABLE TO DO THAT I
HAVE NO CLUE TO THE STATE BUT?
EVEN WITH THAT BEING SAID SO
WHILE WE WERE GETTING COUNTY
SERVICES OUT HERE AND HE WAS
GETTING COUNTY SERVICES OUT
THERE.
CLAIMING THAT WE WERE STILL
FAMILY TOGETHER LIVING TOGETHER
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I ENDED
UP HAVING TO PAY FOR WHAT HE
RECEIVED.
MY WAGES WERE GARNISHED.
I HAD BEEN WORKING MULTIPLE JOBS
IN MIND YOU HAD LOST MANY JOBS
BECAUSE HE WAS ABLE TO UTILIZE
THE SYSTEM TO PULL ME INTO COURT
ALMOST ONCE A WEEK ON A REGULAR
BASIS FOR YEARS.
JUST ONGOING ONGOING ONGOING
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE SO MANY FAMILIES LIKE
MINE ARE GOING THROUGH BECAUSE
EVEN SOMETHING AS AS SMALL BUT
AS GRAND AS CONFIDENTIALITY WE
WERE UNABLE TO REACH OUT. TO
EVEN GET EMOTIONAL SERVICES
TAKING CARE BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOTHING IN PLACE THAT WOULD
PREVENT IT OUR ABUSER FROM USING
THAT AGAINST ME.
AS A MEANS OF WEAKNESS TO SHOW
UP SHE'S EMOTIONALLY UNSTABLE.
YOU CAN'T HOW CAN YOU GRANT
CUSTODY TO THESE CHILDREN YOUR
HONOR IF.
SHE'S EMOTIONALLY UNSTABLE SO
EVEN AFTER ALL OF THESE YEARS
AND HASN'T REALLY BEEN THAT
LONG.
WHAT'S IN PLACE FOR PEOPLE LIKE
US WHO HAVE THAT FEAR THAT WE
CAN'T REACH OUT TO THESE
DIFFERENT SERVICES BECAUSE OUR
CONFIDENTIALITY MAY BE BROKEN
BECAUSE THAT MAY PUT US IN FEAR.
YOU BETTER BELIEVE THAT MY
CHILDREN AT NINE ELEVEN THEY
KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO HAVE
TO RUN THEY KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO HAVE TO LIVE IN A CAR
BECAUSE WE WERE IN A SYSTEM
WHERE THE COUNTY DIDN'T GIVE US
ENOUGH MONEY. TO ALLOW US TO BE
ABLE TO GET OFF OF AID AND
ACTUALLY LIVE LIKE HUMAN BEINGS
WE LIVE WITHIN A SYSTEM WHERE
THAT COUNTY SYSTEM ACTUALLY MADE
US FEEL LIKE WORSE THAN WHAT WE
DID WHEN WE WERE BEING ABUSED.
AN HOUR ABUSER HE LITERALLY USED
TO RATION OUT THE AMOUNT OF FOOD
AND WATER THAT WE COULD CONSUME
SO TO SAY THAT A COUNTY SYSTEM
WHICH WE WERE WITHIN YOLO
COUNTY.
MADE US FEEL LESS THAN EVERY
TIME I HAD TO WALK IN THAT DOOR
EVERY TIME I HAD TO MAKE A PHONE
CALL EVERYTIME I HAD THE
QUESTIONER ASKED ABOUT.
IF WE COULD WERE ALLOTTED
SERVICES AND I WON'T EVEN GET
STARTED ON HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS
TO NOT ONLY GET.
FUNDING FOR CHILDCARE TO EVEN
MAINTAIN A JOB WITHIN THE COUNTY
SYSTEM BUT TO MAINTAIN THAT
[inaudible]
HORRENDOUS.
HOW MANY TIMES MY CHILDREN
WATCHED THEIR MOTHER SPOKEN
DOWN?
TO TALK TO ACT BELITTLED.
SO I SAY ALL THAT TO SAY THIS IF
WHEN YOU WALL ARE CONSIDERING
THESE LAWS CONCERNING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND INCREASES IN GRANTS
AND WHICH GRANTS YOU'RE GONNA
PLACE WHERE IF YOU COULD TAKE
THE THINGS THAT NOT ONLY MYSELF
AND OTHERS IN THIS ROOM HAVE
SPOKEN OUT ABOUT INTO.
GRAVE CONSIDERATION BECAUSE IT
IS A REAL THING IT IS A REALITY
IT SICKENS MY HEART TO THINK
THAT.
EVEN IN SPITE OF EVERYTHING THAT
I'VE DONE AND THAT I AM DOING IN
LIFE TO TRY TO CREATE STABILITY
FOR MY FAMILY.
EVEN WORKING A FULL TIME JOB
THAT DOESN'T EVEN ALLOW ME
ENOUGH MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN STABILITY AND CREATE
ONGOING STABILITY FOR MY
CHILDREN AND POSITIVE
CONSISTENCY.
I CAN'T REACH OUT TO A COUNTY
SERVICE BECAUSE I'M WOULD
CONSIDER HAVE BE CONSIDERED
MAKING TOO MUCH.
IF MY EXPERTISE TELL SUPPORT
CONSISTENTLY FOR A FEW MONTHS
THEN I'M DISQUALIFIED FROM
GETTING AID BECAUSE OF THAT BUT
YET WE'VE GONE THROUGH THAT AND
WE'VE LIVED IN OUR CAR.
BEING CONSIDERED MAKING TOO MUCH
BECAUSE THEIR MOTHER HAS A JOB
WHERE AS IF I DIDN'T HAVE A JOB
THEN SOCIETY SAYS TO ME.
I'M NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH ME
I NEED TO GET UP AND I NEED TO
GET A JOB SOCIETY SAYS TO ME I'M
JUST ANOTHER STATISTIC.
THAT FALLS IN THAT POVERTY LINE
IN THAT GAP.
OF IN THAT CLASS OF MINORITIES
THAT SIT AROUND AND WE JUST DO
NOTHING WHEN THAT'S NOT THE CASE
AND SO EVEN SITTING HERE TODAY.
I I WANT TO SHOW MY KIDS.
THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENT SIDE
THAT NOT ONLY CAN SOMETHING BE
DONE BUT THAT SOMEBODY WALKS THE
STAND UP AND LISTEN AND DO
SOMETHING SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE SAME
THINGS THAT I'VE GOING THROUGH
SO THAT EVEN THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WATCH THEIR MOTHER FOR THE REST.
OF HER LIFE HAVE TO KEEP
FIGHTING FIGHTING FIGHTING TO
JUST BARELY MAKE ENDS MEET THE
FACT THAT --
EVEN THAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING IN PLACE TO AID
WOMEN LIKE ME WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH STUFF LIKE THIS AND LIKE
I SAID I WORK FOR A RAPE CRISIS
CENTER RIGHT NOW.
WHO SERVICES THAT MY FAMILY
COULD UTILIZE WOULD WOULD HELP
US SO MUCH BUT I CAN'T EVEN
UTILIZED BECAUSE I WORK FOR THE
RAPE CRISIS CENTER?
AND NOT IS CONSIDERED NOT OKAY
WHEN IT PERTAINS TO THAT BUT
EVEN TAKING IN CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
FUNDING.
FOR TING SPECIFICALLY LIKE THAT
FOR PEOPLE LIKE US WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE'VE GOTTEN PAST THE
IMMEDIATE AND WE'VE BEEN OUT FOR
A LITTLE BIT AND OR EVEN A FEW
YEARS AND WE STILL HAVE THIS
TRAIL.
THAT IS ATTACHED TO US FROM THE
ABUSE THAT WE STILL NEED TO TAKE
CARE BUT WE CAN'T AFFORD
[inaudible]
TO BECAUSE I WANT MY CHILDREN TO
GROW OPEN HOUSE BUT I CAN'T
AFFORD THAT.
I WANT MY CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO
GET HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE
BUT MOST OF THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING NOT ONLY IS IT.
THAT ARE THE WAITING LIST
EXACERBATED BUT THERE IN SOME OF
THE MOST VIOLENT WORST
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND TO BE AND TO MY CHILDREN IT
SAYS.
YOU'RE NOT WORTH [inaudible]
LIVING LIKE.
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE WORLD GET TO
LIVE.
AND THEN I'M FIGHTING AND OTHER
PEOPLE LIKE ME ARE FIGHTING TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO STOP
THAT CYCLE SO THAT WEEK OUR
CHILDREN CAN HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE.
BECAUSE NOT EVERYBODY'S OUT
THERE BREAKING THE LAW AND NOT
FOR THE THING YOU KNOW AND
THAT'S NO PUN TOWARDS ANYONE
BECAUSE YOU HEY YOU GOTTA DO
WHAT YOU GOTTA DO IN ORDER TO
GET BY.
I KNOW I DID FOR MY CHILDREN
WHEN I HAD NOBODY I KNOW I STILL
DO [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK YOU FOR LISTENING I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME HERE
TODAY I THINK YOU FOR TAKING ALL
OF THIS INTO CONSIDERATION.
ARM.
I HOPE THAT LEAVING HERE
[inaudible]
ON THAT THE FACES OF MY CHILDREN
WILL BE EDGEDINTO YOU YOU ALSO
BRAIN WHEN YOU'RE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THESE DIFFERENT
LAWS THAT YOU'RE MAKING AND THE
COMING BECAUSE THEY VERY MUCH SO
AFFECT US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE JUST SO YOU KNOW I HAVE A
TENURE THAN AN ELEVEN YEAR OLD
SO I I CAN TELL THAT THERE THAT
THE SAME AGE AND EVEN THOUGH MY
SITUATION IS NOT THE SAME AS
YOURS --
TRUST AND BELIEVE THAT --
MY HEART AND I THINK ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATORS OUGHT LEGISLATORS
HEARTS ARE WITH YOU --
THERE'S MANY --
VERY DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS FOR
ALL OF US BUT I THINK WE ALL
CAME HERE TO HOPEFULLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF OF HOW
WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE OF
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE KIDS FOR
BRITAIN FOR BRINGING THE KIDS I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THEM
TO SEE THAT THERE IS PEOPLE THAT
ARE LISTENING.
AND IT MIGHT NOT BE IMMEDIATE
AND THE LIKE I SAID EARLIER
TODAY WITH A MAGIC WAND THAT
WE'RE GONNA FIX EVERYTHING BUT
LITTLE STEPS.
TOWARD THAT GOAL I THINK IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT SO THANK
YOU.
ONLY FEEL LUIS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF TWO ORGANIZATIONS I AM
PROUD REPRESENT THE FIRST THING
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE NAY HEARD
PREVIOUSLY ABOUT HOW INTERNET
LEADERS HAVE FREEDOM FROM
VIOLENCE AS A CORE TENET OF WHAT
IT TRULY MEANS.
TAP CHOICE WHEN YOU CHOOSE TO
HAVE A FAMILY IS YOUR FAMILY
ABLE TO BE SAFE IS YOUR HOME
ABLE TO BE SAFE ARE YOU ABLE TO
ACCESS THE SERVICES AND
RESOURCES.
NEEDED TO PROTECT THE CHILDREN
EAT YOU HOP AND SO WE THINK
ABOUT REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE WE
HAVE TO THINK OF IT COMPLETELY
ALIGNED WITH WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
SAFE IN YOUR COMMUNITY SAFE IN
YOUR HOME.
SAFE GETTING TO WORK AND WHEN WE
TALK WITH SPECIAL OR YOU KNOW AT
RISK POPULATIONS IN THOSE WHO.
HAVE IMMIGRATED HERE.
IS YOUR DOCUMENTATION STATUS
BEING USED AS A MECHANISM TO
CONTROL.
AND THOSE TYPES OF FREEDOMS ARE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT IN REALLY ENSURE THAT
WE'RE HAVING DIVERSE VOICES.
AND EXPERIENCES WHICH IS WHY
HAVING SO MANY PEOPLE SPEAK
TODAY IS SO VITAL SO THINKING
FOR A TIME YOU KNOW BE RECEPTIVE
AND YOU KNOW WE KNOW ON THESE
ISSUES.
MANY OF YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN YOU
KNOW ALLIED WITH WOMEN'S
ORGANIZATIONS WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS --
SECOND ORGANIZATION IS CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING IN
WORKING WITH CONSUMER GROUPS AND
COALITIONS ON WHAT IT MEANS TO
HAVE.
ECONOMIC ACCESS YOU'VE HEARD
PERSONAL STORIES OF PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR JOBS HAVING THOSE
THREATENS WHAT IT MEANS TO
ACCESS.
MONEY WHEN YOU NEED IT BECAUSE I
HAVE.
ACCESS TO CREDIT ACCESS TO
SOMETHING SEPARATE ACCOUNT AWAY
FROM YOUR ABUSER THOSE ARE
PATHWAYS TO FREEDOM WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN YOU'RE
ACCESSING THEM THAT THEY'RE DONE
IN A JUST WAY.
AND THEN NOT YOU'RE NOT BEING
YOUR VULNERABILITIES NOT BEING
EXPLOITED BY BAD BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND PEOPLE WHO ARE.
YOU KNOW JEOPARDIZING WHETHER
IT'S LOANS ON YOUR CAR HOW YOU
GET RENTS PAID WHETHER YOU'RE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW PROTECT
YOURSELF FROM EVICTION THOSE
THINGS ARE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
AND WE HAVE TO THINK OF THE
VULNERABILITIES THAT GO ALONG
WITH THAT RISK POPULATIONS --
UP BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT HAPPEN
TO GET SOMEWHERE IN FRONT OF THE
STATE IS THAT OF A FAMILY MEMBER
HILL.
YOU LEFT A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION.
AND TO WATCH.
YOU KNOW COUSIN HAVE TO LEAVE
WORK.
AFTER STEP AWAY FROM HER FULL
LIFE.
BUT SHE ASKED FOR HELP.
AND SO TO HAVE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS
AVAILABLE TO PULL THEM OUT.
NOT EVERYBODY HAS THAT.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
THOSE.
ACTIONS AREN'T THERE.
WHAT'S AVAILABLE AS A LOBBYIST
WE HAVE DIFFERENT ACCESS AND
KNOWING PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS
TO POWER YOU KNOW IF WE CAN WALK
TO OFFICES.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME FOR PEOPLE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITIES SO JUST
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE CAN TO TO IN
TO HELP DELIVER THE MESSAGES.
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
SMART RESOURCES AND I WERE
LISTENING TO SERVICES THAT
REALLY HAVE AN IMPACT AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO US LAND FOR MY MANY
HATS THAT I WEAR BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HER ID WELL THIS IS A A GREAT
LIKE I SAID EARLIER THAT WE'RE
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS BUT
IT ALSO IS OVERWHELMING I'M NOT
GOING.
TO I SIT HERE AND SAY THAT IT'S
NOT BECAUSE MY YOU KNOW I NIGHT
I'M ASSUMING THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY GOES THROUGH THE SAME
THING WHERE ALL THESE IDEAS
START POPPING INTO OUR HEAD AND
YOU KNOW REALISTICALLY THERE'S
ONLY SO MUCH.
THAT WE CAN DO AT A CERTAIN TIME
AND SO AGAIN I'M LOOKING --
FOR DIRECTION FROM YOU AND FROM
HELP FOR HELP SO THAT WHEN WE
ARE PREPARING FOR OUR NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WE CAN COME
UP WITH IDEAS THAT ARE.
ARE ARE TANGIBLE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT MUCH --
THE THE AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TO MAKE --
SMALL CHANGES SO I THINK YOU
AGAIN FOR A ALLOWING US --
TO BRING YOU ALL TOGETHER SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND WITHOUT
--
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU AGAIN --
SOON AND I ACTUALLY --
HAVING SOME OUTCOMES FROM THESE
CONVERSATIONS SO WITH THAT I'LL
I'LL GO AHEAD AND ADJOURN --
OUR MEETINGS UNTIL NEXT SENSE OF
THINK YOU